hey this is angrew brown over here at
exam Pro bringing you another complete
study course and this time it's the
GitHub foundations certification this
one's all about GitHub and practicing
some of your git skills and this is a
great certification if you're looking to
show your developer skills in the cloud
or Tech the way we're going to help you
get the certification as always is the
lecture content doing Hands-On labs and
giving you that free practice exam so
you can go as that exam get that
certification and put it on your resume
I want to point out if you love these
kinds of courses the best way to support
more free study courses is to buy the
paid additional materials that is
optional but you'll get uh things like
cheat sheets U more pratice exams and
other things like that so I just want to
tell you that I've taught a lot of
different kinds of certifications in
cloud and in Tech you name it I've
taught it we got adab us Azure gcp
terraform kubernetes and more more and
obviously now GitHub and if you're
wondering why I'm in a snowsuit it's
because my office it's really cold it's
like7 so this is how it has to be but I
will see you in class in two seconds
[Music]
ciao hey this is angrew Brown from exam
Pro and we're at the start of our
journey asking the most important
question first which is what is the
GitHub Foundation certification well it
is an entrylevel GitHub certification
teaching you Git Version Control Basics
working with GitHub repos collaboration
features modern development project
management uh GitHub privacy Security
Administration GitHub community and open
source now I put in Git Version Control
Basics but uh they don't really required
in the uh certification itself but you
will implicitly learn them as you work
through uh this course The Unofficial
course code uh for the certification is
ghf because there are no course codes uh
that GitHub has published so I've used
the um small initial initializations
that they use on their um certification
page GitHub is the leading uh Version
Control service in the world it's one of
the most common ways for developers to
Showcase their code uh if you go for
developer interviews a lot of times
people want to have your GitHub link so
they can see your activity um and your
code so who's the certification for well
consider this certification if you are
new to Cloud programming and need to
learn Version Control fundamentals um
more like Version Control workflows
online I I would be better to say uh
you're a non-developer uh at Tech role
so you are in Tech but you're just a
non-developer looking to quickly add
developer skills uh you want to be
effective uh collaborating on code bases
with other developers this GitHub
certification will not test your git
skills it's focused on GitHub you will
use git but you may have serious gaps in
git knowledge um to be used in a uh work
or production environment so make sure
you polyfill that information where you
can um in terms of the road map they
have four certifications the foundation
the advanced security the actions the
admin and this is where I would put them
in terms of difficulty they don't um
categorize them into levels but uh you
level 100 I would say the foundations is
is very easy um the advanced security I
put it at 150 because it looks like an
extension of the foundations focusing on
the security features actions is very
technical so a level 200 makes sense an
admin is I wouldn't say hard but it goes
into Enterprise so it's harder to get
access to the Enterprise account and
test it out and you have to understand
Enterprise Concepts so I put it the
level
300 uh there's a lot of different routes
you could take you could go from the
level 100 uh or sorry the get
foundations to Advance Security to the
admin or the foundations to the actions
to me the advanced security seems like
such little effort to do that it seems
like a good follow-up or something you
should do at the same time uh if the
content's available to to um study when
doing GI GitHub foundations uh if you're
looking for particular roles you could
probably say the cloud security engineer
is where you'd go for the advanced
security so You' start with the
foundations for all of them go there if
you want to be a cloud developer GitHub
actions is super useful because it's a
cicd pipeline and it's becoming one of
the most popular cicd pipelines out
there if you're an Enterprise engineer
then the administrator is good for
having that Enterprise knowledge if
somebody wants to run GitHub uh there
but you know these are just titles
you're not going to actually have that
role from completing these
certifications it's just part of uh
content for those particular roles um
get up certifications do not validate
programming technical diagramming code
management other technical skills that
are required for obtaining technical
roles so just understand the limitations
of these certifications they are useful
for learning but understand that uh it
it stops at a certain place okay how
long should you take to pass if if
you're a beginner uh and you've never
used GitHub before and you've never used
git or written code before and you're
new to to Cloud in Tech maybe 20 hours
um there is no uh historical information
about this certification because it's
brand new and I'm the first one with a
study course out so we'll say 20 hours
is a sufficient amount of time uh for
experienced folks um if you have
practical knowledge working with GitHub
if you have technical knowledge working
with Git uh you have strong background
in technology worked in a technical
developer role it's going to be 4 hours
if you're an if you're in a technical
role but just not a developer you might
be more in the middle um and so I would
probably say 14 hours of average study
time 50% lecture 50% Labs uh or sorry
50% lecture in labs and then 50%
practice exams that's usually always the
same thing I always say and one to two
hours a day for 14 days if it's 14 hours
you can do an hour a day and you'll be
in really really good shape what does it
take to pass the exam watch the video
lecture and memorize key information
this exam in particular is very fact
toal and unfairly so so make sure where
I call out fact toal information to
memorize it because it is silly and
you'll lose points for that do the
Hands-On Labs it's going to really help
cement how all this stuff works together
and even though the exams don't really
require it I I want you to have that
knowledge and I want you to have an
easier time passing so please do the
follow follow alongs do paid online
practice exams because this one in
particular again it's very fact toal and
you need to see some variations so you
don't get caught off guard if you think
that you go through my course and go I'm
really good at GitHub now uh you'll be
thrown a bunch of Enterprise questions
and stuff that you didn't think that
would be there and in particular what
information's there so make sure you
utilize practice exams make sure you
utilize my free practice exam which will
come out with this um and you'll do fine
again not a hard exam but you know I
don't want you to be frustrated on that
exam losing out some particular points
because you didn't know that you had to
know the uh uh the lineup of GitHub work
uh workflow actions inside of uh GitHub
projects or something like that there
are seven domains for this certification
and I need to point out that for some
reason GitHub uh does not share the
waiting of each domain most exams do
that and my experience when I sat the
exam it was kind of imbalance where I
had a lot of Enterprise questions so
just understand that you might not even
see a question in the domain that you
are expecting or you might have very few
a lot in other areas I don't know why
they did this it was a bad choice but
that's what they did we have seven
domains we have support uh GitHub
Enterprise for users and key
stakeholders uh domain two manage user
identities and GitHub authentication uh
domain three describe how GitHub is
deployed distributed and licens domain
four manage access and permissions based
on membership domain five ensure or
sorry enable secure software development
and ensur compliance domain six manage
GitHub actions domain seven benefit of
benefits of the GitHub Community there's
no development stuff in here but I've
crammed in the exam development stuff
because you really should know
development stuff and GitHub is a
developer platform for some reason they
decided not to include it in here but I
feel that it really makes it easier to
utilize GitHub if you know the developer
tools uh where do you take this exam at
an in-person test center or online from
the convenience of your own home GitHub
delivers it with PSI um so PSI has an
online version and then they have a a
bunch of test networks that they
partnered with um it is a it it is a
proctored exam so there's somebody
that's supposedly watching your exam so
that you do not cheat I just want to
warn you PSI is not known for having a
good test experience when I saw at my
exam um uh I was 30 minutes early
checked
in and uh I waited 40 minutes after my
check-in time because it said it was
connecting me to a special specialist it
never did I had to contact support they
uh they made me uh fill in a bunch of
information which seemed weird because
they should know who I am already cuz
I'm in their app and then they told me
oh I'm not actually connected to anybody
and so the app lies to you so don't get
stressed out if you have technical
issues with PSI it's extremely common
and uh if you're doing it online if you
can do a test center I strongly
recommend doing so because it just makes
the whole experience a lot less
stressful from the environment
perspective from uh the technology
perspective but if you got to do online
just uh don't stress out and understand
that everybody has these issues uh
doesn't make sense but everyone has
these issues and not to not to to sweat
it or throw you off before your exam
starts in terms of grading they don't
give us a grade GitHub does not provide
a passing score we don't know how many
points there are we do know how many
questions there are but uh for some
reason they've decided not to provide
that information uh they say in their
FAQ because they can't exactly calculate
it they don't want to give you an
inaccurate number it really makes no
sense but I'm going to tell you that you
still will pass pass this exam it's not
that hard but yeah you just have to make
sure that you can get get as many points
on those fact total questions and don't
stress out about not knowing what your
passing score is there are 75 questions
in this exam 60 scored 15 unscored so
you can afford to get 15 questions wrong
at least there is no penalty for wrong
questions at least as far as I'm aware
of and I saw U both multiple choice and
multiple answer uh sometimes it was
choose two choose three it was never
more than three there wasn't that many
multiple answer uh like basically
multiple select ones so it wasn't that
bad don't stress out about the unscored
questions because there's 15 of them
they don't count towards your exam why
is there unscored questions uh they're
used to evaluate the introduction of new
questions to determine if the exam is
too easy and the passing score or
question difficulty needs to be
increased to discover users who are
attempting to cheat the exam or still
dump exam questions if you encounter
questions you've never studied for that
seem really hard keep your cool and
remember they may be unscored questions
the duration of this exam is 2 hours so
you get 1.6 minutes per question so that
exam time in minutes is 120 Minutes your
C time is uh 30 minutes or sorry 150
minutes because you add 30 minutes there
when I say see time that's the time you
need to go in and check in and re review
the instructions and get your workspace
set up and sign the NDA and show them
your space um provide feedback at exam
uh I was able to check in 30 minutes
online
prior you you probably want to be 45
minutes prior to your exam okay so give
yourself a few minutes to get set up and
try to check in early sometimes they let
you start exams early right so even if
you're scheduled for 5 uh sometimes 5
minutes after your check-in you can
start and get rolling on it but uh yeah
there you go and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
ciao hey everyone it's Andrew Brown in
this uh video I want to show you uh
where you can get uh the exam guide and
other additional information so you can
understand where I'm getting this stuff
and make sense of it yourself and you
might hear my space space heater here I
have the tiny space heater to keep my
feet warm my hands warm so sorry if the
background noise picks up but let's go
take a look so the way you can get to
this is you just type in
G.I certifications love the short link
by the way and I mean they have stuff
down here below but what you really got
to do is go to register and then connect
your account and it'll do something with
GitHub and then you'll see this stuff
here okay now I want to point out that
um they have an FAQ down
below uh I guess they have a candidate
handbook which is something I don't even
sure if I open that
[Music]
up this is more about like how to run
stuff
yeah okay not really useful but um what
we're looking for is the exam guides
okay so if we were to go into the
foundations which is this is the
certification we're focused on you can
see the price here it says you pass with
the exam of 82% hooray I actually can
see my score now I didn't know where
that was you can't see
it I'm trying to move my head here not
sure why uh it's not letting me do that
there we go and so I actually got an 82%
which is pretty good considering I
thought I flubbed a bunch of questions
but that's pretty good remember there is
no study course or practice exams before
I took this um so that's great but they
really should tell us the the non-p
passing score so if we go down H to
FAQ
okay and we look up passing
score since there are multiple versions
of the certification exam the passing
score can have minor variances depending
on which version you take to ensure the
Integrity of exams to avoid confusion on
why there is a small variance will not
provide you a specific total score and I
mean I think that's kind of a failure of
uh any kind of certification program I
think that would be very frustrating for
the person taking the exam not knowing
what the score is but again again I
passed it so I'm just telling you like
you will pass it but understand that
they're just not going to tell you what
it is at least not at this time so
that's one thing that I found uh stood
out there but let's go back over to here
and we have the learning path which is
on Microsoft learn they might have some
content that um that gets covered a
little bit differently here I found it
not to be uh very good but there was
some stuff about like Enterprise um that
I don't really go much more into detail
where they're talking about like
bringing identities it might be
this right so again I didn't I didn't
look at this until afterwards so yeah I
don't really go this full top into this
um I do like UFA but um you know you
might want to top off in that one
section here but the rest I don't know
about the rest like in terms of quality
it's it's not uh it's not there um so
let's go into the study
guide and we'll just open that
up okay and we have our domains so we
have our seven domains and if we go and
scroll on
down we can see they have git and GitHub
Basics so they have like a little bit
about expect you know about git like
commit and
branching um I made sure to include
other things like what is
remote uh I don't know I have a big list
of it it's in the uh we have a uh a git
and GitHub quick and dirty crash course
to get you through all that stuff we
have uh GitHub ident identities so
understanding the different types of
accounts GitHub markdown what's unusual
is like they talk about GitHub markdown
but they don't talk about GitHub
flavored markdown really odd they have a
markdown section but not that GitHub
flavored markdown Is Amazing by the way
you have GitHub desktop you have GitHub
mobile um coming down here all about how
to work with GitHub repos um how to work
with issues how to work with pull
requests how to work with discussions
how to work with notifications I don't I
even got a question on notifications on
my exam uh gists wikis and GitHub Pages
nothing on GitHub Pages surprised it
didn't promote that a bit more I really
like GitHub Pages we have GitHub actions
um in this for GitHub actions you know
you need to know a little bit about the
syntax of the file because I was getting
very specific questions about that um
co-pilot so we have co-pilot we have
code spaces I actually was surprised how
little there was on codes spaces but I
do do a very thorough CH job of covering
codes spaces with us because we need to
you utilize it to be effective and so we
get a lot more knowledge in that than
expected we have uh GitHub projects um
it's weird because they say GitHub
projects but it's really project
management so like labels and Milestones
aren't specific to GitHub projects so I
kind of broke that up into a different
area there and there was some other
things that were Project Specific that
um um that I uh that I had to put in
here and things that I didn't what's
weird about GitHub projects is they need
they want you to know very specific
things like they want you to know um the
types of built-in workflows right the
types of of charts and that kind of
threw me off because they seem so
trivial to know but they asked you in
the exam so I was surprised this thing
is not specific to GitHub projects I'm
not sure why they put it in there um but
anyway and this this as well so I'm not
sure why these are in here or even
create template repos these all these
here shouldn't be in this section but
they are uh we have privacy priv privacy
Security Administration so we have a few
here uh for uh security then we have
GitHub admin rtion I might call it
administrator I'm not sure why but I
might messed that up this is supposed to
be about like the management of your
repo I actually covered a lot of it in
the GitHub repo section so I end up
repeating the content a little bit we
have the benefits of the GitHub
community so knowing what sponsors is
what is open source what is github's
relationship with open source um inner
source and there you go so yeah I would
say that again it's not a hard exam um
and I really make sure that you're super
prepared for it just make sure you do do
uh uh some practice exams just so you
don't get caught off and lose some
points on that factal information but
there you go
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown I'm just
going to do one ask of you if you can uh
if you if you like this course and it
helped you out they have this program
called GitHub stars and they basically
recognize people that did good work uh
uh promoting GitHub or educating and
communities I think I'm doing that
because I'm making a free course and if
you want to do me a favor you can go get
here to the nominate up at stars.
github.com you can say I nominate and it
would be like Omen King because it would
be something about the actual uh you
know like I taught you GitHub and you
thought that was really great and I
really great greatly appreciate that and
you know maybe that way I will go make
more of GitHub content and we can help
the community more so there you
[Music]
go hey this is angrew brown and we are
taking a look at Version Control Systems
which are designed to track changes or
revisions to code and there's been a lot
of software over the years that helped
us do that we had CVS aers mercal and
get so back uh in 1990s when we got
CVS though even though we had it I don't
think a lot of companies were using it
it took some time to adopt if you ever
heard of like Doom or Wolfenstein you'd
be uh interested to learn they didn't
use Version Control Systems and what
they would do is they would literally
copy files onto floppies and hope that
they don't lose their files but of
course AV Version Control Systems makes
it really easy to not worry about losing
floppies or CDs or drives because they
keep track of all the history then came
subversion in 2000 but the real game
Cher was in 2005 when we were introduced
to a new type A version control system
and we had Mercurial and get um but the
key difference between the old ones and
the new ones was the old ones were
centralized and the new ones were
decentralized and these decentralized
ones became very popular for very
specific reason reasons they had full
local history and complete control of
the repo locally they were
straightforward and efficient for
branching and merging which was a really
big deal uh better performance improve
fall tolerance flexible workflows work
fully offline um and out of the two git
was the one that won and there are
reasons for that we'll talk about that
when we look at version control services
um but uh yeah git is the one that
everybody is using today and that's why
we are taking this course I just want to
point out they're going to come across a
lot of terms that sound like trees tree
trunk branches um the reason for this is
that Version Control represents um the
revisions or changes in a graph-like
structure you can even say a dag um if
you're familiar with that and so uh you
know you'll see these terms and we're
not talking about real trees we're
talking about uh the components of a
verion control so there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at git so git is a
distributed Version Control System a
dvcs that's going to be hard to remember
uh and it's created by lonus torold if
you've ever seen that name before you
might know that lonus is the creator of
the Linux kernel but he is also the
creator of git and git right now resides
with the Linux Foundation which I
believe is a nonprofit set up by Linus
as well or has some a part to do with it
where a lot of Open Source projects
reside um but you know I don't really
want to focus on that I want to focus on
the practicalities of git so the idea
with Git is that each change of your
code a git commit can be captured and
tracked through the history of your
project a git tree so I'm going to get
my pen tool out here for just a second
and so I just want to make this very
clear so we have over here a file and a
get commit can or a commit can be made
up of multiple files with multiple
changes in them and then they're
represented over with a a a message okay
so here this is a single um git commit
and it can have multiple files and uh
files and changes in that single one and
then that's your tree okay so hopefully
that is clear if it's not don't worry
we'll get Hands-On skills and we'll
definitely be able to remember them
later I want to take a look at a bunch
of common get terms um and it doesn't
matter if you remember these now but you
will know what they are hopefully by the
end of this course um and so there is
this nice graphic here that is provided
by Wikipedia that gives an idea of how
all of these terms uh work together uh
but let's go quickly through them and
see what we can make sense of so the
first term is a repository this
represents the logical container holding
the codebase in fact you you could
interchange the word codebase repository
and mostly mean the same thing we have a
Commit This represents a change of data
in the local
repository and so um that's pretty clear
then we have the tree this represents
the entire history of a of a repo so
when you see tree just think of that
graph we have remote uh this is a
version of your project hosted elsewhere
used for exchanging commits uh some
people might be a bit uh picky about
this because they might say remote is
actually a remote reference to a
repository so it's pointing it's a
pointer but I'm just going to make it
think that it's a remote uh repo it's
just somewhere else and there uh there
are branches so these are Divergent path
to development allowing isolate Chang
you're absolutely going to know what
branches are you're absolutely going to
have to work with them quite a bit um
there is a branch known as Maine it was
formerly known as Master uh the word was
changed because it was not a popular
term anymore and so now main is the new
name uh and this is usually the default
Branch or the base
Branch uh if that makes sense there too
so we have clone this creates a complete
local copy of a repository including its
history so this will create like a
littleg folder um so it's not just the
contents of the files but some
configuration around the git repo we
have checkouts so this switches between
different branches or commits in your
repo we have pull so this downloads
changes from a remote repository merges
them into your branch we have push this
uploads your local repository changes to
a remote repository we have fetch this
downloads data from a remote repo
without integrating it into your work um
we have reset so undoes local changes
without options to unstage revert
commits we have merge this combines
multiple commit histories into one we
have staging files this prepares and
organizes uh changes for commits it's
not a command but like it's just where
you would work with your files um in the
uh example here I'm just going to get my
pen tool out again it's kind of over
here it has to relate with this up here
as well and So within staging files
we're going to have commits which we
already talked about prior and then
there's that add command so adding
things that will get committed so
hopefully that makes sense and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
okay hey this is SRE Brown and we are
taking a look at version control
services and if you're thinking that we
already covered this it looks that way
but the other one was Version Control
Systems this one is version control
services and yes they have the same
initialism which is confusing but it's
very important to make that distinction
because those are two separate things so
version control services are fully
managed services that host your version
controlled repositories these Services
often have additional functionality
going Beyond just being a remote host
for your repos git is the most popular
and often the only choice for a VCS and
we often call these get only uh
providers get providers um I need to
also point out that some people call
version control services Version Control
Systems and vice versa and it just gets
really confusing so I did did my best to
make that clear distinction between the
two okay let's take a look at some vcs's
so the first here is GitHub and it's
owned by Microsoft it's the most popular
VCS uh due to offering uh due to its
ease of use offering and being around
the longest at least forgit um and
they've always been very developer
focused and super friendly uh GitHub is
primarily where open source projects are
hosted and offer Rich functionalities
such as issue tracking automation
pipelines and a host of other features I
remember the day GitHub came out and I
signed up for it because I was so done
with using subversion then came along
gitlab so gitlab was an emerging
competitor to GitHub and at the time had
unique features such as cicd Pipeline
and improve security measures this is no
longer the case as GitHub is now on par
with gitlab um but yeah at one point a
lot of people were looking at gitlab
then there's bit bucket this one is
owned by at laian you might have heard
of laian before because they are are uh
the same company that makes jira and
jira is the most commonly used project
manager uh for um people in Tech so you
know even though GitHub is really great
for developers a lot of companies still
use bitbucket and the interesting thing
about bitbucket was that they originally
hosted Mercurial so remember I said back
in 2005 mercal and get came out well
alatan adopted mercal GitHub adopted um
git and
git one and GitHub one and so what's
really interesting is that bitbucket
then eventually added git and then
sunsetted mercal so everything basically
is get now there is another provider
called sourceforge they're one of the
oldest places to host your source code
they existed before GitHub um and they
were the first uh to provide free of
charge um uh get repository hosting to
open source projects um the only thing
about Source Forge is that they never
really dominated because they just had
so many ads and bad practices and so it
just didn't work out for them they are
still around and a lot of Open Source
projects like to only host there they
might mirror make a copy to other
providers like GitHub um but for the
most part everybody's on GitHub um but
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown we are
taking a look at GitHub and this is a
version controlled service that
initially offered hosted manag remote
get repos and is expanded to provide
other offerings around hosted code bases
if you go look up what GitHub calls
themselves today they call themselves
like an AI uh developer powered platform
um it's really bizarre because they are
basically a host for uh for get repos
with extra stuff on top of it but I
guess since AI is so popular they got to
try right but let's take a look at all
the functionality that they have so we
have get repository hosting that is
their main bread and butter we have
project management tools issue tracking
PLL requests and code reviews GitHub
pages and wikis GitHub actions GitHub
co-pilot GitHub code spaces GitHub
Marketplace GitHub gists GitHub
discussions collaboration features for
organization organizations and teams API
access development so GitHub development
they have a GitHub CLI they have
sdks um we have security features autod
detecting credentials in repos they have
education specific things or course
automation like GitHub classroom and I'm
sure they have more uh we're going to
learn about all of these things because
this is what the GitHub course is about
to understand the full offering of
GitHub and to make best use of it and
just a fun fact is that GitHub was
originally built in Ruby on Rails Ruby
is my favorite language rails is my
favorite framework so I've been uh uh on
the the ride or the train since day one
with GitHub um so I know it pretty well
but let's jump into it
[Music]
okay hey everyone this is angrew brown
and this fall along I want to show you
how to set up UFA or multiactor
authentication we'll talk about it later
in the course but it's very important
that we get this set up early uh so we
get it out of the way and that's our
opportunity to also install a really
useful application called GitHub mobile
so I'm going to go into Google and just
type in GitHub mobile so we can take a
look and so what GitHub mobile is it's
an application that allows you to U
basically interact with um uh GitHub on
your phone but the major reason why I
want you to install it is because it's
also used as a uh authentication tool
for GitHub now you can use another tool
if you already have Google Authenticator
Microsoft authenticator aie you can use
what you want to use and you can
actually add both of them there but I
find the easiest way to um do UFA is to
use G uh GitHub mobile mobile so I
really do recommend that you install
it's for both Google Play and your Apple
phones I'm on screen for a second sorry
for the uh the upward camera I'm in
standing desk mode right now but the
idea is that you're looking for the app
it's literally just called I if you can
see it GitHub right so you want to
install that
application okay so here it's showing my
profile as I'm logged in here and this
will be what we use to log in or confirm
when we log in the future so what I'm
going to do is go up here I'm going to
turn off the video so I don't have to
look at my self and we're going to go
over
to um settings I would think and then
from here it' probably be under
passwords and authentication and so if
we scroll on down um I mean there is a
passwordless way of logging I have yet
to use that but what we're looking at is
the two Factor authentication I'm going
to go ahead and enable that now what's
interesting is that if you have a lot of
um open source contributions you have to
have UFA turned on so in my account they
turned it on for me they said I couldn't
use my GitHub account unless they turned
it on but we have this QR code so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
take a quick look here um I mean this is
one way of doing
it I guess we could do text message as
well let's go back here because I
thought if you had the GitHub mobile
application it would showed here but
since we have nothing attached we'll
have to attach something so I'm going to
go here I'm just going to carefully look
here and
um
you know what I'm going to do s no I'm
going to stick with the authenticator so
I already have aie installed um so I'm
going to use that I really like aie it's
by twilio and I find it is one of the
most light ways of um getting a
multiactor
authentication so I'm just going to show
you what it looks like again on my phone
but I really want to
use GitHub mobile but I'm really
surprised that they don't show that in
the setup
but yeah so for example this is uh aie
it's really simple you put in a pin and
then you can get into your actual codes
uh that rotate out um so you can go
install that it's in the Google Play
Store and
the iOS Apple Store but um I guess I'll
add that so what I'm going to do is scan
this QR code with my phone and all
phones can scan QR codes you just open
your photo app and hover over and it'll
pick it up you'll get a link and you'll
click through and then it'll ask you
what app you want to open with and so I
already have ai installed so I'm going
to click
aie if you want to see this again I'm
trying to show as much as I can on my
phone but it's asking me what app do I
want to open with aie after scanning
that code
right and I'll say uh this time yes and
then uh I have a pin so I'm have to
enter my pin
in
okay and ay opened but it didn't
automatically add it so what I'm going
to have to do in aie I'll just show you
this for a
second because I thought it would add it
but it didn't so I'm going have to say
add account at the top there's a little
drop down for for that okay so now it's
asking me to scan the QR code so I'm
going to do
that okay and so it's Brad it in here
and so now I have it here it says GitHub
and then my username I'm going to hit
save and so now I have a code and so
that's the code I need to enter in all
right so I'll just turn off my screen
and enter the code in as quick as I can
705 839 really doesn't matter if I tell
you this code out loud and now we have
our backup codes you should never share
your backup codes with anybody this is a
way that people can get into your
account um I really did not mean to show
them to you here I'll have to do some
editing to um hide them okay so I've
downloaded my codes and make sure you
print out these codes and you put them
somewhere safe and have it offline do
not have it online that's the whole
point so go get the special duang you
have permission to go buy some uh
stationary and put that in and put it
somewhere safe okay so I have mine
downloaded to my computer and I'll go
print it out later and what we'll do is
we'll go ahead and say I have saved my
recovery codes and so now it shows
GitHub mobile this is so silly the
GitHub mobile app on your phone can be
used as UFA enable it by installing the
GitHub mobile app so maybe the reason it
didn't work was because I didn't sign
into it so if I had signed into it
initially maybe we didn't have to do
this to begin with so what I'm going to
do is just go hit
done and I still think again it's easier
to use the GitHub mobile app so I'm
going to go and see if I can log out of
GitHub mobile and log into this other
account or maybe I can be logged into
both of them at the same time so I'm
opening up GitHub
here
and I'm just seeing if I can be logged
into
multiples so what I've noticed here I'm
logged in already I just want to show
you
something so here I am
in GitHub mobile and there's a little
Cog at the top so I'm going to click
that Cog and then I have my settings
right and I'm going to scroll on down
and there's I think that says accounts I
know I'm sorry about the glare so
there's accounts I'm going to click
accounts and it looks like that I can
add multiple accounts and that's what
I'm going to do okay so I'm going to go
ahead and hit add account and it's going
to ask me to sign in with GitHub okay so
I'm going hit the big white blob of a
button and then it's going to show this
here sign in with different account
so I'm going to go ahead and use a
different account and I'm have to enter
my uh username email and password so
just give me a moment
okay all right so I had to like email
myself my password because my my Dash
Lan wasn't letting me log in but once
you're there you're going to see the
that authentication code that it's going
to want so I'm going to go grab that
from aie and it's good to have ay
installed I like having it uh because
you can't use GitHub authenticator for
everything so I'm going to go real real
quick and put that code
in nope I missed it so I'm going to have
to try that again sometimes you miss it
you'll have to try it
twice
okay there we go it's going to ask uh to
get access to authorize It Go Down Below
say authorize GitHub that green button
there and it's signing me
in and it looks like I'm now in so I'm
now in here with my account I imagine I
can switch between the two what I'm
going to do is just turn off my screen
here and let's take a look and see if
this is showing up now so we'll give
this a refresh and there it is so it's
now configured so the idea here is that
you can also set the default so again I
would recommend GitHub mobile doesn't
hurt to have more than one but I find
this to be super convenient because um
it like when you go through this you
only have to enter in like two letters
it's a lot faster it'll it'll it'll jump
up on your screen whereas these other
authenticators will not not um so that's
my recommendation to you there and now
that we have two Factor we are in great
shape I'm going to just go back to Home
by clicking the octocat and uh that's it
so I'll see you in the next one okay
[Music]
ciao hey this is angre brown and in this
fall along I want to show you how to
create your own GitHub account every
single developer on the planet should
have a GitHub account because it's a
great way to Showcase your work uh we'll
talk about that later but you can see
that I'm already logged in here so I
already have a GitHub account and what
I'm going to do is log out and I'm going
to create a new one from scratch so here
we can see uh we can have multiple ones
um I'm going to just sign out of all of
my accounts here and let's go ahead and
create ourselves a new one so I'm not
sure remember I told earlier I told you
they're like the leading AI power
developer platform which is such a silly
term but um let's go ahead and see if we
can make a new one so just in case it's
a future and they've changed this
homepage I'm going to go up to sign up
and and I'm going to see if I can make
an account if I can find an email that
has not been used so far so I'm going to
type and your exam prod. so if you're
using Gmail so I can't use that one if
you're using Gmail you can use like plus
signs to um create multiple ones so like
my really really personal email don't
email me because I don't ever check this
one it's like Omen King gmail.com you'll
learn that my username on GitHub is Omen
King why is that I don't want to talk
about it it's like forever ago I made
this account like so long ago and I
really wish I could have got Andrew
Brown as my username but that's not what
it is and so I'm just going to go here
and say alt okay so this is a trick with
Gmail that you can do you can put a plus
alt on it or uh maybe a minus I'm not
sure but let's go ahead and see if that
works and I need to create a password so
I like to generate really strong
passwords um you can use whatever you
want I like to use hold on here I like
to use this site which is
the uh password generator plus password
generator.net um I should make a
disclaimer if this isn't insecure don't
use it blah blah blah but I'm pretty
sure it's fine so I'll us to go like 24
and get a nice long password um and I'll
just generate a few different ones off
screen here and I'm going to enter that
in okay so just generate out a few and
I'm going to drop this in on here okay
we're going to hit continue says it's
strong that's good and then I got to
choose my username so I probably can't
get Andrew
Brown and um so I need like another name
I'm going to try
Dono not available that's like my game
uh gamer uh tag on um steam so what's
another one that I could have uh we'll
just say Andrew Cloud can I get that one
so hard we'll just say Andrew WC Brown
Canon I get that there we go WC is my M
middle initials it doesn't stand for
water closet okay I know it looks like
that we'll go ahead and hit continue I
hit continue again and so now what I
need to do is do this verification
please solve this puzzle so we know
you're a real
person uh verify okay use the arrows to
rotate the object to the face in the
direction of the
hand okay use the arrows so I think I
have to make it face the same way match
the
angle okay uh this
way okay
there we
go create my
account and so now I need to open up
that email just give me a moment okay
all right so I've been waiting a few
minutes and I haven't seen anything and
I resent the code so maybe it doesn't
like emails that have that plus in there
it's totally possible so I might
actually have to go ahead and create a
new email which is quite the headache as
I've ran out of emails here uh unless I
can think of another one you know what I
think I have another idea I'm going to
use uh a different one here so it looks
like unverified can I change this I'm G
to try um because you have an privacy uh
privacy email uh will be used for
account related stuff um yeah I'm not
really sure what's going on here I
thought maybe my account even exists but
it looks like it already does
exist so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to add another one I can do
Andrew maybe at teacher seat.com we'll
try
that oh it's already in use oh my
goodness it's so hard to get an email
out
here okay let me just think about this
for a second all right all right another
thing I'm going to try is I'm going to
try uh maybe Accounts at teachers
seat.com that's another one that I might
be able to
use okay and I going to change this over
here and save
it great
and
that should be my primary now
right it really wants to send it to this
one maybe what I can do is I can
click oh looks like we have both okay so
we have this one um please verify that
I'm going to get rid of this one here
because that one's not working I'm going
to try uh accounts teacher.com so that's
in my Outlook so I'll go take a look
there and see if I get it all right so
uh this is working out totally fine so
over here we have um the confirmation
email so I can go ahead and just verify
that email we can also just grab this
link I kind of prefer using the link
here um because that just gives me kind
of a guarantee and we'll go here and now
we are in so this is exciting um it's
been a long time since I've made a new
GitHub account so I'm not sure exactly
what to expect but it looks like we have
some places we can start stting a new
project collaborate with your team learn
how to use GitHub hey I'm already doing
that you don't need to do that GitHub
let's go ahead and skip this for now and
we should get back to our main dashboard
so we are now in and we have an account
that we can use um so yeah that's all I
wanted to show you in this video uh but
I'll see you in the next one okay
[Music]
ciao hey this is Angie Brown and this
fall along I just want to show you that
I'm going to be setting up multiple
accounts to quickly switch between them
um if you want to take full advantage of
learning how to use GitHub you're going
to need probably another account because
you're going to have to have somebody
else to work with so I already have my
primary account I already showed you how
to make an account so what I want you to
do is make a secondary account I know
it's a pain but go ahead and do that but
what I'm going to do in this video is
show you how you can log into both and
switch between the two and I'm also
going to set up a
repository um that I'm going to put code
examples in if we happen to put any in
there so what I'm going to do is go up
here at the top right corner I'm going
to go add account and so this is going
to allow me to log into my other account
I can put in my username or my email so
this one is um this is monsterbox
pro.com that's my old my old company
that's not been around for a long time
but I've never updated it and the exam
Pro email is on a another GitHub account
but I'm going to go ahead and find the
password so I can go log into this one
so just give me a moment I'm just trying
to find it here it is there is the
password I'm going to paste it in here
okay we'll hit sign
in okay notice it says GitHub mobile so
now it's my opportunity to show you
GitHub mobile so what I'm doing is I'm
opening up my phone
and right away it pops up it says uh you
know new signin request now it says
reject or approve I'm going to hit
approve it says authentication request
was approved uh the first time I I had
to do that I had to enter in like a code
like two numbers but now from then on I
just have to do that and it's very easy
to uh to do that so if I want to switch
between accounts we can go here and just
switch between them uh freely so that is
really easy and so what I want to do is
go to exam Pro this is my other
organization you'll learn about
organizations in this
um this here that didn't really help but
what I want to do is create a new repo I
can create a new one up here in green or
I can go up here I never notice these up
here but this is another place to do
that anyway you're just watching you're
not doing right now okay so I'm going to
go ahead and hit new and in here I'm
going to go to exam Pro I'm going to say
um GitHub examples so this will be the
um
GitHub we'll say a repo containing
GitHub examples for Pro for programmatic
examples for
programmatic examples this will be
public because I want you to have access
to it I want to have a read me I'm going
to create that repository and so this
will crop up later in the course and
you'll have to know where this this is
but just remember that is but the key
part of this video was how to log into
another account um and be able to switch
between them okay so we'll see you in
the next one
ciao
all right so what I want to do in this
fall along is set up a GitHub
organization and the reason we want to
do this is so that uh it's going to make
it easier when we get to that section so
what I'm going to do is go to the top
right corner and I want to I can make
this in either or account I'm going to
make it in the alternate account because
I already have enough organizations in
my main GitHub account and what I want
to do is go over here to um maybe
organizations and here it says uh you
are not a member of an organization we
could turn this account into an
organization I don't want to do that or
we can make a new org so I'm going to
make a new org and notice right away
it's going to hit us with some pricing
so um you know teams gives you the full
functionality we just want to have the
free one uh which might have some
limitations but um it should get us
started if there's are things that we
can't do um then I'll switch over to our
paid one that I have in my account for
the most part we should be able to do um
pretty much everything as long as we're
using a public GitHub um public GitHub
repo so I'm gonna go ahead and hit
create a free
organization and so I need some kind of
name for this
organization um
[Music]
so I don't know but we'll just say uh
GitHub Cloud Learners or
journeyers okay notice that's be the
name of
it I say Accounts at teacher
seat.com and this organization belongs
to a personal account we could say uh
business or institution but then we get
a little bit more details there so I'm
going to just stick it to normal and go
to personal account then down below we
need to solve our puzzle so we've seen
this one before we'll rotate that out
and we'll
submit
okay and you'll have to name your
organization whatever you have to name
it but that's what I'm calling M you can
put some numbers on the end here if that
makes it easier you do like four five
six s or something because these are
going to be unique names just like your
your username going to go ahead and hit
next and so now it says add organization
members so we can go ahead and add some
people so what I want to do is I want to
add um Omen king so I'm going to go
ahead and do that please don't add me
all right add your own other account
your two
accounts okay we'll hit complete setup
and so now this person has been invited
not sure if they're instantly added um
not yet but I believe that I was yeah
here's the invitation so we'll go here
so the invite has been sent and we'll
have to go look for that so I'm going to
go over here and switch to my other
account okay and so now what I'll do is
I'll click up here and maybe it's up
here my
notifications
no do I have invites
here no
and um maybe I got an email check my
email no email and this is something
you'll learn about GitHub which is like
invites are a pain and you always have
to really figure it out so I'm just
trying to think about where that or that
could be um what we could try to do is
type in the organization name which I
thought we already
did um
so this one let's see my profile is
this yeah so the organization's going to
be what was it cloud
oh I don't even
remember we'll switch back to the other
one what a
pain okay and we will look for that
organization GitHub Cloud journeyer so
I'm just going to copy this
URL I want the um view organization I
want to go to this page actually I'm
going to copy it here I'm go switch
back and I'll enter this
in and so now notice that it's showing
me where the invitation is so it says
Andrew Brown invited you to join this
organization view
invitations okay and I I don't know if
there is but I'm just going to double
check here because a lot of times GitHub
will have like invitations invitations
they might have a page for it they don't
GitHub if you're watching make a SL
invitations page so we can easily find
them across them here so as you've been
invited to GitHub Cloud Juniors ask for
a GitHub co-pilot seat optional I guess
this is kind of an upsell they're like
hey do you want to be able to use GitHub
co-pilot but I'm going to go ahead and
join this organization and now I'm in
there so there's two people in here
again we'll come back to this later I'm
the member this is the
owner um and uh you know if your company
is using GitHub they're likely going to
be using using organization so it's good
to get some knowledge on that but I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao all right so I'm on the my oat.com
and we can go ahead and build our own
octocat so what I'll do is create your
octocat you also getting started we'll
do the exact same thing and it'll have a
fun little animation here there's no
audio but it's kind of showing you
something we'll give it a moment here
and so now we have the default octocat
and we can do something fun so you can
choose obviously a color I'm just going
to go down one shade here for face um
I'm pretty pale so let's go real pale
here these just look like off colors to
me but we'll do that for eyes we could
choose anything else but I usually will
do glasses so it's not going to matter
anyway so if I go down here uh I'm going
to want some glasses
on uh we'll go to mouth we'll choose
something there you can choose hair
there's probably something that kind of
looks like my hair um facial hair it's
bizarre because they show like other
ones that I could have I don't have a
full beard but like they have this one
and it doesn't show up do not want
mutton chops okay we'll go over here to
Tops I'm in Canada so it would probably
make sense if I was to choose the
Canadian
one I know it's somewhere
here where are you it was here the other
day I wonder if this is like region
specific nope there it is okay so I have
Canada um I'm going to keep the bottoms
off maybe have some
skates
and got a toque I should be wearing a
toque shouldn't
I no any accessories props whatever you
want to have and the funny part is I
don't play hockey but this looks good
enough so what I want to do is save it
so we can share
it I'm not sure what happens if we do
that click the share button oh that
downloads the file so that's perfect so
now we can use that as our profile I'm
just going to quickly open that up in
Explorer
it's opening somewhere on my computer
I'm sure it went to downloads but I'm
going to go ahead and close that out I'm
going to switch back over to my other
account and obviously for your primary
account you should treat it like a
profile just like your LinkedIn profile
if you're alternate alternate it doesn't
really matter we're just goofing around
so if we go over to um profile it's
still not showing up here it is great so
I want to go ahead and change this I'm
going to change my avatar and then I'll
click
here
and I'm just going to move this off
screen here and I'm going to go find
it there it is right
there I'll hit
open and there it
is say Andrew
Brown okay alt
account this is Andrew
Browns so at sign Omen King's alternate
account for the
purpose of learning GitHub since you
need another GitHub account to make use
of learning all of
update our profile all right I can go
and view my personal profile and I mean
that should be
there I don't see it we'll go back to
edit I'm going click it again maybe it
didn't upload it is there so probably
what's happening is it's just a caching
issue right um and so it's just going to
take some time for that to show up so or
maybe if I open it up another browser it
will show up there but you know
eventually it'll show up and I'm not
really worried about it but that was
octocat so um yeah I'll see you the next
one okay
[Music]
ciao let's take a look at GitHub octocat
so this is github's official mascot and
it's a cat because and an octopus
because it's supposed to symbolize
friendly and engaging nature in the
world of software development
collaboration I don't know if I believe
that but it looks cool so cool uh you
can actually create your own octocat I
thought that'd be a great opportunity
for us to create a profile for our
alternate alternate account or for both
whichever you want to do you will see
octocat in other places so um they have
a bot that's called octocat that is used
throughout the platform their SDK is
called octo kit so you're going to see
that themes in a few other places so you
know where that is originating from
[Music]
okay all right let's make sure we
understand clearly the difference
between git and GitHub I don't think
it's that confusing but it is in the
study guide or exam outline so so I'm
just trying to make content that they
want us to know um so let's do a
comparison and go through some things to
make sure we understand the difference
so git is a distributed Version Control
System a dbcs and GitHub is a version
control as a service I called it a
Version Control service it can also be
called a get provider or you can call it
a version control as a service I'm just
trying to get you exposure to all those
different terms you could call what
GitHub is for functionality for Git it
manages source code history for GitHub
it provides cloud storage for git repos
of course it does more than that but
that's its main functionality um for
Access you're doing this via your local
system installation or it's basically
wherever it's installed the point is is
that you're working on it on a machine
on a server or some kind of compute uh
and GitHub is accessed through a web
interface because it is a cloud service
for the scope we're talking about local
repository management and then for
GitHub we're actually talking about the
online collaboration and remote hosting
uh so anything that has to do with
remote or things around the repo the git
repo itself for collaboration it's for
local changes requires manual sharing
for GitHub it has integrated tools for
collaboration like issues and PR and a
lot of other features for usage you're
going to be using this primarily by the
command line interface there's
definitely software out there that makes
it a lot easier to use um we'll get into
that but generally it's a command line
tool that you're using for GitHub it has
a graphical interface and it also has
its own CLI tool but most people are
interacting with it via the website okay
so there you go
[Music]
ciao so a git repo or repository is your
git repo think of your local one that
you push Upstream to GitHub to be uh
hosted remotely and GitHub allows you
access to manage your re repo with
several functionalities so here is a
screenshot of a GitHub repo this is when
I ran a boot camp in
2023 uh and so let's talk about what is
on this GitHub repo page I don't know
what they want to call this page I just
called the GitHub repo page for a
specific repo um but you can view
different branches view tags view commit
history explore repo files view releases
uh see codebase language breakdown view
top level markdown files and so those
top level files might be the read me the
license security other things like that
you can perform actions from this page
or quickly to it such as pinning
watching forking starring cloning so uh
a lot of stuff going on this page and
this is going to be we're going to be
spending a lot of time or uh going from
here to somewhere else but that is a
GitHub repo so there you
[Music]
go all right in this follow along I just
want to give you a tour of GitHub repos
so that you have a a general Fami
familiarity uh so that when we start
diving a bit deeper we understand what
we're looking at so I'm on my dashboard
I have a lot of different repositories
um and so I can go here and find a
repository I can search stuff and say
like if I'm looking for my boot camp I
can type in boot camp here and then make
my way over here and find it um a lot of
times when you are looking for stuff
you're going to use the global search so
up here you could do that as well well
and I could find my own repos or other
repos um there are a lot of Open Source
repos on GitHub and so um I know rails
pretty well so I'll go ahead and type in
rails and so we have this rails repo I'm
going to go open this open this up and
take a look and see what we can see
because this is a very mature Li um uh
GitHub repo and we'll make it very clear
of all the functionality that's
happening so notice we have our main
area this is where all of our files are
uh we can actually view any of these
files so I can click into any of them so
I can go into the gem file and it will
show me the contents of the gem file
what I like about uh GitHub is that when
you click into here then you kind of get
this file explorer and it's extremely
powerful uh if I click this on the right
hand side it will show me symbols that's
not a very good example I might open up
a ruby file to show you what I mean so
I'm just looking for Ruby file here and
so this will show you like places you
could jump uh jump towards in your code
um that's really nice you can see who
did what by going to blame so we can see
exactly what some he doing by the way
I'm going really quick here it's not
important for you to remember any of
this I'm just giving you a tour of stuff
so just relax and uh enjoy the
information that we're learning here you
don't have to write it down if I wanted
to find a file really quickly in this
repo I could go here and type something
in so maybe I'm looking for um something
like View and so it's going to drop down
and it has this fuzzy search if I want
to find a ruby file I can type this in
we have a lot of them here I believe
there's a hotkey here so if I hit T if
I'm over here and I hit t T it will
bring me over there I can switch
branches really easily um does that let
me add a file it's not my repo but if I
add a file I'd have to create a fork um
the search brings that up there but
we'll go back over to code okay so my
point here is that you have all the
files here and you can browse them um
you can switch branches you can go and
take a look at all of your branches you
can take a look at all your tags you can
star you can Fork you can watch here for
code you could launch this up in code
spaces which is a cloud developer
environment I normally have um G pod
installed so if I hit refresh that
button might show up here this button
you will not have this button I
installed this because it's like code
spaces but
different um on the right hand side you
get a bunch of information about the
repo like stars watching Fork uh some of
these probably are conditional because I
don't remember seeing these on my repos
you have releases so maybe you are
building up binaries like downloadable
files that people can uh utilize so some
people they will host all their code
here and they'll build the binaries for
quick downloads so that's somewhere else
you can go to packages is probably
similar to releases I don't I don't
think I've ever used packages ever in my
life uh let's go over here and take a
look browse browsing all packages yeah I
don't know what packages do we can see
who's using it the contributors so
people that are writing uh writing code
um we have the languages so you can see
this is mostly a
ruby LI or uh repo which makes sense
because it's Ruby on Rails down below we
get a preview of our readme file so that
is in the top level directory they have
a codes of conduct I imagine that is a
markdown file here and as well the
license file I'm sure that's in here as
well the security policy as well um so
yeah there's a lot going on in here and
then there's all this stuff up here this
these are features on top of your
repo so lots and lots and lots of stuff
if we want to see our commits we can go
here and click on commits and this is
kind of like a tree it doesn't give you
the full view because when you are
looking at um when you're looking at a
tree uh there's branches and stuff so
we're missing that information here but
the idea is you can go here and uh go to
different branches and look at those
commits and that's basically all I
wanted to do here we'll get into it a
lot deeper later on but that is your
tour of GitHub repos
[Music]
ciao hey this is Andrew Brown and in
this video what I want to do is a quick
and dirty get crash course um you are
supposed to already have this knowledge
uh coming into this uh certification
even though they kind of suggest that
you do and you don't um this is not
going to be a complete crash course um
it's just going to be uh the least
amount of knowledge we need to know in
order to be able to be productive in
GitHub uh you really do need to make
sure you know git very well and should
look at other additional resources to go
be on this little component but it'll be
good enough uh we did create that repo
or I created that repo earlier in exam
Pro I think that's a great uh great
place to start so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go and log into my other
new account so over here and uh I'm
going to go and make my way over there
so I'm going to type in for slash exam
proo up here I'm going to look for this
new repo here and um the reason I'm
doing this normally I would just open it
in my regular account but what I want to
do is I want to show you how to fork and
then we're going to do some work in here
and you'll commit it to your own repo
but what I will do is I will end up U
bringing those changes over into the
original repo okay so anyway the way
we're going to get started is um there's
a few ways we can go ahead and open up
a terminal but probably the easiest way
is to open up
github.io that's going to make a copy of
it and have a reference to it so I'm
going to go and click that and notice
it'll prefill the name in make sure it
stays the same it says copying the main
branch only that's all there is right
now and that's what we're going to do so
we'll create that fork and now we have
GitHub uh uh uh GitHub examples and
notice under our name we have it here it
shows that it is a fork so I want to
open this up in
github.com
okay and we'll give it a moment and I
think that we can do stuff in here if we
can't we'll have to open up a developer
environment like a GitHub code spaces
but I'm hoping that we can use this
initially because we can write commits
in
here so this is open and um we have our
readme file and on the left hand side we
have this GitHub icon so this is
obviously an extension installed
specifically for GitHub but if we don't
have a terminal we're not going to be
able to do a whole lot here so we could
commit stuff over here and maybe we'll
start with that and I'll just show you
how to do it with the goey so let's go
ahead and I'm going to make a new
folder I'm going to call this git crash
course okay and in here I'm going I'm
going to name it lower case I actually
prefer when they're lower case get crash
course and there's a few things that we
want to cover okay so I'm going to make
a new file here I'm going to just say
readme MD
and um a couple things I want to cover
uh commits I want to cover branches I
want to cover
remotes I want to cover stashing because
I think that's really
[Music]
useful I guess merging is something that
would be really important and so I think
that's sufficient enough to begin with
and whether we'll do this in order I'm
not really sure but we'll start at the
start so the first thing I want to do is
I want to go ahead and create um a a get
commit and we're not doing this
programmatically we're just going to
start out by uh doing this over here in
the source control so Source control is
a built-in extension in vs code that
allows you to um uh basically write
commit messages it's really simple so
what I'm going to do is just right here
and say um create skeleton readme for
get crash course okay and so I have my
commit message and notice that we have
changes that are staged so changes can
be either staged or not staged so if I
right click this here um I can H I click
stage changes and now it's up here so
what's the difference between being up
here and being down below well when I go
ahead and click commit and push it will
only take the stuff that is from the
stage changes anything else will be left
behind because sometimes you're working
with a lot of files and you don't want
to commit them all okay so that is the
reason for that um but the idea is that
you can hit minus and plus and move them
back and forth so hopefully that is very
clear we can click on a file we can see
the difference and changes this is a
completely new file that we're adding so
we're basically having having stuff
that's added and prior there was nothing
so it's showing that on the left hand
side and we are ready to do something
with this if we drop this down we can
have Commit push I've never clicked on
this before so I'm not going to do that
but I'm going to go ahead and click
commit and push and so what it's done is
it's committed it and it's pushed it Up
Normally you wouldd have to perform
those as separate actions okay but we'll
talk about that when we start using the
terminal so now that we have pushed that
up what we can do is click on this
little icon or maybe not what I'm
looking for is a visualization for our
um uh for our tree here it is view as
tree and that's not helping okay so I
guess that doesn't do what I thought it
would do and that's totally fine so what
we'll do
here is we'll go back and open this up
in uh GitHub the repo so I'm just trying
to find if there's like a short way to
do that no there's not so we'll have to
go ahead and type in GitHub I'm going to
have to type in my name uh Andrew WC
Brown this will be GitHub examples to
get back to this repo and we can observe
that we've pushed that commit so if I go
here you can see our uh get commit we
can click into it we can you can see our
get commit we canot comment on stuff
here so I can say this looks
great all
right add a single comment and so that
should be pretty darn clear we have a uh
commit Shaw so that's over here um there
should be some way to get the full Shaw
I'm not exactly sure where it
is uh because I can see parts of
it a lot of times if we click into here
it might show it here so if we go here I
could copy that go back here I can get
the full Shaw right okay but what I'm
realizing is that
github.com mans but it doesn't so that's
okay but we can use this as a means to
quickly edit files what I want to do is
go ahead and close this out and we'll go
back over to our code and what we'll do
is we'll launch up GitHub codes spaces
so GitHub codes spaces has a free tier
um and that's what we'll be
utilizing okay I'm going to try to find
the pricing here if I
can and I'm not exactly sure where the
pricing is but that's totally fine we'll
go ahead and open up a new Cod space on
Main there's a whole section of code
spaces in the course so we will come
back to this and cover it in more detail
so we'll give it a moment to launch up
is spinning up a virtual machine
underneath uh so that's why we have to
wait a little bit um or if it's not
spinning up a virtual machine it's
spinning up a Docker container on
existing virtual machines that's
probably what it is and so now we get a
terminal and that's going to allow us to
interact um with GitHub using git
commands so I'm going to go down to the
bottom left corner here I'm going to
change my theme because I cannot stand
working in a light theme and I'm going
to change this over to something that is
dark um so I'm going to go to GitHub
dark
and so this is a little bit easier to
read we can also increase the font here
if this is hard to read I'm going to do
that by going to settings and I'm just
going to bump up the font here to 20 for
font size and I'll do the same thing for
terminal so I'm typing terminal in
here and I'm looking for font size we
can also just type in
font sometimes it's a bit tricky to find
terminal
font there we go and we'll turn this up
to 20 okay so that should be a lot
easier to read so I can go in here I'll
click into read me now this is going to
come pre-installed with Git if I type in
Git it should be here okay so I didn't
have to do anything it's already
installed I'm not covering how to
install git on your local machine I'm
going to be doing everything in the
cloud developer environment because it's
just easier and I don't want to uh work
through all those challenges of trying
to show you how to do that um so
normally what you'll do is when you
start working with a repo you're going
to clone it now this repo has already
been cloned because we opened it up but
let's say it hadn't been let's go ahead
and just do that ourselves so what I
want to do is I'm going to just CD back
a directory and type in clear and type
in LS and we're going to see where we
are so right now we're in workspaces
okay I'm just going to make uh a new
directory and just call it temp I'm
going to CD into that and what I want to
do here is I want to take the first step
into bringing in this repo okay and the
way we're going to do that is by going
back over to here and we're going to go
over to
code and we're going to go to local and
then we have these commands we have htps
SSH and the GitHub CLI and so these are
ways that we can bring in um our
repo okay and so the most common way is
by using SSH where you will actually
have to add a public key and we can do
that the second one is https where you'd
have to use your personal access token
and there's the GitHub CLI and this I
think is probably the way we should do
it in the future but we're just going to
work any way we can here so what I'm
going to do is go back over here and
we're going to go all the way to top and
we're going to talk about cloning okay
so we have three ways to clone so we can
clone three
ways
HPS uh
SSH and GitHub
CLI okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to start with htps
so we'll go over here I'm going to copy
this and I'm going to go over here I'm
going to type in get clone I'll write it
in here so we can copy it out but this
is going to be get clone and I'm going
to paste this in okay and since we're
working in markdown and that's part of
the course you have to learn how
markdown works I'm going to put three
back ticks and put an MD
here okay you should do all this because
we're just learning everything up front
if you're wondering what the the back
tick is it is is a character that's
above your tab key see if I can find it
for you here back tick
key and it's this key right here okay so
notice that there's a back tick it's a
tick that goes back and so that's what
I'm pressing I'm pressing three of those
and the reason I'm doing that is that it
will then render that out um it's
actually not MD It's Just sh I don't
know why I did that and if you go up
here in the top right corner we can
preview all the stuff we're working on
for our documentation but anyway this is
the first command that I want to
run um so I'm just going to go up here
we'll make a
directory uh since so we'll say since
we're
using we are using GitHub code
spaces we'll
use we'll create
a
temporary directory
in our
workspace okay and so that's what we
did so that's going to
be sh stands for bash I mean it's not
exact it's shell or whatever but it's
pretty close to it and so what we did
there is we typed in mkd slw workpace
TMP and then we're doing CD workspace
TMP okay and then the next thing we want
to do is clone this uh repo so I'm going
to go ahead and attempt
that so it really matters whether the
repo is public or private if it is
public then we don't need any
credentials to clone it but when we want
to push it back up that's a different
story so I'm just trying to copy that
this is a bit finicky the the copy paste
here control command V uh and it's not
letting me paste it I'm going to try
this again
copy there we go right click paste for
whatever reason from here to here it
didn't work so I'm going to go ahead and
hit enter and so I'm actually cloning
from here now now we have this this is
attached um to that other location so
just ignore this for now we're going to
pretend this doesn't exist and we're
just going to strictly use the git
commands to do everything so we've
cloned this and I'm just type in clear
and what I want you to do is type in LS
hyphen La so what LS hyphen La does is
it will show you all the hidden
directory or hidden
folders and um we don't have any yet but
we're going to have to CD into this
directory I'm going go go ahead and type
in GitHub examples
right and um so what we'll do is just
type
CD GitHub
examples and so now we're in this
directory and I want to type in LS hyen
LA and so I'm showing you here that
there is a hidden folder called dog this
is how it knows that there is a GitHub
repo okay so I'm going to go up here for
a second and we'll make another thing so
we'll just say GitHub or sorry get get a
hidden folder so there is a hidden
folder called
doget which tells you that uh your
project is a git project or a git repo
okay and normally what we would do is we
create our git repo outside of this so
if we wanted to we'll see you back here
I know this is a mess but I told you
it'd be quick and dirty is that if we
wanted to create a new repo we could
actually go ahead and just type in get a
knit in a new folder so uh you know if
we want
to to create a get repo in a a new
project we'd create the
folder and then
initialize that
repo using get
nit okay so what we would do
here try and get those back ticks here
get a n cuz we're using Code we always
use back tiex for
codes so what we would do here is we'd
create a new folder so so we make we'd
say um mkdr slw workspaces and then we
would say temp uh new
project and then in here we'd have uh
that new product so we' CD CD into it so
we just say
workspaces temp new
project and then we would do get a nit
we'd create some files so we' say touch
make a new file so you say readme.md
then we could open that file up so I
could say open readme.md
then we' make some changes to
it uh so make changes
to readme.md then we could Commit This
so we' say get commit hyphen M hyphen M
hyphen a sorry hyphen a hyphen M so add
readme
file
all right and so let's do a little bit
of that right now so I'm going to say
mkd I'm going to say new project okay
and then I'm going to go get a nit it
initializes a new git repo we end up
with this
dogit uh folder here
okay and then we could touch a new file
so we say readme.md
and then if I want to open that up I
probably can type in open. MD I would
imagine that it would open up in here it
didn't what if I type in vs C vsvs code
readme.md
no how do you open files in vs code from
terminal I thought it was just
open terminal
command what is
it there must be like a
command code I think we type code that's
what it is code
okay I us usually use Vim so this is not
my
primary editor so we open that up and I
can say hello
world okay we'll save
that I'll type in clear here and now
what we can do is we can type in get
status so we can see what's going on
here so we'll say get status to see what
files are being tracked or untracked
this is the exact same thing as this
thing here when you're typing get status
this is what this is right here that's
your get status okay so we have files
that are are tracked but nothing's
change uh uh stage so we can do get add
all okay I guess I missed that there get
at all take this part out here because
we don't need it and um it says you've
added another git repo inside your
current repo we'll just ignore this
because it it's it's just confused
because we have that other repo we'll
type in get status and notice now these
are changes to be committed okay so the
idea is that these are going to be the
things that get pushed let's say we
didn't want to add in GitHub examples we
definitely don't want to do that so I'm
going to say git remove GitHub
examples get status didn't really work
that's okay um we can say sorry get I
didn't mean to do remove I meant to say
get um
uh um Ty
reset sorry get
reset get
status there we go so reset will'll put
them back in here I actually only wanted
to add that say get add readme.md okay
so we go down
here you'll say
get add
readme.md and while we're on it I'm
gonna have to go and just say
um
reset get reset
so reset allows you
to um move
changed files back to untracked files or
un like change or
sorry
staged staged changes to be
unstaged
okay this is useful
when you don't want to uh you want to
when you want
to
revert All Stage change all
files not to be
committed sorry I know it's a bit messy
but the idea here is that we're going to
go
here and we'll just say get add all get
reset so I'm going to go here and just
say
uh
G reset will revert a git at all
okay we have
ADD so this
is get add readme.md
get
ad
when we want to
Stage changes that will be included in
the commit we can use the period to add
all possible
files all right we have get
status get status shows you what files
will or will not be
committed okay let's get
status all
right
so I want to type in get status again
here okay so this is what we want to
commit so we'll go back up to our commit
section here and
um yeah over here which we were kind of
working on it and we we'll go ahead and
type in get
commit okay so if we just type in get
commit it's going to try to open up the
editor so it actually opens up here so
what I want to do is just comment
something here
so get
commit when we want to
commit code we write we can uh write get
commit which will open
up
um the
commit edit message in the
editor of choice and so this is already
configured to open up in vs code if
you're running this in your local
machine it would complain and say Hey
you have to set a default okay so get
config set default
editor okay so if we had to do that I'm
just going to look this up really
quickly
here
editor normally you'd have to set it
right so you'd have to first set
that
um
okay and so this would be emac or
whatever
um set the global
editor I don't know what it is for this
um we could take a look and see what it
is I just hit control C to get out of
that because I really don't want to do
that right now so let's go find where
this is actually configured
um so I believe that there is like a
global get folder somewhere it's not
there yeah I'm not sure where it
is let we type in get config can we see
that we type that in I just want to see
what is being set
for the
editor um so I'm not exactly sure I just
want to know what it is so uh you know
get uh editor vs code default I just
want to know what that value needs to
be
um so that would be set as
what oh it's dog config that's the file
we're looking for okay hold on so this
would probably be
in our home folder let's try this again
so let's say code get git config where's
git config stored where is git
config
stored
um oh we just list it out
okay let's see if that
works okay um we'll go down here for a
second
the git config
file is what stores your Global
configurations uh for G such as email
name uh editor and more
okay so we go here and I'm just going to
say get
config hyphen hyen
list
[Music]
uh and that's
showing the
contents of our
git config file still don't know where
that file
is but at least we
know what some things are set at and so
what I'm looking for in here is that
editor
and it's not showing up so what I'm
thinking is that it already
knows what to do but it is setting our
user. name and user. email this is
something that you would normally have
to set so I can go back to just get
config here and customize and get and
notice these are the first two things
that they set right so
um when you first install get on a
machine you are supposed to set up your
name and email
okay and so those are the examples
there all
right so they're right here and you can
see that they already set it for us but
normally you'd also have to set the
editor and it would complain but for
whatever reason it knows to open it up
already in uh envious code here so I'm
going to go back up to here and so
that's going to open this up
interactively so I'm going to type in
get commit whoops
editor down below here I'm going to type
in um first I want to make sure I'm in
that that folder that new
project oh you know what I created that
read me in the wrong
spot let's go back here for a second
type in LS hyphen
LA and yeah I didn't even make it in the
right place so remove that folder we're
going to remove the readme
file new project I'm going to type in
clear and I'm going to try this again so
we'll type in m mkd or sorry just touch
touch readme.md
we'll open up this file so code read MD
we just
say hello world save that we'll close
that and now we will type in get status
there is no get repost we'll type in get
AIT and then it's initialized an empty
repost that's good we'll type in clear
and then we will type in get status and
now it's not complaining about that it
us or that um GitHub examples because
this is now in a subfolder so it's not
trying to add a sub module so now we can
do get add all we can do get
status and now this file will be added
and we'll do get commit which will open
it up in here and so now we can write
our message so let's just say add readme
file okay I'm going to save that and
close it okay so now it completed it
it's created it if I type in get status
you'll see it's gone
and so if I want to see the tree for
this I think I can type in
get uh was it get log and it's going to
show me uh that commit there so if I
added another one it should show
multiple commits here so let's let's go
ahead and and modify that readme file
again so I'm going just open it up again
here uh code readme and what I'm going
to do I'm just going to take this other
Tab out of the way and open a new tab
and have it over here so we can make
sense of what we're doing I'm going to
put another exclamation mark so another
way that we can commit is in line is by
putting the m flag so I'm going to type
in get
status and then uh what I want to do is
add that file okay and type in get
status again and now I want to commit
that change this this part here and so
what we can do is type in get commit and
now we'll type in hyphen M and I'll just
say add another exclamation
mark
all right and don't worry about the
spelling I do not care and I'm really
bad at
spelling and here we'll type in get
commit hyphen M add
another
exclamation okay so uh make a commit and
commit message without
opening at
editor and so what we'll do is go ahead
and hit
enter and so that added there we'll go
ahead and type in get status we'll do
get log to see stuff so we'll go here
and say log so get log
will show recent git commits to the git
tree um if we want to see more of the
tree I don't know what command it is
like is there git tree I always forget
and the reason I don't remember is
because often you're relying on these
tools so there's some stuff you should
know here and there's some stuff you
should just utilize in here but you
should know the basis of get commit
commands Okay so that's good so we
learned about get commit status a few
other
things okay and so if we wanted to take
this project and push it up uh to GitHub
it's not going to it shouldn't work
because we don't have credentials but
technically this account uh or this
environment is actually
um tied um to GitHub so it actually
might work um how it would work I don't
know maybe we add our personal access
token um but we could just find out by
trying to push so what I'll do let go
down here
below and type in uh push so uh when we
want
to push a repo
to um our remote
origin and so this is so just be
simply get push this should not work
because we don't have a repo to push
to okay and so we have to add a remote
um so we can do get remote add origin
and then put the name there but we
haven't created a repo so there's
nothing for it to go to so even if we
added a remote it's not going to work
okay so this project here is done so I'm
going to go ahead and just clean this up
and we'll just go ahead and type in
remove RF new project so that's going to
give you some ideas what you can do
there so what I want to do is LS and I
want to go back into this one because
this
one
has um
sorry a get folder and let's just open
that up really quickly so we can take a
look at what's in there so we open this
up I typed in code it opened it up in a
new repo I'm not really sure why try
this again code.
git I don't know why it's opening up in
a new repo
there I guess it's
confused um but it did work the only
problem with this is that it's opened up
another developer environment so in here
this is all the files that are in this
why couldn't do it over here I don't
know but um if we just take a look here
uh closely we have the config folder and
this is what I showed you earlier in
those slides this is how it knows what
the origin is this is how it knows how
to push to main we have some core
configurations here and there's some
other stuff like we have reference and
stuff like that I don't really want to
get into all this stuff um because it's
just too much but uh the most important
thing to know is this config file
because that's where these things are
and so if you ever get this stuff mucked
up like your remote or origins or
something's not working you can fiddle
with stuff in here um and that's all I
wanted to point out here so I want to
just stop this um this one here so I'm
just going to go ahead and close this
out there's some way to shut this one
down I'm just going to close it out and
should stop it with with GitHub code
spaces you you got to really be aware of
all the ones you're running because then
you can run through your free hours very
quickly so I'm going to just see what's
running I'm going to see if I can just
type in code spaces up here there we go
I just want to make sure that I'm only
running
one okay it looks like I'm just running
one so I think all it did was it opened
the same uh running environment in
another tab because it got confused
which is totally fine but anyway this
file is now gone and let's focus on this
one so we created this repo here and
technically
we should not be able uh to push up to
it now we might be able to because it
might be storing our personal access
token or some credentials but in uh
technically it should not work so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go ahead
and try to add a file to this
repo
okay sorry I don't want to lose this one
um and see what happens when we try to
push okay so uh what we're going to do
make sure we're in this repo we're going
to type in touch readme.md and then I
want to open this one up so I'm going to
type in this here I'm going to say
hello world we'll save that and the idea
is that this is the same repo as that
other one so actually we just um we just
technically edited this one so you know
what I actually don't want to make this
file here because I realized that's
going to causes a problem uh what I'm
going to do I'm just going to LS here
I'm going to CD in to get crash course
and I'm going to make a new file here
we'll just call it
um
uh hello so just say touch
hello okay and then we'll open up this
file
here oh sorry code and then we'll say
hello all right so it's not here because
of course we're ignoring
this okay but if we type in LS Ty and La
we have this hello file right and so if
I type in get
status I can see that this file is
untracked so I want to add it and do get
status type in clear and now I'm going
to do a get push so this should fail but
it still might work let's see what
happens it says everything's up to date
and the reason why is that we didn't
create a commit right if we do get
log you notice we don't have anything
this is the last one we ran so I'm going
to do get commit hyphen M add hello
file
okay and now I'm going to do get logs so
I can see that it's there right and now
I'll do a get
push and it did work so it probably
worked
because this environment already has the
stuff loaded up if I was using my local
developer environment this should not
work um and I suppose I could show that
I'm just trying to decide whether I want
to do that or
not
um give me a second to think about it
yeah I think I really should show you
this so what I'll do is I'll open up vs
code on my local
computer and we'll do that
okay so my point is is that even if
you're not doing this I just want you to
watch and understand what you'd have to
do if you're using your local developer
environment the trick with local
developer environments is they're really
finicky because um especially on Windows
because you have to get Linux installed
and you need the windows subsystem Linux
and that's such a pain to work with so
I'm here in vs code this is on my local
computer and what I want to do is I want
to uh bring down that repo um and so
what I'm going to do is just open up
terminal okay if I can find it any day
now here it is um and I need to store
this somewhere it's opening up in
Powershell but I want to use Windows
subsystem
Linux
okay
and I'll give it a moment here and so
it's it's starting up
Linux and so here it's on my desktop in
a folder called
code okay I'm just going to type in
LS not sure what this
is but I normally like storing things in
a folder called sites so I already have
one here and the idea is I want to um I
want to clone that repo into here so
what I'm going to do just bring this
over here for a
second all right so this one was uh this
was this one was no good I couldn't
really show you this example here so I'm
just going to go ahead and
[Music]
remove this
one and we'll just get this back to
normal okay type in that clear and I'm
going to go back over to here into our G
GitHub crash course so we can keep
working on
this and I want to go back up to commits
or sorry cloning and I want to go ahead
and attempt this clone uh that we're
doing earlier so this is mine right of
course you'll have to switch this out
for yours so understand you can't just
copy and paste this you have to modify
it but I'm going to copy this I'm going
to go over here and in my Linux system
I'm going to go ahead and paste this in
because I think I already have get
installed right and it's downloading it
here okay so I've downloaded it because
it's a public repo but the question is
can I push to it so I want to open this
project up here in vs code I'm going to
go ahead and type in code
period and that should reopen vs codes
in this context I'll get rid of this old
one here out of the way that was some
other thing I was working on I'm going
to say I trust the authors it's totally
fine and apparently there's a newer vs
code I do not
care and it's opened up this entire
directory so I kind of messed that
up and I'm G to go into terminal again
so sorry you can see I have a bunch of
stuff in here
I'm going to CD into this by typing in
um GitHub examples and we'll try this
again I'll type in code period and then
I'll close this one all right and then
this time we now have our local
developer environment in good shape okay
so just understand that you can connect
GitHub codes spaces to your local one I
don't want to do that I because I want
this to be detached from git so I can
show you the challenges of cloning so
this has been cloned already we already
did that and if I go over into terminal
here okay new terminal and I want to
make sure I'm
in uh WSL which I am I'm going to type
in lsy La I want to see that I have that
dog directory here and we're going to go
ahead and modify this hello file I'm
going to put an exclamation mark I'm
going to hit save and so the idea is I'm
going to do get push and I'm expecting
it not to work so it says it doesn't
work work would you like to sign in with
GitHub no I don't want to sign in with
GitHub even though that's awesome I
don't want to do that and the reason why
is because I want to show you how you
would use a personal access token so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
over here bring this down and I go back
to GitHub and we're going to go over to
here and we're going to go to settings
and then all the way down to the ground
we're going to go to developer settings
and we're going to click into personal
access tokens and we have a fine grin
access tokens
you don't need to use access tokens very
often this is just for this specific use
case we're going to go ahead and
generate this token I'm going to say um
temporary
token uh local Dev and I want this to
expire uh in the least amount of time so
today is Sunday I'm going to say
tomorrow uh this token is just for today
and I want this for a very specific repo
so you can say say all repos we're going
to say a select repo I'm going to go
here and select my one
repo and for repository
permissions
um I just want to be able to push this
and work with it count
permissions so I just have to make sure
I give this proper
permissions um PLL requests merges
issues
um I'm trying to give it permissions to
just push
code
push
commit so I think we definitely want
this read and write want commit statuses
read and
write and I think that should be
sufficient I'd probably put poll
requests in here as well before GitHub
used to just have like you'd make a
classic token you wouldn't have to do
all this but they're trying to make it
more secure so that's how it is uh
um and so I think this is sufficient so
I go ahead and create this
token and so I now have this token so
the idea is that um when I'm over
here normally this would prompt us it
wouldn't do this oh yeah we have the
username up here so it's asking us to
enter our username in here normally this
would prompt down here but it's not so
I'm just going to hit
clear okay and I'm going to try try this
again say get push I'm saying cancel and
so it's prompting up here if you're not
using vs code it would normally show up
here so I'm going to type in my username
like this and now it's asking for a
password and before you could put your
actual password in here you can't do
that anymore you have to use this
personal access token so if I got those
permissions right this should work okay
so I'm going to paste that in hit
enter and so now it says everything up
to date so did it
push that's what I want to know so we'll
go back over to here um and if we click
here we can go um um oh sorry down here
I'm looking for how to find this
repo there was a button here
before why can't I find it maybe it's
over here
no that's fine but we want to go ahead
and look at that repo so I'm going to go
and type in Andrew WC
Brown and I want to look at our only
repo that we have and I want to see if
those commits work so if I click in
here we have ADD hello
file and that didn't do anything so
maybe it's because we didn't add
anything let's go get status here get
status we have to add it if we want it
to work right we say get commit
update and then I'm going to type in get
push and so it's trying to log in so
every single time we want to push it's
going to ask us for that because it
doesn't remember what it is we can
technically cach those credentials um
I'm not sure what the flag is I've never
had to ever have have to to do it but
there is some way to Cache it we're
going to just hit cancel because I just
want to show you how to use that
personal access token
okay and uh then I'll go go back there
and grab that I think we still have it
there
good okay I'm going to go back to our
local vs code I'm going to paste this in
hit enter and so now it pushes
okay so it's pushed it there
and so that's one one example of us
doing that okay we'll just confirm that
it's there we can see it right there so
that's one method of cloning so go back
over to here to our uh
documentation in GitHub code
spaces so here we'll just say uh you'll
need
to um
so you'll need need to generate a
GitHub access
token or sorry personal access
token and we'll go grab that link so we
know where that is so it's right
here okay says this it's a beta feature
but I can't imagine they'll revert that
you will use the pat as your password
when you log
in
uh and the permissions we you know give
it I think we need that all right so
that's one way another way is with
SSH okay so what we'll
do is I want to get rid of this token
because I don't need it anymore I'm just
going to go ahead and delete
that and I want to go back to our repo
which is over here and we want to clone
this VI the
SSH and because I can't trust GitHub
because I think it's uh the GitHub code
spaces it already has our credential
somewhere we're going to have to do it
this way so I want to CD back here I'm
going to remove this directory
okay clear and I want to clone it again
and so this time I'm going to grab the
SSH if we go over
here we'll paste this link in
here and it looks really similar but
this is not the same
link
SSH okay and we'll want to CD into that
so the difference here is that look at
this this says htps is the protocol this
one puts the stuff in the front so it's
a different
protocol um and and URL for cloning so
we go ahead and copy this and we'll go
down below I'm going to paste this in
and hit
enter okay so it can clone because it's
a public repo if this is a private repo
we would have to already have our
credential set I'm going to go ahead and
um close this out and we want to reopen
this so it should know this is the same
thing but because we deleted that repo
it's confused so I'm going to go into
GitHub examples and I'm going to reopen
this up in vs code it'll open up a new
window not sure what's taking it so
long okay it just autod detected it so I
guess it didn't have to do that it's
fine but um we'll open this file up
again and I'm going to put an
exclamation mark on the end and so I'm
going to do get
status right again we can do it over
here we refresh it
but I'd rather do it from here so that's
not there I'm going to say get add read
me or period now let's refresh it notice
it moved to Stage changes and then we
can do get commit hyphen
M update SSH
way all right and it
pushed um how did it do
that because it's not supposed to work
um so it makes me think that that
personal access token is still
there
okay oh no no no no no no it it didn't
push it didn't push the reason I'm
confused is that notice that this said
push so when we go here this will let us
commit and push sometimes but we've only
just committed it locally okay so if I
type in get
status all right it's here
okay it's not um it's not it's not
remotely there okay
so in order to actually get it get it up
we have to type and get push so that's a
separate action so we'll go ahead and
type in get push so now it should
complain so this says rejected um and
the reason why it's rejected is because
we don't have an SSH key so what we'll
need to do is generate out an SSH key
and the way we do that is we type in SSH
key gen hyphen T I believe it is and we
type in RSA to be specifically what it's
for we even say the length of it this is
a Linux command uh mode Linux
distributions should have this
pre-installed so you can definitely do
it the place that you would put this key
would be in a very specific location so
I already have a default one and I'm
going to rename it to something else but
you can leave it as a default if you
want if you've never ran this command in
your life I'm going to go ahead and hit
enter oh you know what it's key gen SSH
or key
gen SSH
keyen I forgot what it is
already keyen
SSH it's SSH key gen okay so go back
here I'm Type in SSH key gen TR
RSA okay and it's saying where do you
want to create it it will usually create
it here I want this to be named a little
bit different I'm just going to say um
GitHub
alt and then I'm going to say ID
RSA
okay
and then I'm going to hit enter for no
passphrase a passphrase passphrase is a
way to password protect it I don't want
to do that you don't always have to do
that um but it makes it more secure
notice that it generated up both the
private key and the public key we're
going to talk about key pairs later in
the course I made sure to cover this
they didn't make it a requirement in the
in the uh uh the uh the guide or the uh
the C the certification course but I
know you need to know this so I made
sure to put that in in there so we've
generated out this uh private private
and public secret and they're located
here so we're going to need to get the
contents of this one and send it over um
to to GitHub so the way we can do that
is we can just grab this URL or write
this out and and Cat it out so cat is a
way in Linux to print out to the
terminal and so I'm going to type this
full path I'm hitting tab to quickly
complete uh this so I don't have to
write it all out by hand and I'm looking
for GitHub
GitHub
alt ID
RSA it's kind of not showing me all the
files I'm going to just go ahead and
type this here for a
second
okay and um weird it's not there so it
says TS RSA enter the file in which to
save it oh it didn't actually save it
here did it save it over here it did all
right I don't want it here I'll try this
again so we'll hit up because it wants
the full path that's why um and so we'll
do this again we'll say home Andrew
SSH I'm going to say uh alt
GitHub
ID
RSA enter enter enter so now it's where
we think it is so it's actually here I'm
going to copy
this and we'll type in cat and we'll
paste this in that's going to give us
this funky looking thing so this is the
contents of the public key and I I need
to copy that so I'm going to just do
this and write copy I I did contrl C
because I couldn't rightclick
it um and I'm going to go back up to
here and then in GitHub we got to add
that to our account so I'll go to
settings and I'll go over to SSH and I'm
going to add a new SSH key I'm just
going to say paste this in here I'll
just say uh
local uh environment you might even say
what computer this is from you might
have multiple computers with local
developer environments so I'm on my my
my Windows machine so Windows local and
you know we have two things here I
believe it's an authentication key and
we'll put that in there so this should
allow
us uh to now push okay because it will
it will match the private and public key
out I explained in the course how it
works like the logic behind it but this
should work assuming I set it right so
what I'll do is I'll type in get status
because we should have something ready
to push right so notice it says here
your your branch is ahead of origin by
one commit so we have one commit that
hasn't been pushed yet we'll go ahead
and hit get push and if we did it
correctly it should work and so I did
something wrong um what I did wrong I'm
not 100%
sure um so we can try that again so I'm
going to go ahead and go back up here
because this format might matter it
might be in the the wrong format but I'm
pretty
sure it should just be
this give this a refresh
here um says never used I'll try this
one more time maybe takes time sometimes
it's VY like that nope so if it didn't
like
that I'll try signing I don't remember
there being to key types before so I'm a
little bit confused myself and I don't
remember this stuff off the top of my
head if we copy this wrong that could be
the issue as well but we really want to
copy the public key okay notice it says
begins with R RS or that okay so I'll
paste this
in it's definitely the right format so
I'm not sure why it doesn't like it
Windows local we'll try this
again
okay and we'll go back over to our local
environment and we'll say get
push still doesn't work yeah I don't
think it's the signing key we'll try
this one more
time
new
paste
and like that doesn't seem like that's
the problem right maybe it's supposed to
have a space let's go back and take a
look at uh vs
code this has a space in between it
okay this has a space
okay so SSH key
gen key not
working
GitHub it's not uncommon to have issues
like it just happens to me
sometimes
um sometimes we can test it
out we don't have to set the origin
because we cloned it
e that should be fine I'm not really
worried about
that um
SSH key
gen GitHub because maybe they might tell
us like it give us an example and then
um maybe I entered it in wrong maybe it
wants it in a very particular
format because it can be finicky give me
just a second okay so not sure if we
have to do this but maybe we need to add
the SSH or the the key to our our SSS
agent um I remember doing this one time
but normally it usually picks up
anything that's in that directory so I'm
actually kind of surprised but if that's
the case let's go ahead and just
explicitly set it so let's give that a
go and um so we'll just hit up here and
I'm just going to go ahead and type in
SSH
add
and add your SSH private key
okay and that's just RSA there like
that put
enter could not open a connection to
your authentication
agent just a
second um it's suggesting you run this
line again I'm kind of getting the
territory of like doing anything which I
don't really like the SSH program runs
in the back room to hold your private
Keys keeps them ready use by SSH okay
well let's try this um and again this is
why I don't like showing local
development because it's so finicky it's
a lot easier on a Mac but I can't share
my screen on a Mac so I mean you could
but I I it's very difficult for me to do
so so now we've added the the identity
and I'm hoping that now this will work
there are debug commands that you can
use so like GitHub SSH
debug um like here there there is like
this you could run so attempts to
connect to SSH to see if it works so we
could use that and give it a test
um go back over here right and hit
enter hi King you successfully
authenticated but GitHub does not
provide shell access so that's one way
we could test that's a good command to
know
um we'll go here and say put this
here we can test our connection
here we will need to create
our own SSH keyy key
pair RSA key pair so that' be SSH key
gen TR
RSA for uh WSL users and if you create a
[Music]
um you WSL users and if you create a key
in a a
different a if you
create a
non default key you might need to add it
so that was us running that
um like this
here
so that might fix that issue for us um
this is for testing our connection so
that's telling us that we can push okay
and so what I want to do is go back over
to here and let's see if we can push get
push fingers crossed and normally what
happens the first time you add something
it's going to add it uh to the key ring
usually ask us to uh say yes but it's
still not working so I mean that might
establish connection that we can
reach you you successfully authenticated
but does not provide shell access okay
um so our keys still not working we have
permission
denied are we pushing to the right repo
yeah we are it looks like we are um one
thing we could do is check that hidden
folder it's not showing them here
there's some way to show hidden folders
and get not sure why it's not showing up
give me two seconds I've being told the
hcky is control shift G control shift G
if you're on a Mac it might be
Control G that didn't work for me I
tried
it what is
it command shift
period control shift
period nope no good so we'll just go to
our settings and open it up hidden
Files come on show hidden files I just
want to see them show hidden
files files exclude preference
settings
files
um yeah so I I want to see that there we
go so it's it's it's hiding some of them
the reason I want to go here is check
the config I want to make sure that
we're going to ours because if you try
to push to mine let's say you cloned
mine it would not work because you can't
push to mine you don't have permission
to do so but I I should have permission
to push to my own here's another
question when I upload those keys what
account was I in okay I'm in the correct
account so this is the one that I'm
supposed to be
in uh uh is it though because I might
have had another tab open let's make
sure we're 100% in the right location we
are here I'm going to go to SSH
Keys it's not here you think you know
what I think I did I might have added it
to the other account or we deleted it we
didn't add it back in so I'm going to go
ahead and add this
in Windows local you really have to
think these things through and think
okay check check check check check all
right and so I what I want is that SSH
key again I think it's going to work
this
time
okay uh I don't want to add it I just
want to C it
okay and we'll go back up here and we'll
paste it in and we'll hit uh add the key
and now this time I think it's going to
work get
push excellent okay great so that's now
done I want to go back here I'm going to
delete the repo again because we have
one more way that we can do it okay and
the last way is going to be with the
GitHub CLI so I'm on local so I might as
well just go ahead and install it I'm
going to delete this key because I don't
want to have it I want to see if it will
work without a personal access token or
or without SSH so that we can attempt to
log in so what I want to do
here is I want to install uh that and I
believe that it would use Brew or
whatever so type in GitHub CLI install
we'll go
here
and um it's going to be different based
on what you use so if you have home brew
installed you can use Homebrew if it's
Linux um it's going to be
different um I'm looking for Ubuntu in
particular so Debbie and Ubuntu are
basically the same way of installing it
and um I think that we could probably
just do it this way so we need to do a
pseudo app
update I guess I have to put my password
in here is this my password like I don't
know yep that was my password so that's
doing an update once that's done it will
do the next step so I'm going to go grab
this here we're going to go back over to
GitHub codes spaces close this one out I
guess we never saved it that's why it
didn't work um and so our third way
is GitHub
CLI install the
CLI
okay EG Ubuntu for
Linux Okay so in this particular case I
believe this is Ubuntu and that's Ubuntu
they're both
Ubuntu and I'm going to grab the next
line
here and we'll paste that in that's
going to install it could not locate the
package if it couldn't locate the
package it probably doesn't know where
the package is so I have to go back over
here and so this adds The Source that's
what it wants so I'm going to just go
grab this whole darn thing is this all
the same command no it's not but we
we'll grab the whole thing and this will
actually install all of it in one
go
paste you can actually see that it's
doing an update and then it's installing
it here so I'll go back here and update
our
docs a bit
messy
okay and so once that's
installed uh we'll have to do a couple
things we'll have to
do GH
login and then we'll have to do GH clown
and get that link we'll go grab it from
our
repo
um so go here we'll go to code we'll go
to CLI we'll grab this and we'll bring
this on up here and I'm going to do
GP well I want to paste that into our uh
example
here see GH
clone Okay g GH
login now we technically don't need to
log in for uh this to
work should be oh I think it's j off
login that's probably why there we go
GitHub um oh we're going to choose a
method uh
htps authenticate with your GitHub
credentials yeah I thought it was going
to just do something for us but
apparently it's going to have to rely on
on something like that so if that's the
case I think what I would rather do is
use the SSH key so I just hit control C
to log out of that and what I'm going to
do I'm going have to go back and put
that that SSH key back in because we
deleted it um it doesn't matter if you
see mine because you don't have my you
can't see my private key so you really
shouldn't show anyone your public key
but it's not going to hurt that you see
mine um I'm going to go back over to
here and add it again I
guess we're going to go down to here
we're going to add that SSH key Windows
local
okay and then I'm going to go back over
to here we'll type in clear um I want to
just update the doc so that says off
here we'll save that we'll bring this
back up we'll type in clear and I want
to do GH off
login and we'll log with GitHub we'll
use SSH and we'll tell it which key to
use which is pretty cool and the title
for your SSH
[Music]
key well why do I need to upload it
title for your SSH key oh it'll actually
upload it for us oh that's cool okay
clear it let's go back I didn't know
could do that we'll go ahead and hit
delete and we'll try this
again GH login that's really cool I like
that and we'll say SSH I also wonder if
it would generate out your token for you
so we'll use this one and we'll say
windows
local and um we'll log in with a we web
browser first copy this onetime code
into your browser press enter to open
github.com your browser okay I'll hit
enter and I'm going to log in with this
we'll enter that code in we'll continue
and we'll authorize it and so now we're
logged in okay so we can now use GitHub
to clone the the CLI and we'll go back
over to
here okay and we'll copy this and we'll
go back over to here and we'll paste
this in and we should be able to clone
so maybe I I typed that command wrong it
doesn't look right it looks like it's
doubled in here I'll try this again
we'll hit enter sorry try this
again that's not working so I'm doing
something wrong let's go back over to
our docks have it in here
double and uh oh maybe it's like GitHub
repo clone that's probably what it
is there we go and so we clone the
repo all right we'll CD into that
directory as per
usual um we'll go in here and just say
hello get add uh
all get commit say GitHub C way and
we'll say get push oops get
push and that worked okay so that's all
of our ways that we can do it locally
I'm pretty much done with this I'm going
to close it out and so we've
learned um all the ways here so that's
pretty sweet um this get get repo clone
so that's good we learned about
commits
okay um learned about adding we haven't
learned about branching so branching is
pretty straightforward we're going to be
doing a lot of branching so I don't feel
like I have to do a lot here right now
um but uh what we can do here is we can
type in get Branch to get a list of
branch
branches say list of
branches okay and we can go ahead and
create ourselves a new Branch so I'm
going to go ahead and type in get Branch
um and then type a name so we'll say um
Dev and I'll hit enter
so create a new
branch Branch
name if I type in get Branch I can get a
list of them okay and so I can check out
that Branch so we'll
say check out the
branch get Branch I'm sorry get
checkout
Dev get checkout Dev and notice I'm in
dep this highlighting stuff here will
not be in your local terminal uh you
might have to install something or
additional or invs code it may or may
not show up just understand that this is
pre-loaded with some stuff in here um so
we're in Dev right now we're actually in
a different branch so I'm going to do um
get
um uh I want to change this file here so
we go ahead and just change
it uh where is it'll
refresh oh you know the thing is is that
we've been making changes but we haven't
been doing them in here so if I do get
fetch for a second
you'll notice that origin main is
there's more going on here than you than
you think and so by doing fetch we can
actually see if we're out of date or not
um and so my issue right now is there's
that file I don't have access to it but
I'm going to go ahead and make it again
I'm say hello here and I'll say uh
Branch
version okay and I'm going to do get
status and so we have that there um so
what we can do is go ahead and go get
add all and I'll say get commit hyphen M
uh
changes
okay and now what I want to do is get
push and push that branch and right away
you're going to notice that it's not
going to work and the reason why is that
Branch does not have a remote right
that's really important because if it
doesn't have a remote reference it's not
going to be able to push and there is no
branch in our GitHub repo right now if
we go back to our repo um
in mine is listed over here remember
your name is different than my name so
type
yours GitHub examples let's go
here into
here um you know I have a branch here it
should well we don't have one yet we
haven't created one yet so that's one
thing uh that we need to make note of
um so the thing is and the other thing
is like
um have we been making these changes
this entire time yeah we have um but
anyway
so yeah we have a
branch that's that locally but we don't
have one that exists yet and so the idea
is that we want to we can either create
the branch and then push to it or we can
basically run this command and do it in
one go okay so what I'm going to do is
type in get push and I'm actually going
to type in U because that's a much
shorter version of this I'm going type
in origin
Dev okay and now it is tracking our Dev
to the remote Dev if we go over here
this Branch might exist now okay and if
we drop down you can see Dev is there we
haven't pushed anything into it if you
go to commits our new commits not there
yet right go to main you'll notice main
is over
here
right um my point is is that uh we need
to for this to work we will need to um
uh push this change so we have this one
file and I'm going to go ahead and say
uh get
status
okay oh did we actually push it oh I
think we accidentally pushed it so maybe
we did make that
change yeah we did it's over here okay
sorry so I thought we had not pushed it
yet but we did um now the question is
how do we visualize this in a way that
is easy to read and that's where we
would have an extension normally there's
one installed like in git pod they'll
have pre-installed but apparently this
one doesn't um so what we'll do is go to
extensions we'll type in get
tree okay because I want to be able to
see what we're doing and there's G graph
so G graph is the one I usually use I
think we'll go ahead and install that
there's another
one um I'm not sure like get
lens some of these can get pretty crazy
so I try to keep it really simple get
history yeah we'll stick with G graft
and so once get graph is installed if we
go over to here we should have a new
icon up
here um and so I don't see it sometimes
down below it'll be down here so I can
click this no that doesn't help either
and so maybe what we need to do is
reload our environment for it to show up
I'm going to hit Refresh on here and
just hit enter and so hopefully what
this will do is load it up again so we
can see that because I want to see that
g
graph what do you mean doesn't
exist uh okay
it's telling me it didn't exist because
I hit a refresh there
um okay I'll open up code spaces because
it seems like it's confused right
now this one's
running open in browser we'll try this
again
here give it a moment to
reopen what do you mean ites doesn't
exist it's right here you're crazy we
have it open so it's saying it doesn't
exist but we clearly have it
open but it's opening the dogit
directory okay let's CD back for a
second what is going
on oh no I really don't want to lose my
changes I don't think I'm going to
because everything's pushed but this is
where it's kind of acting weird again I
don't use gith GitHub codes spaces I
prefer git pod but this one's acting a
little bit funny um and so in this case
I'm not 100% sure what to do because it
does exist
here so what I'm going to do is stop
this code
space okay and I'm going to start it up
again and maybe what this will
do is it will un Jank
it okay so I'll be back here once once
it stops and then restarts it takes a
little bit of time okay okay it shows me
this button I'm going to hit restart
start code workspace and hopefully this
will resolve our
issue it's saying the workspace does not
exist the terminal process failed to
launch the starting directory so it's
getting confused I don't know what's
going on here but this workspace is is
defunct so what I'm going to do is again
stop this workspace we'll open up code
spaces I'm going to stop this
one and I'm going to delete it because
it's not really doing what I wanted to
do I'm not going to lose anything
because everything we worked on we
should have pushed at this
point but uh yeah you just got to be
careful code spaces because it kind of
Acts a little
funny but uh we'll go back over
here and what I'm going to do is I
actually want to open up this Branch we
have the two branches but I want to open
up code spaces in this Branch I'm going
to go ahead and drop this down I'm going
to say create a code space on dev okay
and so hopefully we don't run into any
more issues it looks like it's losing
all my settings so it's not persisting
them uh there are ways to persist
them syncing settings
um there's an option I think here we go
into here because this is going to drive
me crazy if we don't do this and we'll
say automatically detect not DOT files
but um sync settings so I'm going to
click this and I'm hoping that what this
will do is anytime we change branches or
stuff it's going to remember my settings
I don't want to keep changing them so
I'm going to go here and it should be
syncing settings now
I'm going to go and change my theme
again and I'm going to go over to
settings I'm going to go to uh uh I'll
change the font size to 20 here 20 was a
bit too large we'll say terminal
font here I'll change this to
18 okay and so I also want to make sure
that my extension's installed so I'll
try this
again personally I think they should
have this pre-installed that's the other
one so there's get log graph and get
graph I'm going to install both of these
because I actually like both of them to
be
honest and uh we can add this to our Dev
container yeah make a new Dev
container um I don't know make an empty
Dev
container I want whatever the base one
is
base Bare
Bones you know I just want the
configuration I'm going to go ahead and
just say barebones Ruby here
sure and just say Okay I I don't want
that so I'm just trying to create this
file in here so it knows to remember our
extensions um for this
repo go back and do that also for here
it should remember it but in case it
doesn't I'm going to put this in here
and I'm going to go modify the step
container this is also something we're
going to learn about later on um I don't
want to build anything so I'm just going
to take this out here here and I'm just
going
to take this out as well U just
say basic
config get graph I don't see the other
one added there I'm G to go back over
here and try this again get
graph um add to Dev
container there they're both added there
but the reason I'm doing that is I
really want to get these tools in here
so now they're here they show up here
and they show up down below so this is
one of them we'll open that up it's
before I made a pull request and there's
the other one so I just want to show you
there's more than one kind of tool that
you can visualize the stuff and
sometimes it give you different
information and so right now we're here
we're in Dev
okay and we added that one those couple
changes over here and the idea is that
we branched over here so this doesn't
know about these changes and vice versa
and we got a whole lot going on here
okay and so this is is where we get into
things like merging so if we want to
bring um Dev up to date with main which
we really should do we should merge main
into Deb and that's what I'm going to do
so I'm in dab I'm going to type in get
merge
main um and sorry I should I should note
that there's origin Main and then main
so that's there's what's on Origin
there's what's on our local Main and so
our local Main might not have this stuff
okay if I go over here it's a bit more
clear because it shows them as separate
thing so our head shows us exactly where
we are right now we have origin Dev
origin main so I'm going to do a get
fetch because I want to know where we
are right now and it looks like we're
all up to date so we're
fine what I'm going to do is I'm going
to type in
get
merge
Main and it's saying did you mean to
merge no I wanted to merge Main and so
it looks like we don't have a local
branch of
main okay so what I'm going to do is
type in get checkout
main okay and so now if we go back up
here we maybe there's some way to
refresh this like a refresh button
notice there's two now okay so before it
didn't even know there was a main I did
check out and immediately it said there
was no main branch but it said oh you
have one on Origin main we'll just add
it here now it's here okay so now we
have a main and I can go back
to
Dev and I'm just going to do get fet
it's just out of habit and so now we see
both of them here okay so now I'm going
to do get
merge
main it says we have a conflict okay and
the reason why is that we went ahead and
we changed read me and that other file
and they exist there as well and so
sometimes you have to resolve
conflicts okay so this say Auto merging
merging conflict automatic merge failed
fa fix the conflictions in order to
complete this here and so normally what
happens if you
pull or sorry if you try to do if you
try to do a pull or you try to merge and
there's a conflict you have to resolve
it and so notice right away that now we
have new files over here this wasn't
here before we go here we can see type
in get status it wants us to resolve it
and the message is a little bit
different here says you have un unmerged
paths so we gotta fix this here and so
it's showing us in this file we have two
versions which one do you want to keep
the top one or the bottom
one so I'm going to just take the top
part and take out this part because we
don't want that
committed and so these it had no
problem and so what I want to do is I
just want to go ahead and add this and
we're basically just adding everything
uh adding everything at this point so
I'm say get add all and then I going to
say
get commit and in this case you do not
want to put a a get commit message in
here because it needs to put it its own
in here I'm going to hit enter and it's
going to open and this is the this is
the merge message it has to be this you
don't ever set this so notice I typed in
get commit and it also filled it in here
and so all I'm going to do is close this
and now it's merged it so if we go back
over here now we can see it
represented okay so we took that and we
brought that up to dat right okay so and
the reason we want to do that is so that
when we merge back into main we don't
have to deal with conflicts you really
don't want to deal with conflicts
merging in main you want to do deal with
those those conflicts in your branch
before you merge back in main okay so
that's good now what we can do is now
that we're all up to date we can
continue to work on our readme file so I
don't need this dogger file this wasn't
supposed to be here but that's a great
opportunity for us to delete it because
I don't want to launch up a ruby
environment um so what I'm going to do
is type in
get um get
remove
well first I want to yeah get
remove Docker
file no no no I don't want to do that um
I just want I'm going to go ahead and
delete this here we'll just delete this
permanently so if we go over here this
should show up here yeah we can do
that I think we could have just typed in
if we deleted the file it would show up
there anyway but um G remove is a bit
funny because you can have files you
want to remove from tracking that are in
your repo to say stop tracking this
forever
um or uh if there's even there's pre
previous versions of it and there's
removing the file so we'll just delete
and now we'll keep it simple so I'm
going say get ad and we'll say get
commit hyphen M remove Docker file we
don't want to build a Ruby Ruby
environment um so this I have to put a
single comma there so I need to point
out that like we can rebuild our codes
space um and and then it would build
that Docker file but but we'd have to
manually do that because it won't do
that until we rebuild it manually but
anyway so we have that Chang there and
I'm going to go ahead and do a get push
and we go back and take a look and we
can see that this is now pushed up to
date it wasn't pushed there a moment ago
and so now Main's starting to get out of
date but let's go over to our readme
file in our crash course and what I want
to do here so I want to do a few a bit
more
documentation so we'll go down here here
below and
so we can add
remotes but often you will just add
remotes when you are doing uh when
you via
Upstream when adding a
branch so be get
Branch um U origin new
feature but you could do it like a get
remote at I like I rarely ever do that
so I I don't feel like really covering
that here that would be something I
would actually cover in a proper uh get
crash course
um I don't know if we really need to do
stashing right now we could leave it or
take it get merge
main so get checkout Dev get merge
main
okay so I like we've done a lot here I
don't want to overload you folks um I
think I'll just show you stashing really
quick so um let's
say let's say I wasn't I wanted to work
on something else and I just wanted to
move this to a side and come back to it
later what I can do is add all the file
so it's
staged get status okay and I could just
stash these for layer I type in get
stash and what that will do is it will
put it in in I'll just put it somewhere
okay it'll put in my stash if I type in
get stash list it's here in my stash
okay and I can bring it back and say get
stash pop and pop it off the stash and
bring it back you wouldn't want to do
this in a cloud developer environment
because you could lose changes but if
you're in a local developer environment
you might just have stashes and just
hold on to them for a long time but a
lot of times you need to move things out
of the way but usually you want to name
your stash so you'll say get stash save
and then say
um read me change
so we know exactly what it is and then
we can do get stash list and see what's
there and then we can say get stash
apply and instead of popping it'll just
apply the last one um so there are some
commands there that are useful so we
have get stash
list get stash get
stash save my name then get
stash
uh apply a pop and we have apply and
then we have get stash pop okay so those
are really useful I use them all the
time again I'm hoping that as we go
through this course we'll run into
scenarios where we need to use them um
but I do actually want to add this so
I'm going to go ahead and get get
commit hyph M minor
updates um I'm just going to refresh
this make sure I have that latest one
there sometimes you miss them and I'm
going to go ahead and do that
and I just want to show you what the
graph looks like so you can see even
shows the stashes as well and dev's in
front of it we're going to do get
push
okay now let's say we wanted to do a
pull request that's something we're
going to learn later in more detail but
I'm going to just do it really quickly a
common thing that you should do is open
up pull request so
um I'm kind of done with this uh
workspace I'm going to go ahead and just
close it out because I think the rest of
this we don't need to do in here I'm
going to go ahead and stop this okay we
can leave it in this state if we come
decide to come back to this but I'm
going to just stop it for now and I want
to go back to our
repo
GitHub Andie
Brown and we'll go to our
repo and I'm going to go ahead and open
up a new pull request so I'll go here
I'm going to create a new po request and
I want to have the polar request come
from Dev
into this it's showing me everything I'm
not sure why it's doing that but I'm
going to go here and go from
Dev into Maine and from Andrew Brown
into Andrew Brown I want to be into my
own I want to merge I want to make a
pull request into my own there we go
it's simplified that's what you should
see and so what I'll go go ahead to do
is hit create pull request and the idea
is that this would be an opportunity for
people to review it so uh will you
accept my code
right and the idea is that somebody's
supposed to review it now because I'm
the only one in my own repo
um I'm just going to merge it myself and
confirm that and so the idea is that
that is now merged if we were in GitHub
we would see that that was now merged
into main okay all right so now what I
want to show you is just the last thing
is I just want to show you how I would
bring these changes into my Fork so I'm
going to switch back into my other
account actually before I do that I'm
going to go ahead and go into my poll
request and I'm going to create a new
pull request and I'm going to make a
pull request from Main from this GitHub
account into the exam Pro one the base
one I'm going to go ahead and create
this poll request I'm not telling you to
do this please don't do this because I
don't want to deal with a bunch of pull
requests this will be uh documentation
changes documentation for
GitHub uh or sorry
git crash course I think I called this
like GitHub crash course which it should
be really GitHub git crash sces show me
the
basics of G okay so go ahead and create
that pull
request all right and the thing is like
I can't merge it from here because I
don't own that other one so what I'll do
is switch over to
this and now I'm going to go and see
that there's a poll request and it's
coming in from Andrew Brown oh how nice
of this person and I'm going to go take
a look here and I can see that they have
some changes and I can go and review
their C Cod and then ask them to make
fixes I can go here and say hey do this
do that and then I might accept it but
I'm going to go ahead and approve it I
don't need to approve it here because
there's no required reviewers for this
but I'll just say it's
approved and then we'll go over to code
and I'm going to go ahead and sorry pull
requests I'm going to go ahead and merge
this stuff in because I I want this
stuff okay and we'll merge that in and
now it's merged just one other thing I
want to want to see if I actually named
this right get crash course yeah it's
named right okay great and so there's
our stuff that's all the stuff we
learned was this a mess yes could I have
taught this a lot better if I organized
it yeah but I got to record the rest of
the course and again you know if I'm
going to make a a proper get crash
course I'll do it somewhere else um but
I just want to get you the basics and
hopefully that was helpful we wasted a
lot of time on cloning but that's
something that's really important to
know how to do and I'll see you in the
next one
ciao
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown from exam Pro
and we are taking a look at get commit
so we're going to take a look at a
series of G components uh in this course
um it's not really a focus on get skills
but more so GitHub but I want to make
sure you still have some git skills so
after we go through uh some of these
things I'll then do like a really quick
and dirty uh git uh command crash course
okay so a g commit represents
incremental changes to a codebase
represented with a git tree so a graph
at a specific time so here we can see
that git tree um this is in GitHub so
it's not the full representation when we
go into U vs code we will we can see a
better representation of it there are
external tools for that but for the most
part the idea is that you have um uh you
have get commits that are over a
historical period of time then we have
have our uh git commit here is one
within uh GitHub that I clicked through
and I looked at okay and from here a get
commit contains additional modifications
deletions of files uh additions and
deletions of file contents and it's not
the whole file themselves and this is a
strategy to make the uh commits
efficient because if you if you were to
store full copies in every single commit
your repo would get really big really
fast I'm going to repeat that again and
we'll talk about the contents of commit
fils here just shortly each commit has a
Shaw hash that acts as an ID so it looks
something like this we can use this uh
to check out very specific commits which
is very useful I want to repeat git does
not store the whole files in each commit
but rather the state of changes this
greatly reduces the file size so uh so
for developers to the developer you it
will look like a whole file but really
when you store it in in uh your git tree
it's not going to be like that um so
what are the components of a git commit
we talked a little bit about that but we
have that commit hash that is a unique
Shaw one hash identifier for the commit
I don't know if it's really Shaw one
because I'm not really familiar with all
the different types of Shaw but it's
Shaw something uh we have the author
information so we have name and email
often you have to configure git to say
what email you're utilizing the name so
that's attached to the commit message uh
or the commit itself you have the commit
message this is the description of uh
the the Commit This is we're going to be
spending a lot of time when you are
making commits because you want to write
good commit messages you have a time
stamp so this is the day and time when
the commit was made um you have the
parent commit hash this is a sha and
hash of the Commit This commit is based
on I don't really understand that
because I've never had to bother with
the parent one but it is something
that's in there and the snapshot of the
content a snapshot of the project at the
time the commit not the actual files but
references to them and the changes that
are occurring so if you had vs code open
and we were taking a look at a um at uh
changes that we have staged so they
haven't been committed yet but you can
see here we have uh the commit message
it says remove old comments we have
files changed that we plan on putting in
the commit and you can see some
deletions there on the right hand side
we can have additions so hopefully it's
very clear what a uh a git commit is you
are going to need to know these basic
commands and we will get a little bit
practice again quick and dirty this is
not a full-blown git course but it'll be
enough to get you by so that you can do
the GitHub stuff so we have a bunch of
stuff there like get add get remove get
Comm message with the The Hyphen m flag
to add a message hyphen a to
automatically stage all track changes if
you have a commit you haven't pushed it
up uh to your uh your remote repo you
can amend it
um you can create empty commits uh you
can specify the author if you need to
you can check out a very specific commit
but yeah that is get commits in a
nutshell I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao hey this is Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at git Branch so G branch
is a Divergence of the state of the repo
there might be better uh descriptions
than that but that's the way I think of
it you can think of branches as being
copies of a point in time that have been
modified to be different and so what I
want to do is Step you through what it
would look like working with get
branches and this is going to be a
little bit messy and it doesn't matter
if you can remember or make sense of all
this because it will make more sense
when we start working with it but do
your best to follow along here so
imagine we have a git repo in that git
repo we have a main branch and basically
all git repos have a main branch and
that's pretty much the standard name for
them now and we're going to also have a
production Branch so the main branch is
where we're going to have code uh that
features and bugs will be um rolled up
into and then when we're ready to push
it out for production it will go to the
production branch and some cicd tool
we'll push it out and automatically
deploy it so um let's imagine we already
have a commit in the main branch uh
maybe there are previous versions in the
production Branch we're not going to
worry about it so uh you have developer
a developer a needs to to work on a very
specific feature they're going to open
up a feature branch and in there they're
going to put in some commits and they're
working along uh meanwhile in the
company somebody already has pushed some
stuff into the main branch it's not
ready to go in production but that
commit is now out so what's important to
note here is that feature Branch one is
not aware of that new commit because
things are happening asynchronous a in
async manner in different branches and
this is the challenge with get is that
you have to deal with all this Asing
stuff and make sure you bring those
changes into yours deal with conflicts
things like that now let's say we have
developer B and developer B is working
on feature Branch to and when they
started on their on their um uh their
feature they decided to Branch from this
point in time okay and so they start
working on it and they get their feature
uh done and um they get they talk to
their um uh the director of engineering
and and they make a poll request the
poll request gets accepted it gets
merged back into main okay and
so developer a who's working on uh
feature Branch one has all these changes
that they still don't have so let's
remember that they're going to have to
deal with that at some point but anyway
that feature got merged into Main and it
looks like it's ready to go into
production so it gets merged into
production and so this particular commit
contains I'm G get my pen out here
contains all of this information right
and it's all packed into here if that
makes sense okay I'm just going to erase
that here and so that gets ped
production and it gets tagged a lot of
cicd systems will trigger when a tag is
applied that's definitely how I do it
but now coming back to developer a
they're on feature Branch one and they
have all the stuff um that they need to
get their Branch up to date so what
they'll do is they'll merge back in in
their Direction I know it doesn't show a
merge but they'll merge that information
into feature Branch one so they are now
up to date and they have now finish
their feature by doing a bit extra work
and so they've merged back into into the
main branch and now their stuff is to be
rolled up to production so it gets
merged into production and then that
gets Tagged so hopefully that gives you
kind of an idea of uh this kind of
workflow this should have really been
like that uh and this actually has a
very particular name it's called the
GitHub flow now there are some
variations of this so that's why I say
very close to it because in case I'm
wrong I want to have that buffer to say
that well I didn't say this is exactly
the GitHub workflow but this more or
less is the GitHub workflow where you
are creating branches feature branches
merging it back into some other branch
and then you have a branch for
production uh you can have branches for
all sorts of things you can have
specific environment Branch branches
like staging development production you
can have specific branches to developers
so like based on their names you can
have branches per feature features
branches per bugs is going to be based
on what your team wants to do all right
uh there are definitely get Branch
commands you should absolutely know and
we will do again a quick quick and dirty
crash course so you are familiar with it
this is a extremely common pattern that
you're going to find that you'll be
doing which is you'll be creating a new
Branch for a feature you're going to be
adding changes you're going to be
pushing it Upstream we might do this via
vs code using the G CLI we might be
doing this using using GitHub uh
creating a branch from an issue but
we'll definitely be doing this because
this is something that happens a lot um
in professional um uh teams is that
they're creating feature branches so
hopefully that makes sense and again if
it doesn't wait till we go ahead and do
it and then it will make more sense then
okay
[Music]
ciao hey this is Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at get repos so these
represent the reference to a remote
location where a copy of your repo is
hosted so when I say remote get remote
I'm saying remote reference or remote
ref you might see those terms uh used
all over the place uh you can have
multiple remote entries uh or remote
references for your git repo and the
most common one you're going to see is
called origin it's almost always uh
there everybody seems to use it it
indicates the central or golden repo
everyone is working from and represents
the source of Truth
uh the remote entries or references are
stored in your dogit config we don't
really talk about this dogit folder in
any of the slides but the dogit folder
is how you know that your project is a
uh has a a git repo in it because it
needs that folder uh to initialize a git
repo we'll look at that in the quick and
dirty crash course um so in here in the
config file you can see we have remote
defined so this format of a file is
called a toml file um so anytime you see
those Square braces and then definitions
that's usually a toml file but I'm just
going to get my pen tool out here the
idea here is we're saying we uh we have
a remote named origin and the URL is
pointing to our GitHub repo this part
says how it should fetch I'm not going
to get into that right now and then down
below we can see we have some branches
that we are tracking and they're
pointing to remote origin and then they
they're saying that we want to merge um
there so hopefully that is clear notice
remote names can be referenced so we
have origin up here and it's referencing
this up here okay so I'm just going to
clear my annotations here so this is a
little bit more clear and there are a
bunch of get remote commands you should
know I don't remember the most like the
git remote ad I don't ever remember that
one because often when you clone it's
going to add them anyway and so usually
you pull them from GitHub but you should
know push you should know pull you
should know fetch uh and when you are
creating branches you should know um how
to uh push upstream and we'll talk about
upstream and downstream next
[Music]
okay all right let's talk about the
concepts of upstream and downstream so
imagine we have GitHub who is hosting
our remote repository and then we have
our local developer environment or Cloud
developer environment uh this is local
basically where we are doing our work
and so they both have a main repo
because we know that git is
decentralized so we can have repos in
more than one place we might already
have some commits on the remote side but
what's going to glue these two together
is going to be the remote and so we set
up a remote tracking Branch okay and and
you'll see that turn when you create uh
and you push branches up because the
idea is that it's tracking uh the origin
is pointing to main so this is the way
we track them uh we saw that was stored
in theg getconfig so when we go ahead
and we perform a poll from our local
developer environment we call this
Downstream we're pulling Downstream so a
repo that pulls or clones from another
repo and just understand this is
relative to the direction or the
perspective um of who's pulling so if
the remote was pulling it would be down
stream it's it's anytime you're pulling
it's always Downstream and now imagine
we have commits we've been working
locally we want to push those up to
remote we would call that Upstream so
this is when you are pushing changes so
that's Upstream that's Downstream and
when we have a remote reference it is a
tracking Branch so there you go
[Music]
okay hey this is angre brown we are
taking a look at GitHub flow so this is
a lightweight workflow for multiple
developers working on a single repo
there's a lot of variations on this uh
so this is not a technically perfect
description of it but there really isn't
one and I want to show you a really old
graphic um I don't know how old this is
but I've seen this in older ones maybe
all the way back to 2008 at least and I
remember before GitHub flow because
GitHub came or sorry git came out in
2005 and it took a few years to gain
adoption
so for a long period for a few years we
just had a mess of stuff and then
somebody came up with this maybe it was
GitHub I'm not sure but uh it's called
the GitHub flow and um here we have a
bunch of branches and it looks very
similar to the one that I showed you in
get Branch it's a little bit different
and so the big difference is that well
first of all uh we don't call it Master
anymore we call it main but my main was
the develop branch and then I would call
this Branch master I would have called
it production because I think that makes
more sense and a lot of people do that
these days but when it first came out
this is how we were doing it okay so
understand as variation but the idea is
that you have this one branch I call it
main this is developed and it holds
things that um that uh that hold feature
branches or hot fixes and everything
it's basically like rolls everything up
but it's not in production yet and so
the idea is that when these things are
ready for um production you can push
them out into a release Branch a release
Branch could be also called staging
that's normally what we call uh today
and this could be where it would roll
out so once you push stuff here this
could go out and execute a cicd pipeline
and it would set up a staging
environment so that QA could be done on
it or any kind of load balancing could
be done on it or stress testing um there
and the idea is that as developers you
would open up feature branches off of
develop and as you complete them they
would come back in here uh and they
would get merged in and then when things
were really ready you take it take it
from uh release branches and push it out
to your production branch which they're
calling uh here uh Master if for
whatever reason you had a serious
problem you had to fix really quickly
you could um uh create a branch off a
master into the hot fixes and then merge
it back in skipping all the stuff down
below uh you know again I wouldn't do it
this way anymore I would be surprised if
companies are sticking uh to this method
but this is the original way I just
wanted to show you that there is
variation um and you know a lot of
people do skip having a release branch
and they'll just deploy often and into
production so it's going to be really
dependent on your team so here we'll
just kind of loosely describe GitHub
flow you create a branch for each new
task or feature create a new Branch off
the main branch add commits make changes
in commits commit them to your branch
open a poll request start a discussion
about your commits reviewing code in the
poll request discuss a review share your
poll requests with teammates for
feedback deploy test your changes in
production environment um so yeah oh and
the last thing would be merge so once
your changes are verified merge them
into the main branch so that's the
general concepts of it and hopefully
that makes sense and we will see you in
the next
[Music]
one hey this is Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at the GitHub CLI so this
is a command line interface to interact
with your GitHub account you can quickly
perform common GitHub actions without
leaving your developer environment and
uh if you went through the quick and
dirty um git uh crash course then you
definitely got some exposure to GitHub
CLI but the idea is that you'd have to
log in you can perform actions there so
we have something like creating a repo
creating an issue uh reviewing a PR
there's a lot of uh CLI commands uh the
get up clii can be installed on Windows
Linux or Mac OS um that's an example of
using Brew to install it if you have it
for um uh Dev containers you can specify
it as a feature to get installed so that
is a very easy and quick way to have it
uh installed there and just to give an
idea of commands we have our core
commands we have a lot of additional
commands and then we have one specific
to GitHub uh actions command so we're
definitely going to get some exposure uh
to GitHub CLI uh in this course but
there you
go
[Music]
all right so in this follow along I want
to take a look at the GitHub CLI and see
if we can do a few different things with
it what I'm going to do is switch over
to my other account um this is just my
uh playaround account for for GitHub and
we should already have a repo in here
called GitHub examples and what I want
to do is I want to um you know just do
some things in the CLI so I need some
kind of environment to work in and so
what we'll do is launch up a code space
uh we do have this older one
um I think what I'll do is make a new
one I don't think it really matters if
we make an old or new one that other one
is stopped so we'll open this one up and
we'll see if the GitHub CLI is already
pre-installed it could be pre-installed
on this because I would think that if
well if I was GitHub I would have it
pre-installed so people could start
using my product right away but if it's
not we'll definitely go ahead and take a
look at how to install it we did install
it manually locally um in the git crash
course a quick and dirty crash course so
uh you know if we don't have to show the
install I'd rather skip that but we'll
wait for this to spin up okay I have no
idea why but that took a little bit time
to spin up um you know our goal isn't to
really make anything just to play around
with the um the CLI here the code space
is currently running in recovery mode
due to configuration error I didn't do
anything I don't care it's um I mean
it's a new environment why should it be
recovering is there something it can't
do yeah I'm not sure about this so what
I'm going to do because I don't trust
this
workspace is um this one is running
here I don't know we'll just see what we
can do with it but it didn't pick up myh
settings when I told it to save it
earlier so I don't know if it's because
it's in recovery mode or not but for the
time being I'm going to go ahead and
change the theme so I'm not upset there
we go that's a lot better and I want to
see if we
have um GH install so it's not installed
which is totally fine um so what I'm
going to
do
is if we had this installed can we
install it through here sometimes you
can install stuff through plugins
right and so I'm just curious if we
could do that there no okay so that's
fine we'll go ahead and install this and
I definitely know that Brew is installed
or maybe it's not installed on this
let's find out it is installed on git
pod but I'm not sure about GitHub it's
not okay so what we'll do is we'll look
up the GitHub CLI and we'll go ahead and
install it we already did this before
but we'll do it again and what we're
looking for is those install
instructions and we want it for um Linux
okay so we'll go over into here into
Linux and we'll grab this oneline
command it looks like a lot but it's
really just doing this update and this
install like down here but it has to add
the repo so it knows where to install it
from but I'm going to grab that big
thing there and we're going to go ahead
and paste that on in say allow and hit
enter
and um it failed it failed and I can't
look at I can't see what I'm doing so
I'm G to bump up this font I do not like
GitHub code spaces I'm so sorry I really
like G pod and we're going to go here
and say terminal
font I'll try not to complain too much
about it in the course but uh I can't
promise anything I'm going to copy that
again and we'll try this again it hit
enter no such file directory okay
um yeah I don't know what you want so
there's this line
here
okay maybe because gpg gpg isn't
installed sometimes you don't have to do
a gpg check but we might have to with
this and
um failure to write destination okay so
if that's not working maybe what we
could do in an easier way is we could
just add it
um to the
uh uh to the that this file this code
space is file so we could just make a
Dev container um and maybe that would be
less of an issue so what I'll do is I
want to add a Dev container um we'll go
up to here Dev
container like that we actually already
have one from before and maybe we can
just throw it in
here so grab this maybe we do want to
commit this maybe this is a good good
idea um and so I'll put this
here and I need a comma there and so the
idea here is that this should install
the CLI into this environment and maybe
the reason why this thing messed up was
because it wasn't specifying any base
image and that's why it got upset
because when we did this in the tutorial
earlier um it kind of complained or
sorry like when we spun this up it
complained but we didn't specify a base
image so I'm going to look up what the
base image is for Dev
container the base image for GitHub is
and maybe that will help
us if that doesn't help let's go let's
go ask chaty
BT log in let me in let me
in come on I pay for this let me
in what is the what is the base image
used for uh Dev
container
for GitHub Cod
spaces let's see if that can figure it
out it's probably just going to go to
the um the documentation but um I don't
remember where it is
so if you don't specify one it will
create in the default one okay that's
what I would rather it do so I'm going
to leave it alone and what I want to do
is rebuild uh this environment because
we've added this change before we do I
need to commit this maybe so just say um
it should install the GitHub CLI go
ahead and do
that and I'll say
okay so it should sync it up good and so
let's see if we can find the rebuild I'm
clicking up here rebuild that's no good
we can open up the command pallet this
way command pallet has all the commands
for for vs code and there should
probably be something for codes space so
if I type in codes spaces there's
probably something here to rebuild there
it is rebuild container so I'm going to
go ahead and rebuild that container I'm
going to go ahead and hit rebuild and so
I'm hoping that we'll install the CLI
and that avoids us having to install gpg
or whatever it wants because that's a
headache and I don't want to deal with
that so see you back here when this
finish is building okay all right we're
in it says the code space is currently
running in recovery mode due to a
configuration ER please review the
creation logs update your Dev container
as needed or rebuild the container so
clearly doesn't like something about my
file I'm not really sure because there's
not a whole lot in it uh
um so we have command control shift p
okay control shift p hey like learning's
learning right and uh we want to view
creation blogs oh that's just to open up
the uh command
pallet view creation
log and somewhere here it's messing up
now I don't understand how it could be
messing up because we literally have
next nothing in
it
um
yeah this is supposed to be an easy easy
GitHub CLI
tutorial failed to create the container
an error occurred unified containers
error creating fail doesn't even tell us
why it's just like nope it doesn't work
maybe it's up here
um no matching entries and P unable to
find us your Dev container okay maybe
it's this
okay let's take this out all right and
uh that's probably the reason why okay
so we'll save that okay we'll have to
update that don't change remote
user
okay want Push to Main and I'm going to
try to rebuild this
again I'll open up command pallet down
here below just in case and I want to
say
rebuild
um I want to do like a full rebuild
let's do a full
rebuild that's fine let's rebuild and
we'll get it going this next one okay
I'll see you back in a
moment okay so I think that resolve the
issue it took a while for that to
rebuild but what I want to see is if the
C is in here so I'm going to type in GH
and there it is okay great so that's the
easy way to get in there as long as you
don't make any mistakes in your Dev
container uh Jason or J yes or Json Json
file and so let's go ahead and see what
kind of actions we can perform so what
I'll do is go over and type in GitHub
CLI and we'll take a look at the
documentation and see that's not what I
want I want the uh official
documentation so we can see what kind of
commands we can get here it is okay so
here's all of our commands and the
question first is are we logged in
because that's something we might need
to do so let's go ahead and type in GH
login oh sorry GH off log in to log the
C and we have two options we'll do
github.com it says the value of the
GitHub token environment is being used
for authentication to uh okay so it
sounds like we already are authenticated
because of um get up code spaces and
it's loading some kind of temporary um
token in here something we could check
here is to see if there actually is a
token being set so I'm going to type in
EnV grep and we'll type in
GH and I don't see anything there but
apparently it seems to think that it is
ready to utilize so maybe what we could
do is list out repos so I imagine if we
go here there's probably something like
list there is and we could try to list
our repos so let's go ahead and try that
GH repo
list and we have a repo that's actually
a really nice display what else can we
take a look at here
um so again back over to the
repo we can list our repo what if we go
to view what would that do let's take a
look GH repo
View and I was hoping that it would set
it would select the current one but
apparently it didn't but we can do uh GH
repo set
default
and I got to type it right maybe it'll
let us choose the repo so we don't have
to goof around and so there it is we can
choose one and apparently we have two
exam Pro and the Andrew WC Brown curious
that it's showing forked ones but this
is the one I want CU this is the account
I'm in right now and so let's go ahead
and type in GH repo
View and so now we can see some stuff in
here um not a lot of information it
looks like it's kind of the information
about maybe the description or stuff
like that so I was hoping to see a
little bit more there but that's okay
let's go down here and see what else we
can
do um we could edit our
repo like we could change features turn
things on or
off that's not that interesting
something we might want to do is maybe
we might want to uh maybe change our
labels let's go ahead and try that out
so I'm going go here and say GH labels
list um is it just label or labels
label oh cool yeah we can see our codes
can we add a new one in here
uh we'll go to
create so GH label so we try this one
here copy it paste it
in and there already is a bug so we
can't have
two so I'll go here and just say
um
danger something really not
right we'll hit enter and so it looks
like we've created another label let's
go ahead and hit up okay so that looks
really good there bug isn't working good
um if we wanted to create a new repo
sometimes what they'll do is they'll um
they'll create like a uh a wizard in
here so if I typed in GH create repo and
I said
um
GitHub we just we'll just do this I bet
it will prompt
us oh I got to type it right I seem to
be typing everything wrong here today
repo
create and so it'll ask us some things
like create a repo from a template
repository make a new one so I could do
this say
GitHub um
repo GitHub CLI
example and I'll just go hit enter here
I'll just make this one private I could
add a readme file we could add a Gore we
could say what we want the get ignore to
be so maybe it's for
C++ now let's add a license we could
choose apachi
2.0 um we want to do this we'll say yes
and it seems like it should have created
but we get a resource not accessible by
integration for 43 so I'm not 100% sure
as to why we're getting that it could be
a permissions issue because everything
is based on um that token right and so
maybe we have a personal access token
that allows us to read but not write um
and we got a 403 right so 403 error is
for forbidden meaning we don't have
access to do it so what I'm thinking is
that we can probably create our own um
personal access token and try to get
around that so we going to go to
settings here I'm going to go all the
way down develop for settings and we're
going to go into personal access tokens
find grain tokens and we'll generate a
new token again I don't know if this
will work but I'm just going to try it
so we'll just say um uh repo
access right let us create a repo and
I'm I'm going to set this for tomorrow
because I don't need it forever and if
it's for all repos then that's a
challenge right but then how would you
create a
token this is public repos so here it
says this applies to current and future
repos owned by this resource all all
includes public repos read
only so the other question is is it
because we tried to make it a private
repo but then why would it have it as an
option if we can do that I mean we could
also authenticate uh via SSH so I'm not
sure so I guess that's where I'm not
100%
sure so maybe we'll just say all repos
here and we'll go to repo
permissions and I'm looking specifically
for
repos contents
no and carefully looking here to try to
find
that uh account permissions
maybe it feels closer to
this type in
repo uh let's see
here so what does this one
do interaction limits uh interaction
limits on repost I don't think it's
that and so I'm just carefully looking
to figure
out what functionality we would have to
Prov
divide managing repository environments
it could be this read
write I would probably put this in just
because that is the
usual
um oh repo creation it's up here so I
don't think we need these other ones I'm
going to leave them on because they're
not that big of a
deal um and this one says it's mandatory
so sure we'll have that in there got it
added in there I'm going to go ahead and
generate this token and so now we have
this token I'm going to copy it I'm
going to go over to here I'm going to
type in export GH token and I'm going to
go ahead and paste this in and so the
idea is that when we use the um uh the
CLI it should pick up this as opposed to
what what else is on here so I'm typing
EnV hyphen GP because I want to make
sure that this is actually set as our
environment variable if you have other
tabs open here it might not show up so
just stay on the current tab we'll go
ahead Andy try this again another reason
why it might have not worked is because
that name was already taken but I don't
think so because it's scope based on our
user so we go ahead and try this again
from scratch so we say GitHub CLI
example and then we'll say uh we'll put
nothing in there we'll make it private
and it was interesting there's a
visibility of internal I imagine that
maybe that's for Enterprises we'll say
yes yes and it doesn't matter I'll just
choose that one we'll say yes doesn't
matter I'll choose that one and we'll
say yes let's see if it works now clone
the repo locally yeah sure let's do that
and so now it's working so whatever key
whatever personal access token that is
somehow being loaded in there did not
have the correct permissions we're able
to get around that so I don't really
want this repost I want to go ahead and
delete it um let's go take a look and
see what actions we have there we have
delete so I'm going to hope that it just
will like give me a wizard so I don't
have to pick it so we'll say G H repo
delete um and I don't want to delete our
current one so I'm going to hit contrl C
because that's totally not what I want
and we'll go back over to here and we'll
take a look and see what we can see for
the uh repo I really wish they would
list them up here maybe if we go to the
getting
started or available commands yeah
that's a little bit
easier it's not great but uh we'll go to
repo here and we'll go to
delete and we can can put the repo name
here so we'll go
back over to uh GitHub here we'll go to
our name this is going to be Andrew WC
Brown and we should be able to see two
repos in
here there's our other one I'm going to
grab that
name and we going to go back over here
and I'm going to say that so do we want
to delete
it so type the name again sure and we
have to put in all so uh the username in
front of
it we'll hit enter and that repost
should be now deleted we'll go back over
to
here okay and it's deleted so that is in
good shape so that's all good so I'm
really happy with that I'm going to go
ahead and stop this uh uh code code
space I'm just going to delete
it and you know I'm going to delete the
other one I'm just going to make sure I
keep everything nice and clean and and
not worry about overspend and what I
want to do is just merge this into my
other account again you don't have to do
this you can just watch me do this but
it's good to watch because this is
something that people have to do a lot
and actually what I should have done is
I should have gone over here and I
should have done it from here first so
I'm going to go here and create a PR
create create a new PR and we'll say
create is it going in the direction we
want yes it is we'll hit create
um fix Dev container we'll create that
pull
request good we'll switch back over to
our other account and then I'm going to
go into uh the same repo I'm going to
accept it confirm it and we are in good
shape I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao a common strategy for
authenticating uh to perform git
operations on your remote GitHub repo is
by using an s sh key uh you're
definitely going to want to use this
because it is a great way um to work
with Git uh in your local developer
environment it's definitely the way that
I like to use it as opposed to using a
personal access token but uh the way it
works is you'll have to generate out
your own SSH uh key using a command like
SSH key gen for Linux there's probably
different ways but that's the way that I
know and specifically an RSA key I'm
sure there's different kinds of uh keys
that uh GitHub will take but that's the
one that I know and so the idea here is
that we have our computer our local
computer and then we have the server
which is a GitHub and the idea is that
there will be a copy of the public and
private key on your local computer and
then on GitHub you'll store that private
key and so the the process of
authenticating and authorizing is going
to go like this so the server checks to
see if you have the same public key if
you both have the same public key it's
going to send you a challenge message
that challenge message contains the
public key uh encrypted and so it's
going to send that on over and then uh
the idea is that um the private key on
the local computer will decrypt it and
then it will be able once it decrypts
that message it will then take the
private key and do something there and
then send back a well it won't do
something it'll send back a signature um
and then that signature will be sent to
GitHub and then they'll verify it and
that will establish that connection
allowing you to use SS keys to get Clon
or push or or things like that uh under
your account settings SSH and gpg keys
is where you'll be able to add the
public keys so here you can see I have a
couple SSH keys in one of my GitHub
accounts and it's there under SSH and
gpg keys and when you want to go use um
or clone a a repo you're going to really
want to use that SSH style address it
will not not work with the htps one or
the GitHub CLI one technically will work
with the GitHub CLI one but that's what
you're going going to want to do there
so there you
[Music]
go in this video I just want to show you
quickly how to create SSH Keys we did
cover that in the quick and dirty uh git
crash course but it's good to do things
more than once so that we really get
good at them I'm going to open up a new
environment here in code spaces and
we'll get that spun up so I'll see you
back here when this is ready okay all
right so we have this environment spun
up and it's just not remembering myh
settings whatsoever but you know that's
just how things go and I'm going to make
a new folder in here I'm just going to
call it um SSH
keys and I'm going to just go ahead and
make a new readme file so normally what
we'll use is
the
SSH keyen command I realize that's small
I'm just going to jump it up like that
and so we use t t RSA to make an
RSA um uh style key I would imagine that
GitHub can support different kinds not
that I know much about the different
kinds let's go take a look here and see
what we can see so that's from local I'm
going to go ahead and delete that um
because I don't need that right now if
we go here you can see things like SSH
RSA sha 2 something like that so it be
interesting to generate something else
out so
ecd SSH key key gen ecd
so I want to see if we can generate
something that's a bit more
secure I I assume it's more secure is a
relatively new crypto cryptographic
solution um it's been around for five
years okay so how do we make
it and the way we make it is probably by
supplying this like that okay great so
what I'll do is go back over
here and we'll change it from RSA to
this one and see what happens I've never
done this before but I imagine it's
super
simple and I'm going to CD into the SSH
directory I'm going to go ahead and hit
enter say allow yes I want to paste
we'll enter and see if it can do
this and so we'll go ahead and hit
enter um it will create it in the
codespace directory so I suppose that's
fine and we'll do that and that and so
then we're going to get that key and
then the idea is that we can
then go ahead here and then we could go
and cat out the contents of
it
right all right and so we could copy
this and it's actually a lot shorter
that's actually really nice I like that
and then we could go over here and then
we could add it so just say uh Cloud
developer environment for
CDE and we can add that key now I want
to point out that you can add keys to
repo as well so we're not going to
really test this to make sure it works I
just wanted to generate out another one
and show you that but what we'll do is
we'll go over to our repo because I want
to show you where that deploy Keys
things is and if we're in a repo like
this we can go to our settings and there
should be deploy Keys down below and we
could add a deploy key and it's the same
process you just paste it on in you say
what it's from uh you can say whether
you want to have right access and boom
there you go but a lot of these um repos
only need readon so especially if you're
building you're just cloning the repo so
you don't need that but that's all I
wanted to show you so going to go ahead
and Commit
This okay so we'll just say uh basic
instructions for
SSH okay so that's all
good we'll say
okay and then what I'm going to do is
just switch into my other accounts and I
probably can merge the other way too um
if I try that
so if we go here to pull
requests we go to new pull requests and
I could probably try to grab from that
other repo so I want to bring in from
here from there yep I can do that and
then I'm just basically allowing myself
to pull the changes and without the
other Andrew having to uh Put It
Forward
okay there we go and we are merged I
will see you in the next
one
so deploy Keys allow you to attach
public Keys directly to a git repo and
the use case for deploy keys are if
you're using let's say a build server or
a c cicd thirdparty service that needs
to clone the repo so they can perform a
build or deploy or maybe single repo
access so instead of using a shared key
pair for the uh for multiple repos you
have a single key pair for a single git
uh git repo and another reason would be
to avoid using the personal access token
um I'm going to tell you I've definitely
used deploy Keys especially if you're
not using GitHub actions and you're
using thirdparty cicd tools which is
pretty common with GitHub um you will
find yourself using deploy keys and I
just want to make a wear that's very
similar to the other one with some
advantages so you have to decide in your
use case where you're going to want to
use it but it's as simple as that
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and we are
taking a look at personal account access
tokens or specifically personal access
tokens or Pat which is an alternative
way of using a password for
authentication now PS are not specific
to GitHub but they do utilize them uh
and the purpose of these tokens is to
give you access to the API um when
you're making direct calls or using the
command line or using the SDK uh GitHub
no longer supports the use uh of using a
password directly with interacting with
API they used to but now you have to use
an access token uh if you're coming from
like the adus world it's kind of like
your access secret um so it's giving you
that access uh there are two types of
pths on um GitHub you have the classic
token they are less secure and no longer
recommended for use customers with
Legacy systems may still be using the
classic token like some of my apps uh
then you have fine grain personal access
tokens these Grant specific permissions
they must have an expiry date uh you can
only access specific repo
um or if you want all repos it'll
probably only be readon you can only
access resources owned by a single user
or organization you can find the stuff
under the developer
settings um there are a few use cases
where we'll use uh Pats it'll be like
logging in using git clone for
HPS and uh let's say we are using uh the
GitHub CLI you could set a token or
sorry a environment variable called GH
token to be used uh for for the GitHub
CLI for the to pick that up uh if you're
using SDK you're going to be supplying
your token I would imagine that this uh
that these um sdks would pick up that
environment variable as well but there
you
[Music]
go hey everyone it's Andrew Brown and
this follow along I want to take a look
at personal access tokens yes we've
already played around with them but
let's play around with them a little bit
more okay and so what I'm going to do is
go over to my repo and I might already
have a code space from before and it's
already still active so I'm going to go
ahead and open that to save myself some
trouble if you have to launch a new one
you can absolutely go ahead and do that
remember to close your codes places so
you are not using up your free tear
usage uh you get so many hours per month
I don't know what it is uh you can look
it up if you want to know or we'll find
out when we make it over to the uh code
spaces section in the course um and so
what I want to do here is I just want to
uh work with personal access tokens now
we might have one set from before so I'm
going to take a look here and see what
we have so I'm going type in EnV grep GH
and see if there's anything set and
there's nothing set here so that's great
and what I want to do is go to the top
left corner here go to settings and then
down below we'll go to our developer
settings and we have our personal access
tokens we have fine grain tokens and
token classic now something I would like
to know I'm going go ahead delete this
one why I would like to know is can we
generate them out from the GitHub CLI
You' think you wouldn't be able to
because then you need permissions to
have permissions but I'm going to take a
look here and see what we have have um
because I'm just curious to see if it's
actually there or not and so I'm going
to just type in token and there is a
token so it says the this command
outputs the authentication token for an
account on a given GitHub
host well that's really interesting so
what would happen if we wrote that in so
I'm going to type in GH off token and
see what we get and we actually get a
token back so I'm not sure if that means
that
um that's that token code but let's find
out if it is
by generating out a new
token another thing I might wonder is
like what permissions do we have I'm not
sure if it would tell us I don't think
so what's refresh refresh our token
expand or fix the permission scope of
the store
credentials that's kind of
interesting like you go out and request
to have more permissions but I'm not
sure exactly how that would work um but
let's go ahead and generate a new token
I'll just say um create issues and I'm
going to set this for one
day okay and we'll go down below and
we're going to select it for a very
specific repo this one here and I'm
going to go to permissions and I'm
looking for issues we'll say yes to
issues read and write and we'll go ahead
and generate that token and so we can
see that's what this token looks like
we're going to copy it bring it over
here and I'm going to set it to this so
say GH
token equals and then a double quotation
paste it in enter and so now it should
be set so if I type in E EnV grap uh
GH we should see it there excellent so
now let's type in Gs off token and see
if we get a different value notice that
this is the one we have now it shows
that we're using a personal access token
so this is getting load in loaded in by
GitHub how it's getting in there I don't
know but this one looks exactly to be
the
same as this one let's go test and see
if we can make an issue so we go down
below here and we will say create and
I'll scroll down and grab example so
we'll do this and hopefully it'll just
know to create it in the current repo
put enter and we need to set a default
repo so we'll go ahead and do
that I'll choose this one here and I'll
try this
again and so it's created
it oh this repo has um issues disabled
that's interesting so we'd have to go
ahead and enable that so I'm going to go
back to our repo here I'm going to go
over to settings and we'll go down below
and we'll turn on issues now we could do
this via the CLI but it's just easy to
checkbox that and we'll go back to our
environment and we'll hit
up and now it's created the issue so now
the question is if I get rid of that
token like I unet it uh what would
happen so what I'll do is I'll just hit
up till we get to that set and I'm just
going to purposely set it blank okay and
that way this shouldn't work
work and so now if I do GH list issues
list I wonder if I can get a list of
them now remember this repo is public so
it's going to work because it's public
but the question is can I delete the
issue so I'm going to say
delete and um it's expecting some args
if I type help will tell me how this
works the number of it that's perfect so
the number is two so that's easy and and
I wonder if I could just put a two on
this type two to confirm
yes okay and deleted it now the thing is
is that yes I was able to delete it but
just understand that this thing has some
base uh access underneath that original
token and so it probably had permissions
this one here to do that there's
probably some things that this thing
can't do and we learned that before
which was that uh being able to create a
repo um but uh you know if I did this on
Local Host I would assume that this
would have not worked and that's totally
fine I think that satisfies us for
learning about uh personal access tokens
I'm going to go back to our personal
access token go ahead and delete it and
we'll call this one done okay so I'm
going to go ahead and go into personal
access tokens and delete
this and if you want you can stop and
delete your code spaces I'll see you in
the next one
[Music]
ciao let's talk about the GitHub API and
specifically what I want to talk about
is the fact that there are two versions
of it we have the rest API and the
graphql API I'm not going to do a big
lesson into what apis are and uh that
kind of stuff but I want to give you
comparison between these two to
understand what are the pros and cons of
each of them so let's do a breakdown
quickly here uh so the first thing is
the design philosophy so for the rest
API this is resource base and this is uh
this means that usually with rest apis
you'll have a different endpoint per
resource uh for graphql you'll have a
single endpoint with queries for precise
data requests um for methods we can use
get post put delete um but for graphql
they usually use post for data fetching
we can have multiple requests for
related data for graphql you use a
single single request that can be very
complex but you get whatever you want uh
you can have over fetching or under
fetching for graphql you you have
precise data fetching so you're getting
exactly what you want and nothing more
for performance it is less efficient for
complex systems but you know what I
think that is something we could argue
because I still really like rest apis
for graphql uh it's more efficient for
complex queries for caching it's easier
due to HP methods um for graphql it's
more challenging due to post methods the
learning curve it's super easy as rest
apis graphql uh requires a lot more
knowledge to pick up um for rest API
it's server driven structure for graphql
it's client driven okay for versioning
you often have to do API versioning for
rest API for graphql usually don't have
to that was the huge reason for having
graph graphql apis the ecosystem for
rest API is mature with extensive tools
graphql is still growing but uh the
point is is that GitHub has both and
these are the two big flavors of apis on
the internet um and I think the major
reason they did graphql was when they
opened uh the G ithub App Store so you
get exactly the data you wanted because
the rest apis didn't always return the
data uh that that people needed to build
apps and I think that was the reason why
because I remember trying to build an
app when the App Store first came out
and I had to use graphql in fact I
learned graphql because of GitHub uh
because they're one of the early
adopters of it when it came out but
there you
[Music]
go hey this is angrew brown in this
video I want to show you the GitHub API
um you know there reason I know the
GitHub API is because I've before GitHub
actions and all this other stuff you
would have to interact with a lot more I
need to point out that there are two
types of apis the rest API and the
graphql API I wonder if it could give us
an example of what that looks like for
GitHub so you have an idea if you've
never seen a graphql
API um but uh let's see what we can find
out so it looks like there might be some
way to interactively
explore it here oh there we go so
graphql um it has it own syntax language
and the idea is that you are formulating
what data you want it'll turn it back so
we can sign into this and then we could
probably do some live stuff now I'm not
saying I'm good at graphql but I'm sure
we can figure it out so go ahead and
authorize that and so here it says query
viewer login so it looks like we already
have some kind of query that's showing
who is logged in um so what I would like
to do is figure out how to query more
stuff um and I'm going to go ask chat
gbt because it's such a powerful tool
and let's go ahead and figure this out
so I'm going to go back over here and it
uh we'll
say
write a
graphql query that will return public
repos uh for the uh named
Ruby um
for
GitHub graphql API and let's see if it
can do this this is a great feature if
it can do this for uh this for us here
because I do not like figuring out how
to write graphql and so here is a query
that is writing that we could possibly
use okay I'm assuming that's part of the
language those three hyphens and we'll
go back or periods and we'll paste it in
and see if it can
work oh look at that okay it worked so
there you go that is a way that we could
use graphql graph is a lot more hard
than just this because you actually have
to have some kind of tool um or
interface in order to utilize it but
yeah it's as simple as getting the data
back that you want there is public data
and then there's data that needs to be
authenticated you have rate limits for
certain stuff so understand that you
can't just get everything that you want
let's go over to the rest
API and I'm not sure if they there's
ways to interact with it but sometimes
what they'll do is they'll make it
really easy for you to interact through
here on the left hand side so if we went
to
issues and let's say we wanted to list
things we might have some examples and
we might be able to run them
um so here you can see we have like the
GitHub CLI but what we're really looking
for is how do we do it raw like how can
we do this um using curl or maybe even
JavaScript but let's go ahead and do
curl because that's more like API is and
we'll have to open up a code space for
this I think I already still have mine
running again try to shut yours down as
much as you can so you're saving money
um I'm not worried about it I'm teaching
a course I'm just going to expense it so
understand that I'm a little bit more
loose with this kind of stuff the
question is will there be a curl command
pre-installed In This Cloud developer
environment sometimes they don't like
like installing those in here for you
but this one does have it so we'll go
ahead and copy this command curl and
we'll go back over here and we'll paste
it in we'll hit enter now this isn't
going to work because we didn't provide
it an access token so let's go
over I'm sure you know this by now we'll
go over to our personal access tokens
and get it going so all the way down to
the ground developer settings personal
access token find gr permissions create
a token only
issues uh
issues so this is for rest API we're
going to set this for one
day that way if you forget it's not a
big deal and we'll say for um all repos
I guess it doesn't matter I'm going to
go here and I want to grab oh we can't
do it for that let's say all
repos and I want issues
uh read and write we'll generate that
token out I'm going to grab this token
I'm going to go back over to here and I
need to kind of assemble it somewhere so
I need a scratch Pad really quick just
put that here I'll paste that in and
what I'll need to do is just go above
here and insert this I'll grab
this paste that in here okay I'm going
to cut this out and paste this back
in so now we should be able
to utilize this so let's see if that
works copy paste and so we don't get any
issues back now that doesn't mean that
it didn't work it just means that
there's no issues for it to find and we
really don't have any issues so what I'm
going to do is go ahead and create one
just say uh my
issue I think originally when you
created issues you weren't able to
delete them but now I think they've
changed that and you can um so I want to
try that again if I hit up will it bring
the whole command yes it will and we're
still not seeing anything now that
doesn't mean that it's not working it's
just that uh it's not getting exactly
what I want back so maybe we can specify
a very specific
issue it says a list of
assigned this issues assigned to the
authenticated user now there's none
assigned to us so let's go back and um
assign it to ourselves okay so we'll try
that maybe that will help we'll hit up
and there we go so now we're getting
data back and it must be that issue so
that's all I really wanted to show you
there we'll go ahead and delete
this
okay there's some way to delete this
uh they really don't like you deleting
them there it is down below in the
bottom right corner and that's all I
really wanted to show you for the apis
but most of the time you're going to be
interacting with some kind of CLI this
is in JavaScript um or sorry SDK um but
we'll we'll see that in the next video
okay
[Music]
ciao let us take a look at the GitHub
sdks and I told you octocat would make
another appearance because their uh sdks
are called octo kits these are the
official sdks to programmatically
interact with the git rest API and
GitHub officially supports a few
different languages so we have
JavaScript and typescript c.net Ruby
which is my favorite langu language so
we're absolutely going to use that and
terraform so here's an example of using
terraform to uh create a repository as
infrastructure is a code should you use
terraform for uh GitHub for certain
things yes like repos uh for other
things like issues no but just
understand that sometimes terraform
gives you functionality uh that really
shouldn't be used and it's up to you to
figure out for your use case here's an
example using Ruby and make note that we
are passing the access token the the Pat
Uh to the client um but yeah there we
[Music]
go hey this is angre brown and this
follow along I want to take a look at
the sdks so we can probably use Ruby and
JavaScript those are both very easy to
use uh so what I'll do is go ahead and
launch my code spaces I already have one
running uh you might have to make a new
one you might already have one running
make sure you don't leave them running
because they do cost money and so it
still has some stuff open from prior it
probably still has the GitHub access
token but what I want to do is go take a
look here and type in GitHub
sdks and we'll take a look at what we
have because there's a couple that we
have we have U Ruby JavaScript
typescript c c um and they should be
really easy to work with so I know
they're called octokit so I'll just type
in ocit GitHub and that probably will
get us to the repo for all of them there
we go and so we can get to our Ruby one
o terraform let's do terraform and
JavaScript let be too hard let's do
terraform first because I I'm really
excited to do that one and in order to
do this we're going to have to have
terraform installed so that's something
that I I'm going to want as a feature um
so for
[Music]
our Dev container we're going to have to
get that feature installed and I'm not
sure where we can find that so I'm very
curious if like we get a list of
features um list of Dev
container features GitHub code spaces
because there has to be one for
terraform and so I'm just searching here
for
features available features
here okay container Dev features that's
how we found it and uh just because
we're doing a little bit more here I'm
going to go ahead and make a folder
we'll just say
sdks
and I'm just going to say file new
readme.md we'll go ahead and paste that
on in here um and we'll just
say we can uh install the
following features into our codespace
environment just called
codespace and so what I'm looking for
here is the terraform CLI so go ahead
and do that and it's right here so I'll
go ahead and grab that and we'll go back
over to our Dev
container and um I'll put a comma and
we'll do this put colon c uh cures so
that's that one uh while we're here I
wouldn't mind Ruby do we already have
Ruby installed let's go take a
look type in clear
Ruby they might already have it
pre-installed in the base
image uh if it is it shouldn't take that
long to run it is okay so we don't have
to install Ruby do we have node I think
so yeah we do okay so we don't have to
install that so really we just need um
terraform now terraform uses get or
sorry uh go but they're all compiled so
I don't think we need to install go onto
this image if we needed it so I want to
get this terraform CLI installed so I'm
going to go ahead say install terraform
CLI we'll go ahead and Commit This
and then what we're going to need to do
is rebuild this environment so go down
below go to command pallet I'm going
look for
rebuild um I don't know if we need to do
a full or a whatever I'm going to do
that
one that seems fine to me let's go ahead
and do that and I'll see you back here
when this is done building okay all
right so it rebuilt that was really slow
but it is done so that is good um I'm
not sure if we ran into any
[Music]
issues oh come
on it's currently running recovery mode
due to configuration error what do you
mean to configuration error I did
exactly what you told me to do it's like
literally one line and I'm not allowed
to do it okay so let's find out what the
issue is um control shift
p I do not like I do not like
uh
view code
spaces okay let's find out what the
problem is now we'll go down
below
um what's your
problem it's not even like easy to find
the problem here I'm just going to zoom
out for a second so I can find it
quicker okay looks fine
finished error up
here
um Docker build fail to build
okay but
why it just failed to
build no space left on the
device well then how am I supposed
to all right so I was hoping that we
could install it that way if that's not
going to work that's totally fine I'm
just going to go ahead and comment that
out okay so we can just do this for
now and I'll take that out because I
don't want to fiddle with this all day
we can just install terraform CLI um the
usual way
okay I'm going type in clear and so I
know it's in recovery mode I really
don't care we'll just try try to proceed
forward and do what we can so we'll go
ahead and install the terraform CLI but
you think with all that stuff it just
work it would work right uh
install and we're going to get started I
just want the terraform CLI install
instructions if we go
here um we need Linux and we're choosing
Ubuntu so we're basically going through
all these commands it's that stupid gpg
I really hope that we don't have to do
that um I find that really frustrating
so I'm not sure if I can work around
that I think I have to get the dev
container working let me go figure it
out I'll be back in a second okay I'm
not sure what would fix it but like this
looks right to me I don't feel like
we're doing anything wrong so what I'm
going to
do is I'm going to stop this workspace
completely I'm just going to launch it
again and see if we get any errors and
we probably will don't have to fiddle
around with it but uh I mean this is the
experience of code spaces so I don't
sure what uh why get would want us ever
to use these things but I'm going to go
ahead and delete this delete and I'm
going to wait a moment here I'm going to
go back here to our
repo I'm going to try to launch it again
I'm going to see if it makes any kind of
difference okay we'll try this
again if it doesn't work I'm going to
just use git pod I'm I'm not even going
to try with GitHub code spaces but we'll
see if it builds okay all right so I'm
back and I mean there was no error so
maybe it did run out of space I'm not
exactly sure how that works um I'm not
sure why it would run out of space but
that's totally fine I'm going to go
ahead and open that up there and I want
to see if terraforms installed so I'll
type in terraform and it is so that is
really good so in our um our SDK
directory I'm going to just make a
couple new folders so we'll have one for
terraform we'll have one for Ruby and
we'll do a very simple example with
JavaScript as well okay we'll just say
JS and so for our terraform one here I'm
going to make a new main do TF file
because that is how you create
terraform and everybody should know
terraform because it is a great thing to
learn okay we'll type in clear I'll go
into terraform here and the idea is that
we will want to fill some stuff in so
over here they're saying there is a
terraform
provider and the way that works is it
will link over to the registry so um if
we go
here we'll get to the terraform registry
for terraform we can get it on the
homepage as well by just going to
provider
and there's probably one here for GitHub
if I type in GitHub if it doesn't show
up we could probably just search it um
GitHub right and so they should have
one I thought that'd be a lot easier to
find but apparently
not but that's okay we'll click back and
I mean this is one way to find it and so
the way you use a provider is you're
going to grab this over
here and we'll paste that into the
top we'll say
allow and what we have here is the
required providers and then any kind of
configuration in terraform they'll
usually tell you how to configure that
in the the first block here um and so
I'm carefully reading
here uh it looks like you could use a
CLI to
authenticate uh you can also pass in the
personal access token this way as well
so I'm hoping that it'll just pick up
the CLI um so I think that's probably
our best bet it already has a token
technically installed whether it can
create a repo is another story because
we know we have to create separate
tokens for that let's go on the left
hand side to resources and there should
be something here to create a
repo or we could just create a
branch and so let's copy this
code and we'll go down here below and
we'll paste it in and so we have to say
what repo's for so this is for the
GitHub
examples and I want to call this Branch
uh sdks okay so now what I can do is
type in terraform and
it and that'll initialize it then we can
type terraform
plan okay and it's saying that it's
going to create this
Branch looks good to me so now we'll do
terraform apply I'm just going to type
in Auto approve because I don't want to
have to hit
yes and uh otherwise we just say say yes
or no it says that it created that
Branch now it created this terraform
lock file and some other files in here
um I don't want this to junk up our
um our repo so I'm making a do get
ignore in here and we'll go to GitHub
and we'll just say GitHub uh G ignore
terraform and in here what we can do is
just grab that uh terraform one here and
this will make
sure that we don't have all the junk
that might get committed because we
don't want to commit uh a bunch of stuff
in here and so this is just going to
make our lives a lot easier you can have
get ignore files within subfolders so
that's kind of interesting if we go back
here now it's a lot cleaner that's
totally fine let's go take a look and
see if that Branch was created so if we
go here and uh
refresh making sure we're on ours and
not the other one there it is okay great
and so we can also tear that
down so say
terraform
destroy Auto
approve and so that was pretty nice
there we go we'll go back we'll check to
see if that branch is
there it's gone excellent so now let's
go ahead and do a ruby example so for
Ruby um we need a two files we need a
gem file I'll generate it out because I
think that's a bit easier so we'll CD
into that so say uh bundle a knit to
create a gem file I always forget like
these few lines here but I think their
gem is called
octo octo
kit and it was their first gem so I like
I'm really familiar with uh with that
there and so we have that installed
let's go take a look and uh at that CLI
and see how that works um or sorry SDK
so we have the Ruby one here I'm going
to go over to this
one and they should show some very
simple
instructions
mhm uh they're not showing much but I'm
going to go ahead and grab this one a
lot of libraries especially in Ruby
they'll they'll already assume that uh
there's certain um tokens being set so
I'm hoping that it'll just pick it up
and we don't have to do anything fancy
going to make a new file here called
main. RB doesn't have to be called main
it's just what I'm calling it and then
the idea with the client is I want to go
ahead and I want to uh try to create a
branch so you know they might have like
a a
um a uh
um documentation for that I don't want
all this stuff I just want to get to it
I want the manual so maybe if I go over
here this is what I want and so what I'm
looking for here is uh a way to connect
or create a branch so I'm going to click
on client again I've never looked at
this in a long time so I'm just guessing
but over here client has a bunch of uh
things that we can do on it and so I
mean there could be a method here so I'm
just going to take a look here and see
if we have like
branch and it looks like we
do I want to create a
branch and I mean we do have
methods here it says included in
repositories so if I go over to this one
here we go and I just want to create a
branch and say
create
okay what if I search for create Branch
create Branch I'm going try methods up
here that might help create
Branch I don't know why I can't find it
I mean I can find branches it might be
it might be the case that there is a
thing for branches
here there might be like an object for
it and then we create off of it I mean I
don't see one
branches what the heck
um I mean it's going to be something
under repositories that's for sure so if
I go to repositories they have an object
here and it has to be something on here
so if we carefully look we got Fork we
got
replace so yeah I'm not really sure so
well if I don't know I'll go ask chat
gbt and we'll see if they can make the
code uh create a branch using the Ruby
octokit for GitHub and let's see if it
can do it but normally you know I would
just go and look for it um but you know
it's giving us a really hard time so I
don't want to waste a lot of time here
looking for
it um yeah that probably would be one
way to configure it okay that looks
fine okay so you create a
reference and I guess that makes sense
because you're not actually creating a
branch you're creating a reference to a
a branch and then the branch gets pushed
later so I suppose that makes sense um
they do configure it up here again I
don't know if we'll have to do that but
it looks like this is what we're going
to want to do here so I'm going to just
grab this one I don't know if we need
the shaw but I'll grab it
anyway and I'm going to go back to this
if you don't if you can't find this code
I have this repo public so you can just
grab it from here um and so it says get
the latest Shaw from the base Branch so
get the latest commit in main main being
the base being the meaning that
um and then we'll create a branch from
it we'll need to specify our Branch name
so we'll go back to this code here I'm
going to grab these three lines because
they look
okay and I'll paste this up above and
our Branch here is
called I mean again it's going to be
different for you but uh this will be
Andrew Andrew WC
Brown
GitHub examples I just noticed that I
named this with a lower H but that's
that's okay um the branch name is going
to be
sdks uh the base branch is
main must have been pulling from some
really old code we'll save that I'm
going to go ahead and type in bundle
exec installed that's how we install
ruby
gems
okay and it's saying missing file opend
for install so maybe we have Ruby
install but we don't actually we can't
actually install anything so bundle
install really oh no no sorry it's just
bundle install I didn't mean to write
exact that's why and then what we can do
is type in exact Ruby main.
RB and it should run uninitialized
constant OCTA kit because we need to
require
it
octokit we'll save that we'll go ahead
and hit up and we ran into an
error um it wants faray try to use the
middle middleware faray so um install
the faray retry
gem I think faray is for like apis and
then maybe retries like a variation of
it I actually don't know but we'll just
try this bundle I might install it there
we go and we'll go ahead and try that
again and now we have a 404 so OCTA kit
not
found and it's looking at GitHub
examples for the commit sha on Main so
it's using this
path here I'm not sure if we could past
that in like that this is not found
commits so that's really interesting um
I don't really understand why that's
happening base Branch
main main yep that's right did I spell
this wrong at all maybe I did so we'll
go ahead and hit up I forgot the S on it
we'll try this
again and now we'll see what it
complains
about um 404 not
found Andrew WC Brown GitHub examples I
really don't trust that I'm writing it
correctly so I'm going to go down below
here I'm going to grab this
exactly and I'm going to go ahead and
paste this in
here exactly okay I'm going to double
check my name make sure it's right
Andrew Brown that's right and it looks
good to me so I'll try this
again still says 404 not found
um
okay I mean we could try and ask chat
gbt maybe it's using like an old API uh
one thing we could do is go back to the
Ruby OCTA
kit here and check the
documentation okay okay and in here I'm
going to go look under what am I looking
for um just trying to find here it is uh
this command here so this says create
ref off of the client and to be fair
like we did we didn't we didn't put in
our token yet so that might still be an
issue okay so it does have create ref on
there and that looks fine
okay this one says heads Master this one
says ref heads
main I don't know if that matters I'm
going to take out the ref's part on
it well maybe that one's
fine back to this
one
creates ref heads Master for octocat
Hello
World um just to make this a little bit
more clear I'm just going to take this
out and and so we can simplify this we
say
sdks again we just want this to work and
this is for this particular
repo sometimes simplifying the code
going to reduce our issues and I'm going
to take this completely out here I want
to grab the latest Shaw so if I go into
to our commits over here and we're on
Main we can go ahead and grab this code
here and I'm just going to go ahead and
replace it okay and so the idea is that
this is going to just rule out a lot of
issues that we're having okay and I want
to bring this on down like
this and so this is going to really
simplify this
one okay now again we haven't passed any
tokens so that could still be our
issue and it's still not working I can
also take out heads here and see what
happens if I do
that and no luck so I'm going to go
ahead and just take take take another
look here GitHub um Ruby SDK create
branch and also we could probably check
this way as well because well they'll
have the JavaScript version but maybe
they'll have the equivalent for um
creating uh for JavaScript we just look
at the Ruby what's really bizarre is
they don't have the Ruby example I think
they used to but maybe they just stop
doing that um get a branch rename a
branch I want to create a branch work a
branch merger
Branch so I guess it's not
really any of
those and so I'm going to go back over
here CU it it looked like it was more of
a ref and on the left hand side we're
going to look here in the API and try to
find it um maybe
repositories we'll click into
repositories
here no we'll click on this one
maybe I type in
ref create
ref
no we're not having a whole lot of luck
here but hey we're learning about the
apis and being able to navigate them
that's got to count for something
right because it's not going to be under
refs pendency graph
no actions no because that's going to be
GitHub
actions um commits
no let me go fine I'll be back in a
second okay okay all I did in Google
type in rest API create ref and then I
went to the first one and I think now
we're in a good place and there is
references it's under git database of
all things that's a little bit confusing
a git reference is a file that contains
the get commit sha etc etc great so I
want
to create a reference here can I am I
zoomed in oh that's why it's so hard to
read I was super zoomed in we'll scroll
on down here and we have create
reference and so this is what I think
that we're using right we're creating a
reference we have owner repo
but they don't have a good example for
this so you know if this is not working
what I'm going to do is copy the
JavaScript one and then we'll work our
way backwards to the Ruby one and see if
we can get it to work okay so I'll go
here I'll just say main
JS okay I'll paste this on in here and
um you know it's asking for the token
again it should really load it in via
the environment variables if it's not um
I'm really surprised that it's just
using a request and it's not using the
SDK I don't feel like this is the right
one I think this is not the SDK um so
I'm going to go and type in octokit JS
GitHub and I feel like we're going to
get a much better way of interacting
with
it yeah this is going to make a lot more
sense so in here yeah y okay here we go
um so what I'll do is I'll go grab this
line
here that's why it's good to know more
than one language because you can always
work your way back and try to figure out
what the problem is but it's showing
octokit here so maybe it is actually
using the
kit right yeah it is okay so that code
is using that U we don't need app
apparently not sure what app is for but
that's fine uh but I'm really surprised
that we have to pass the token that way
let's go take a look and see how we can
authenticate
um
I was just like hoping that it would
just pick it up by
default but I'm not sure about
that here they're talking about RB like
uh octokit
RB
um actually this is the Ruby one again
so I'm on the wrong page back into this
one and yeah meant to be over here I'm
looking for
Authentication
here it
is yeah I'm not sure how it picks it
up well I guess we'll bring in the token
then um what I'll do is I is I'll have
to bring in a
token so we'll go here we'll go to
settings and maybe that would fix the
Ruby one maybe that was the Ruby problem
the entire time I'm going to go ahead
and drop this down find grain
permissions I'm delete this old one I'm
going to create a new one and I'm going
just say uh create Branch just really
creating ref that's what we're actually
trying to do I'm going to go ahead and
go to the next one here and we'll say
for select repos this will be for our
only repo and we need to go through
permissions so I'm looking for
references ref
database
API like where would this be would it be
under
repositories so I'm going to choose this
one I'm going to choose the repo one if
I can find
it oh it is that one right there read
and
right
um maybe this one because that's repo
creation commit
statuses I'm just kind of picking a lot
so we have a good chance of this
working I'm going to go count
permissions um don't think I need any of
those so I think that's fine I'm going
to go ahead and generate this token out
I'm going to grab this token go back
over to our environment and I'm going to
go ahead and set this as export GH uh
token and then we'll go ahead and paste
this in and do that we'll type in clear
we'll do
GP EnV GH to make sure that we can uh
find that
there oh I got that backwards EnV grap
GH the token is set and so what I want
to do here now is make sure it gets
picked up I'm going to test the Ruby one
here and just see if it if it makes a
difference and uh it does not another
thing I might try is go back in here and
explicitly set that token I believe we
can set that as access token and I can
say
EnV GH token and so that would be a very
explicit way to get it I'll hit up again
oh there's no problem now okay so maybe
it was a token the entire time like that
was the issue so what I'll do is I'll go
back over to our repo again that was all
just guesswork you know you got to have
confidence you got to try
things and I'll go over here and drop it
down and there it is so that definitely
did work um I don't want this Branch
right now so I want to go ahead and
delete it we can go to our branches here
and I'm going to go ahead
and delete this
branch and I want to delete it again I
just want it gone it's gone I think and
so now we have our Ruby one working so
now we need to get our JavaScript one
working and it wants a token as well the
way we bring in environment variables is
a little bit different um it uses like
process so it' be like import process I
always kind of forget maybe we don't
have to import anything at all um we'll
say reference a nvar or like call an
nvar
in nodejs file
example
yeah it is processed but do we need to
import
it
uhhuh so I'm thinking maybe we don't
need to even import anything for it I'm
going to go ahead and try this uh we'll
go back over
here I'm just going to paste this
in GH token and so I'm not confident
whether it's getting imported or not so
what I'm going to do is do a console log
that should print out the
token
token dollar sign uh or maybe it's back
tis I know a lot of languages so I get
confused
easily um okay so that's in there like
that
um so here we have the reference it
looks like these repl these place
holders so we'll have to specify the
owner I'm the owner so this is going to
be um Andrew WC Brown we'll need to have
the shaw so I'll go back over here and
grab it from
here
okay and we'll paste that
in this is going to be
sdk's I'll put JS so we really sure we
know what we're using here uh the repo
is going to be GitHub
examples okay okay and I'm going to make
my way over to that directory uh for
JavaScript now I'm going to want the get
ignore for JavaScript in particular get
ignore JavaScript I didn't do it for
Ruby because Ruby doesn't really make
that much junk files so it wasn't a
serious issue but if you really wanted
to you could go ahead and and um grab it
if you wanted so go ahead and grab that
and we'll go back over here to here
we'll say dog
ignore and if anyone's wondering I'm
like watch watching when my test is
going to come up here so I'm just kind
of getting nervous uh not because the
test is hard I just want don't want to
forget about and then miss uh sitting
the GitHub foundations certification
course so that is now in there so that
won't dump a bunch of junk files in when
it adds that I want to add that right
away so add the G ignore sometimes it
won't take effect unless you add it
right away I know I spelled that wrong I
don't care um and so I'm going to go and
type in mpm install I'm going to imagine
that this is OCTA kit as
well it has to be CU it was called
octokit JS sometimes like the files
might be a little bit different like
octokit hyphen period JS or JS after it
I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to
do an mpm install oh it's already
installed but and so what we'll do is go
over here and take a look and we now
have a package Json and I want to run as
I don't know why I didn't put it in here
but I want to have a script in here I'm
going to go ahead and just type in mpm
init because it really didn't give me a
whole lot I really don't like that I
didn't get stuff here and so it
overwrote it and I'm going to just
install it
again and that way I don't have to
fiddle with it so much so now I have the
scripts and I can just say start and
what I'm going to do here is just say um
node main
JS okay and so now put a Comm on there
we should be able to do mpm uh start and
that should try to run that screen R um
it didn't like the import for some
reason to load es module types um you
have to load something something so I
think it's just the style that we're
using there that's totally fine I'm
going have to go to the top here and
change this to be require I guess um
we'll go back to our JavaScript
here we going to go all the way to the
top and I need a different way to import
it
um this one is what we
want it could be the node version that's
installed here but I really don't think
that's the case but I'm going to go
ahead and do that that's easy enough to
fix and we'll hit
enter and a weight is only valid in
async functions at at and the top level
bodies of
modules okay I mean I really don't care
if it's a uh async can I just take it
out will that
work the token printed out that's good
um we'll go back over here see if our
Branch created just Refresh on branches
it did perfect great so now that means
we can go ahead and Commit This just
double triple check your files make sure
you're not committing anything you're
not supposed to commit don't commit your
token go ahead and Commit This I'm just
in a hurry for my exam and we'll just
say SDK stuff
SDK GNA go ahead and commit that I'm
going to say okay sync sync sync I'm
going to go back over here I'm going to
switch
accounts I'm in a big hurry uh you know
stop your code spaces don't waste your
money and um I'm going to go over to our
repo here um and I actually want to be
in an exam Pro one exam
proo exam Pro
Co okay I'm G to make a new PLL request
I want to
merge
um compare across forks and I want to
grab this one and bring it over into
that one
boom just sdks sdks I really shouldn't
be silly like that you should take take
time naming your pull requests and wait
a moment merge it we're done I'll see
you in the next one
ciao hey it's Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at GitHub desktop so this
is a standalone application to interact
with GitHub repos without the browser or
via code
and it can do common git and GitHub
operations that you can perform via the
guei for an easy to ous experience it
works for both Mac OS windows and Linux
so yeah it's a very useful tool um you
know when you look at git as uh a thing
that you can use a lot of times there
are these other kind of um Standalone
applications specifically around get to
make git actions easier but this does
two things it does git and GitHub so if
very powerful if you are using the
GitHub platform so I recommend you give
it an install
[Music]
okay hey this is Angie Brown and this
follow along I want to take a look at
installing GitHub desktop and see what
we can do with it so what I'm going to
do is open up a new tab and just type in
GitHub desktop and we'll find our way
over there so here it is uh at desktop.
github.com and we can go ahead and
proceed to install this so I'm on
Windows right now so I'm going to go
ahead and just just download that okay
all right so that's finished downloading
let's go ahead and install it so it
should be pretty straightforward going
to double click the executable if you're
on Mac of course you drag into your
applications for Linux I have no idea
but imagine it's not too hard to install
and I'm just waiting for it to um uh uh
pop up here and proceed with
installation so you can see my computer
is
thinking there we go it's starting to
open
up
all right so we'll wait for that to
finish its install there we go looks
like it's installed we can log in either
into github.com or GitHub Enterprises
let's go ahead and uh log into
github.com you can see we can sign into
uh either or I think I'm interested
right now in this repo here so I'm going
to select this one and we'll go ahead
and authorize it um and it says when
your phone is ready click the button
below so I'm going to use GitHub mobile
to confirm because we have UFA so just
give me a moment and while I'm waiting
here I guess I have to press press the
button I wasn't doing that and so it
pops up with 14 and um I have a pseudo
request and so I'll just share my screen
here for just a moment but what it's
showing me here is I have to enter those
two digits in so that's what I mean
where sometimes it it uh pops up or
other times it's just confirmation it's
going to really depend on the action
that's being performed let's go ahead
and open this up in GitHub desktop and
we can see it's setting our name and
email so it's like it's it is
configuring get underneath um so that is
interesting there we'll go ahead and uh
click
finish and I mean we got tutorials and
other stuff here but I'm not really
interested in that I just want to open
up the repo that we already have let's
go ahead and open that up and I guess
we're cloning it and it's actually
showing us that we're going to clone it
in a specific location here it's putting
in documents GitHub I guess that's fine
uh we go over to GitHub github.com I
suppose we can just select the repo and
it'll put the path there so there's two
different ways that we can do it here
I'm not sure which way is better but
I'll go ahead and do uh this method here
because it just seemed a little bit
simpler and so now we have our repo
pulled up and so we can perform stuff
here um so you uh you have changes on
this Branch would you like what would
you like to do with them uh to
contribute them to the parent
project um I I don't know I just I just
opened it up why am I already getting to
asked questions you have changes on this
Branch would what would you like to do
with them to contribute to the parent
project for my own purposes this will
help you contribute to this repo I guess
the top one maybe it's just trying to
tell me what I want to do or not do I'm
not exactly sure um but now we have this
opened and so the idea is that if we
make changes we can do something in here
looks like we can also open up our repo
directly here in Visual Studio code so I
can go ahead and click this I guess the
nice part of this is that I don't need
to have any compute attached um in order
to work with this so normally you have
to have get installed here and just say
I accept this and so we could go in here
I'll go into our crash course here I'll
just add another exclamation
mark
if it ever lets me here
good I'll just say
save and I'll go back over to here and
it shows that we have a change uh let's
take a look at history so we have um
history over time I would really prefer
a graph I'm not sure if they actually
have like a graph mode in here so this
isn't like super useful a lot of other
uh git programs like there's one called
cracken like get
Kraken um
they say it's a legendary tool I think
it's a little bit heavy but the point is
is that they will have a much better
visualization in terms of what is going
on so you know this tool is okay but
it's not the best tool you can create uh
you can push pull fetch you can view
stuff here you can open up the command
prompt um so there are some things you
can do you can do stuff with branches um
but it's really up to what workflow
you're working in because of course you
know if you're already using visual
studio code you don't really need this
tool because we can do
uh everything and much more here and
then there's also a GitHub plugin that
we can utilize so um you know GitHub
desktop existed before Visual Studio
code and before the visual studio code
extension so um you know it's there and
you know maybe if you're using a
different editor or or maybe you
couldn't install the extension or
something like that there' be a use case
for GitHub desktop again it's not bad
but um you know it is it is what it is
uh it is very good at keeping uh your
repos in a particular location and
managing managing them so that is really
good there but again why they haven't
added a visualization I have no idea but
there you go that is GitHub desktop um
as far as as much as we want to cover it
here and we'll see you the next one
[Music]
ciao let us compare the difference
between github.com and GitHub desktop
for the following uh comparisons so
let's start at the top here so for
github.com it is a webbased interface
access via the browser the GitHub
desktop is a standalone desktop
application for
accessibility the github.com is
accessible anywhere there is internet
and the GitHub desktop is only where you
install it on your computer for repo
management it directly manages
repositories online for GitHub desktop
it manages repos locally for basic git
operations github.com performs
operations like Fork start and watch
GitHub desktop um simplified interface
for commit pull uh push and so notice it
says Fork star and watch those aren't
really git operations those are GitHub
operations I just want to clarify that
um for collaboration direct
collaboration tools like issues and PRS
focuses on local repo management um then
for Advanced GET features supports
Advanced features via commands
simplified experience for basic features
integration tools integrates with
various online cicd tools and limited to
local get tools so these are not like
hard rules for all of them but um it's
just a general distinction between the
two but there you
[Music]
go GitHub mobile is a mobile application
you can install on iOS or Android phones
to perform readon basic GitHub repo
management tasks it can manage triage
and clear notifications read review
collaborate on issues and PLL requests
edit edit files and PLL requests search
for browse and interact with user repos
and organizations receive a push
notification when someone mentions your
username search through codee in a
specific repo secure your github.com
account with two Factor authentication
and that is the primary reason I tell
you to install it is for that as it I
find it very useful verify your signed
in attempts on unrecognized devices
GitHub mobile can be used for UFA which
is a convenient way over other methods
and I definitely agree with that for
everything else you know I'm not really
sure I think the thing about this
particular product um and I really
should have highlighted this is it's
really good good for triage and people
that need to stay um uh stay up to date
with what's going on so people that
maybe they a sis Ops administrator or
something like that um so GitHub mobile
becomes very very important and um even
though it doesn't show up in the exam
it's in the exam guide outline they
really want you to know about mobile
notifications to stay on top of stuff so
we'll look at that next
[Music]
okay let us take a look at mobile
notifications on GitHub just understand
that these are the settings on Android I
have no idea what they are for iOS maybe
they're different maybe they're the same
I would imagine they're the same but
different UI but we just want to make
sure we cover our bases because the exam
guide outline wants us to know this
probably for people that try to triage
things when issues happen in GitHub so
let's quickly look at it so you can set
push notifications you want to receive
so we can say direct me mentions review
requested assigned deployment review
pull request review and workflow runs uh
you can set the working hours to only
receive push notifications for specific
periods of time so that way you're not
getting annoyed when it's your weekend
or it's your time off um you can set
swipe options on notifications to
perform save Mark is read Mark is done
or unsubscribe so you can go left or
right on that um you can change the app
style notification this might be
specific to Android but making sure that
you can see the type of alert you want
to see so it grabs your attention so you
jump on top of it and there you
[Music]
go let us take a look at the types of
GitHub accounts we've got three personal
organizational and Enterprise so for
personal accounts these are individual
accounts with a username and profile
they can own resources like reps and
projects and actions are taken uh based
on the personal account they can either
be GitHub free and GitHub Pro which we
will definitely describe in this section
of the course then you have organization
accounts I said organizational above
organization can just think of them as
the same thing whichever language you
want to use shared accounts where we
have multiple people collaborating on
projects they can own resources just
like uh just as the personal account has
um and these are generally managed
through individual personal accounts I
say generally because um when we were
going through setting up our
organization we have the option to
convert our personal account into some
kind of business um so we didn't go
through that and generally I've always
known this to be through personal
accounts the exam is not going to test
you either either way but I just want to
point that out organizations offer
different roles with varying levels of
access and cons security features those
roles are predefined um if you want more
flexible custom roles you'd have to have
Enterprise for that Enterprise accounts
so this is part of the GitHub Enterprise
cloud and GitHub Enterprise server these
accounts allow for Central management of
multiple organizations they're geared
towards larger setups needing
centralized policies and building
management or if you have to have
internal G uh GitHub repos which is a a
specific type of GitHub repo
specifically for Enterprise the exam
surprisingly for me ask a lot of
Enterprise specific questions which I
don't really think is fair for the
GitHub foundation so I'm just telling
you up front you're going to have to
remember some factoids for Enterprises
if you want to max out your points on
the exam let's take a quick look at
GitHub personal and organizations before
we move on here so as you can see you
get a profile if you look at the top
right corner it is based on your
username so github.com
uhen King there and if you had a repo
the repo is going to have uh your your
your username followed by the repo name
okay for organizations it's very similar
it also has a public profile page uh it
also has a username and um it's not it's
not exactly the same but it's the same
concept but it's going to follow the
same pattern for uh repos so repos can
either have an org name or a username
okay so there you
[Music]
go all right let us compare GitHub free
versus Pro and I just want to warn you
that the exam might ask you one of these
things so it becomes a little bit more
important to remember the differences
between them is it fair for an exam not
really but it's just how they made their
exam so I just want to point that out
that you have to remember some fact
total information here so we have GitHub
free and GitHub Pro so let's go through
the GitHub free features you get GitHub
Community Support dependabot alerts
deployment protection rules for public
repos two Factor authentication
enforcement 500 megabytes of GitHub
packages storage 120 g uh GitHub code
spaces core hours per month 15 uh
gigabytes of GitHub code spaces storage
per month GitHub action features such as
2,000 minutes per month deployment
protection rules for public repos I'm
not sure why it's listed under there
because that makes no sense but that's
where they put it and so basically um in
GitHub Pro you get everything you get in
free with addition of GitHub support via
email 3,000 GitHub actions per uh minute
per month so extra thousand two
gigabytes of gig GitHub GitHub packages
storage 180 GitHub code spaces core
hours per month 20 Gigabytes of GitHub
codes spaces storage per month Advanced
tools and insights in uh private repos
you have required pull request reviewers
multiple pull request reviewers
protected branches code owners automated
link references GitHub pages wikis and
repo insights graphs if you don't know
what all this stuff is right now do not
worry because we're covering basically
all of it like working with all these
tools and then you should come back and
uh review this again so you have it for
your knowledge when you take the exam
okay
ciao for GitHub organizations there are
three type of plans we have free teams
and Enterprise I put an aster there
because this is more an upsell to the
Enterprise um uh uh account uh but when
you go and you try to buy it will show
you their the Enterprise option so just
pointing that out let's talk about free
so you get everything that was in GitHub
free with the addition of Team access
controls for managing groups 2,000
GitHub action minutes per month 500
megabytes of GitHub packages uh storage
um and I don't really understand those
last two because it is it for the org or
is it for the personal account that has
the org but it's in there okay then we
have teams and this is where we start
paying everything from GitHub org in the
free edition with also GitHub support
via email 3,000 GitHub actions minutes
per month 2 gabt GitHub package storage
Advanced tools and insights in private
repos required pole request reviewers
multiple poll request reviewers and
notice that the minutes for GitHub
actions and packages look very similar
to um the pro PL Pro account for the
GitHub uh personal Pro and there is more
so let's keep going uh we have draft
pull requests team pull request
reviewers protected branches code owners
schedule reminders GitHub Pages wikis
repo insights graphs the option to
enable or disable GitHub code spaces um
one thing I'd like to point out is the
code owners because that is quite a
unique feature we'll talk about that
when we get to wherever that is in the
course um but I think that one is one
worth remembering out of the teams
functionality also draft PLL requests I
try to remember those two in particular
as those are very specific and unique
features and and they both showed up on
my exam so just make a note of that
[Music]
okay all right let's take a look here at
GitHub Enterprises deployment options
because they have two kind that you can
have uh we have GitHub Enterprise Cloud
this is when you want to have a hosted
version of the Enterprise Edition on
github.com and then you have GitHub
Enterprise server this is a uh
self-hosted one so let's take a look at
uh what have our deployment options in
terms of feature set on the GitHub
Enterprise for both cloud and server
they're going to share this same
functionality first so first of all
they're going to have everything that
organization teams has but they're going
to get GitHub Enterprise support they're
going to get additional security
compliance deployment controls
authentication with saml uh single
signon um and accessing Provisions
provisioning with saml and S cim they
make a large emphasis on this in the
exam in fact I totally thought it didn't
matter and then I got a bunch of
questions on the sum exam and I was like
really but yeah I'm going to have to
make a couple slides on that in our
Enterprise section because they really
want you to know that that is an
offering for Enterprise um deployment
protection rules with GitHub actions for
private or internal repos and that again
is a feature specific to Enterprises so
make note of that as well we have GitHub
connect Actually I don't even know what
that is um I'll have to I guess make a
slide on that as well option to purchase
the GitHub Advanced security so that is
a um some kind of additional feature for
specific features we have 50,000 GitHub
action minutes per month 50 gigabytes of
GitHub packages storage a service level
agreement of 99.9% monthly up time
option to centrally manage policies and
building for multiple github.com orgs
with an Enterprise account this was a
question on my exam as well and I was
not prepared for it um they never asked
for like minutes I think that's kind of
information I never saw that there so
you don't have to really worry about
that we have options to provision and
manage the user accounts for your
developer by using the uh
emus um I'm glad we never had any
questions on of those but uh emus seemed
like they're really involved but I
imagine that would be in that GitHub
administrator um or Administration or
administrator certification but there
you
[Music]
go so before we can talk about what
markdown is we need to know what the
markup language is so a markup language
I shouldn't said the but it's a markup
language is a way of formatting and
presenting Text data in a different
format and a common use case for a
markup language is to present data in
HTML and so uh probably the one that won
out the battle for HTML uh formatting
language is markdown so markdown is a
markup language that provides a
shorthand syntax to format information
into HTML markdown is popular due to its
easy syntax and being readable in its
raw format I want to point out that on
the exam they might ask you about
markdown and they might throw in markup
in there to confuse you remember down
down down down mark down okay um in
terms of file extensions you have MD and
markdown I've never ever seen anyone
ever use the ladder it's always been MD
but just be aware they are both there so
let's take a look at what it looks like
the idea is you write your mark down it
looks like that and from there we're
going to get HTML and that HTML can be
rendered as a preview so the idea is
that we need to learn and everyone
should know how to do this not just in
GitHub but everyone should know how to
write markdown because it's super useful
as a developer tool as a Tech Tool in
general
[Music]
okay let us take a quick look at the
markdown base basic syntax and so all
markdown parsers support uh this basic
syntax when we talk about parsers that's
a program that knows how to take
markdown uh the raw markdown format and
spit out HTML and there can be
variations between the parsers because
there's implementations in different
languages for different use cases so
understand that uh your markdown might
not be the same as someone else's
markdown in terms of what will work and
not work um but we have headings so
that's just your standard headings you
have text formatting like size and bolx
some of some of the time boltex can be
underscores instead of double uh asteris
why um they made a tal size single
asteris I have no idea as a lot of
people think that it's the single
asterisk but that's just what it is for
Block quotes that's like an indented um
uh uh text usually for quotes uh we have
unordered list so you just put um
hyphens in the front it'll they'll put
bullets there for ordered list you can
keep all the numbers the same so 11 one
and it will then render out as 1 2 3 4
which is really nice uh that is for a
link that is for an image very similar
to link but has an exclamation mark in
the front of it you have the horizontal
ruler or Rule and then you have inline
code I need to really point out that
that is using a back tick so when you're
doing code blocks they always use back
ticks for um for markdown okay so that
is the basic syntax and there you go
let us take a look here at markdown
extended syntax so this will be
supported by some parsers if not most um
and the most common one is being able to
make a table these are not fun to make
but at least we can do them uh we have
fence code blocks this is when you want
to have multi-line code and the really
nice thing is that you can actually
apply uh for a lot of these um the name
of the extension which will provide some
synta tax highlighting this is something
GitHub absolutely does and you should do
it if you have the option to do so
because it makes things so much easier
to read we have footnotes we have
heading IDs which I've never used before
we have definition lists which I've
never used before we have strikethroughs
highlight which I've never used before
might be fun to try that out emojis
which I love and GitHub has great
support for and we have task list which
um GitHub this this one's a really
useful one then we have subscript and
superscript and I've used those in a few
cases but uh yeah there you go that is
the markdown extended
[Music]
syntax so in GitHub when you ever have
to write something that is markdown
supported it's going to have this text
formatting toolbar and it allows you to
uh utilize GitHub flavored markdown
syntax which we'll talk about in the
GitHub flavored markdown syntax section
and it appears right here and so the
idea is that you can uh press these
buttons and it's going to make your life
a lot easier you also notice that a lot
of times you'll have a preview as well
so that uh makes it very easy to turn
that raw markdown into uh the final
product the HTML rendered in terms of
what it'll look like to the end user um
and so I find that super useful
[Music]
okay let us take a look at slash
commands so these are uh functionality
at least within Comon boxes that allow
convenience features such as formatting
markdown and I'm implying that there
could be other functionality but right
now it only does a markdown and it's a
beta feature oddly enough even though
it's a beta feature it appears on the
exam because GitHub apparently puts beta
features in their exams which I think is
bizarre but whatever so let's say you
wanted to create a table you basically
get this wizzywig and you go through it
the idea is that you can put that
forward slash to start triggering that
um line of prompts and it can make your
life a lot easier and actually it is a
good idea but um again you know beta
feed feature probably shouldn't be an
exam but hey that's how GitHub rolls
[Music]
okay let us take a look here at GitHub
flavored markdown also known as gfm this
is a dialect of markdown that is
currently supported for user content on
github.com and GitHub Enterprise gfm
provides powerful functionality such as
collapsible sections embedded
mathematical Expressions embedded
diagrams relative paths or linking to
files in the same repo task lists that
can be converted into issues extended
formatting for tables short hands to
autol links to issues pull requests and
repos render code Snippets from other
code bases via linking and more um and
we can see the whole detailed spec at
gfm spec uh website here so that's at
github.com
gfm it's a really good read and I'm
being sarcastic because it is very dry
but let's take a look at the
functionality we're listing here on the
left hand side so you have a really
clear idea what you can do so the first
that I think is really cool is having um
better syntaxes or sorry a control over
your tables so here you can actually
have embedded syntax within the table
cells which is not a normal thing you
can usually do with markdown another
thing is more uh control over the look
or formatting of your table so you can
better align that stuff I imagine that
they have like merging cells and uh
excluding the headers I think that they
have that but um these are the two that
I could remember that are a big deal um
they have this details tag and this
allows you to have collapsible
sections uh it has support for mermaids
so this allows you to render things like
um uh dags di
acrylic direct acrylic graphs it's just
a type of graph okay um we have geojson
and too Json this allows you to create
interactive maps so here's an example of
geojson and then here's an example of
too Json I imagine that they render a
bit differently so one might be better
than the other in terms of information
shown then we can uh render 3D models so
that's kind of cool um it can render
mathematical expressions and I really
know latex I used to work for a math
educational startup and so you have your
double dollar sign for your latex or you
can use uh fencing blocks code blocks
and have math this is using math Jacks
so if you're wondering what
implementation that's what it's using
and so those will both render out the
same thing based on what syntax you want
to use um if you have links it'll
automatically be linked that's not like
a GitHub specific thing but it is
something that um they have set their
defaults for their markdown to do but
what is really interesting are these
quick links so the idea is if we do
pound 26 or GH hyphen 26 it'll create
hyperlinks and these hyperlinks will go
to issues which is super useful um might
go for poll requests as well because
they usually treat the numbers as the
same so like if you make an issue one
and you make a pull request the next ID
will be two in your project if that
makes sense within comments you can
quickly link to other repo so if you
have something that looks like a repo
it's going to go to a repo uh that would
be the final product uh produce there
and then you can also link Things based
on um commit Shaws so yeah a lot of cool
linking um Tas list can be uh can with
uh can be op can be turned into open
issues kind of wrote that a bit weird
you can associate tasks to specific
issues creating basically subtasks
GitHub can keep track of your open or
closed state of linked issues you can on
click turn a task and associate with an
issue so here is your usual task list
but notice there's like little icons and
stuff um and you can also reorder them
so a lot of great additional
functionality that is on the rendered
side or on the markdown side that is new
um but yeah that is gfm you should know
some of the stuff because it really does
make it a lot easier to work on GitHub
but there you go
[Music]
ciao all right so in this fall along
what I want to do is get some practice
with markdown there's a few ways that we
can uh work with markdown here um we
could uh edit files in line we could use
GitHub dodev we could open up code
spaces but I just want to show you um
you know a few things that we can do
here so maybe what I should do is go
over to our new repo GitHub examples and
we should try to uh utilize um some of
the abilities of creating stuff without
opening up an editor because I know the
exam they might ask you that and so I
figur a little bit of practice with that
would be good so let's say we want to
make a new folder here what we can do is
we go ahead and add a new file and we
will create a new file and in order to
create a a new folder all we got to do
is type A for slash I'm going to say
markdown
uh here and put a for Slash and now we
have a folder and we now have ourselves
a readme file now I didn't mean to hit
forward slash there I think it just
happened prematurely so I just hit
backspace I can type in MD and notice
right away that we can start writing
markdown okay so we can go here and flip
between them they really want to use
co-pilot I do not care about co-pilot
and I'll go ahead and just say U mark
down uh mark down
examples and what we'll do is work
through some here so again I'm just
going to show you that you can commit uh
this but let's make a list of things
that we should learn how to do headings
we should know how to do uh and I'm
already writing markdown as a list
headings uh unordered
lists we should have ordered
lists um uh formattings like uh text
formatting
code uh
tables Auto links
lists
um we could also have like images
links images okay so that's a pretty
good list of things that we can learn
how to do
and I think that's a good start so let's
see
unordered list I'm going to go ahead and
commit that change so I just want to
show that you can commit directly with
files and update files here and that's
really really nice and you can see that
stuff rendered in place but I think
what's going to make this a lot easier
to work with is to uh use that
github.io so if we press in Period what
that's going to do is open up
github.com which is not a thing I hit
period but it didn't do anything I hit
period again and I think it had to like
move or something there and now it's
going to open open it up in
github.com
okay so let's go through and figure this
out so the first thing are headings so
this is a heading up here this is a
heading one if we can go we do this this
is heading one and now we'll just do
heading two
headings and I feel like we already kind
of figured that out because we're we're
doing that so I'm not sure if we really
need to have that as we know what
headings are so we'll say unordered
lists and we'll just uh say
unordered lists yeah we can create
unordered lists
in
markdown using
hyphens
okay and while we're doing this let's
open up uh GitHub flavored
markdown because maybe there's some
things that are there that might be
interesting to take a look at so I'm
going to go ahead and grab this link I'm
going to dump it in remember that just
Auto links as soon as we paste it in
here and if we go here we could see that
there is a bunch of stuff so there could
be something for lists I'm not seeing
anything for list I can type in list
here lists container blocks
lists um notice they have a minus or a
plus so looks like that breaks it up
into separate ones so we can give that a
go let's just go ahead and copy these
and take a look at what we get so we do
this and that will treat this as two
separate lists I guess we can have
pluses or
minuses didn't know that that's cool
again these are extensions to uh the
regular one and then we can have our
unordered list
or sorry ordered
lists okay so it's interesting that you
know you can do one two and then have
three but notice if you repeat three
multiple times it'll increment from
there and it starts from where it
incremented um so I think that's really
cool you can also just have them all the
same number if you want so you don't
have to really worry about that but
that's a nice way of splitting again
never knew that because I never bothered
opening this up till
now um so there's that uh let's go take
a look at uh text
formatting so we have let's say bold so
if we are supposed to do italics first
so italics is going to be
this okay scrolling down so we can see
it bold just going to do that every
single time e bold can be this
doubles and see how like formats it as
well so you can kind of have an idea you
can also probably do bold with
underscores I think apparently that does
a tal size I guess you can do one or the
other so I was kind of wrong but I guess
we could do it this or that way not all
markdown um parsers do that though some
might treat um underscores exclusively
as a bold so understand that let's try
strike
through strike through we have to use
doubles for some reason there we go does
markdown give us anything or gfm does it
give us anything fun we'll go all the
way to the top here
um characters and
lines apparently apparently pays
attention to tabs that's
cool
um yeah not exactly sure but maybe there
is something else there some inline
stuff so that's fine uh we'll go to the
next one we have
code so for code here we'll say
code what we'll want to have here is
stuff like um backtick so we might say
um something as like puts hello Ruby so
that's how you say that's how you print
in
Ruby hello world notice that it has this
interesting formatting so it's different
from like whether we were to bold so if
we were to do the same thing it wouldn't
be really the same thing right if we did
this in
bold that's
great but take out the back
ticks but like this is a lot better when
you have something inline so you can
print to the terminal
using
the command so that's really good when
you want inline code so say like inline
code
multi-line code so here I could do
triple back
ticks it will
say without
highlighting
with
highlighting okay so we'll say something
like defa hello
world
and
puts
hello
world I'll copy this I'll bring this
down here we'll do RB and so notice this
one's highlighted and this one's not so
really try to do those High highlights
as you can um I think they say like what
it's using underneath so there's
probably I can't remember what it is but
uh they say in the documentation in the
getting started like what syntax
highlighting program they're using and
so you can probably look up these codes
but for the most part you can guess I
don't know if like I typed in Ruby if
that would still work as well it looks
to be the same yeah it's the same so
Ruby or the extension okay so there's
that uh we have tables so we'll go down
below here I really don't like making
tables but we can try this
here we use that text Toolbar to make it
really easy but I'm not going to do that
um so somewhere here should be tables
tables tables tables tables tables
tables tables just search tables here it
is
extension okay so some things are like
clear extensions and other things are
just like the settings they use as their
default so go down here and so this is a
basic
table okay
you always use three for this I'm not
sure why but it's always three and you
have to follow this
format here's something that looks like
more about um changing the alignment
let's go here make sure we're at the
right levels here um so maybe you don't
have to have that so cells in one column
don't need to match the length Okay so
basically you can do whatever you want
here and does it stretch it more if we
go
more no it doesn't so it's say it's one
or whatever but standard markdown would
only have uh three so that's uh like
that's nice that you don't have to do
exactly exactly three every
time um so that's piped content okay
that's
fine I see something a little bit more
exotic that's kind of interesting so I
think it make an empty cell in this
case I think I'm missing the one in the
front
here uh that didn't render
out
so despite it being in there oh you know
this one's missing that's why it's
getting
confused and this one's
missing what if I take this one out no
this one just does not render so I'm not
sure why they show that as an example
because that doesn't render oh it will
not be recognized okay I thought for
some reason it would be like it leave an
empty space let's try this one there we
go so we have an empty space in this
case but in this case it doesn't so I
guess you have to have the full length
and if there's one like if you don't
have the full length of one then it
won't work okay looks like we can just
have a
heading or is it a body yeah just the
heading so I know there's more to it
than that but um for whatever reason
that's what it's showing up
there we could take a look at block
quotes um this is kind of interesting
I've never seen that much for Block
quotes before let's go block quote let
so when you're doing like a quote for
somebody or like you're making like a
note so that's really interesting
usually I would just do this like um uh
the cloud is amazing right so you do
that but here we're actually getting
some different levels here I never knew
you could do that let's try
this block
quote okay this one
is similar wasn't super exciting there
so so yeah that's interesting let's go
back to our top we have
um block quotes I can't spell block
quotes this block quotes and I'll go all
the way down to the bottom here or back
to the top images images we'll do images
and links this should really
be over here so something we could do is
if we wanted to make a link we could
link um let's say we want to uh link
this I'm just going to copy this here
unordered lists and we could put squares
around it like
this okay and notice as soon as I hit
pound this is specific to GitHub but it
can link to the anchors that it sees on
the page so if I want to link to this
unordered list uh it'd be this right so
this would map to that which is really
nice so if I click that it would jump to
that part of the page okay you can also
do relative links to other stuff so if I
had like um a file in here and I just
say uh
secret secret. MD
uh we say
this secret
page if I spelled that right secret
secet
secret secret okay that other one looks
right to me I can't really tell the
difference um so you know like for links
I just want to link to that so these
links are going to be become very useful
here in a second
so say
links so let's try this again Link Link
Link Link Link we not have a heading for
this yet so I go down here links all the
way back to the
top links and now I can just jump to
that here on the right hand side and so
maybe we want to go to that secret page
so I'm going to do
squares uh parentheses and this is going
to be this part is the text I think um
secret page and so this goes to the
secret page so now what I can do is I
could type
in um trying to think how I do this real
so now see how it's autoc comp
completing so if I do this this will
actually jump to that right so and I
don't think you need that you probably
do that as well it would still go there
and so this is a great way to navigate
around when you have a lot of pages
again this is specific to GitHub um so
other things might not do that uh we can
just put a link out to anywhere here so
let's say we want to do um something up
to like github.com we say GitHub website
and we just type type in
htps
Colon github.com if something looks like
a link it will turn it into a link so
that's really nice as well you might be
fun to try out that repo thing remember
the link and auto links so let's say we
did uh issue one I wonder if it would
render in here uh it didn't but you know
this might be contextual based on where
it is so this might only work in
comments and I actually think that in my
um my slide that's actually what it says
is that U it should that it only works
in comment so we might have to go test
that out here in a moment um so is there
anything else that we're missing we
didn't do images usually you drag images
in here and then they'll they'll they'll
populate so I'll show that somewhere
else but we'll consider this our
markdown stuff here it'll say markdown
examples okay the thing we didn't do was
I think a list so if I did this I could
say like item one can put a space here
just say Tas
Lisk um double here and say item one
item two I'm not sure if it'll work
here it's not rendering it that doesn't
mean it's not working it just doesn't
render here and so we'll go ahead and um
just commit these changes make sure we
get all of them so I'm just going to add
this refresh got them all in here and
we'll commit that so let's go take a
look at some of the other markdown stuff
that we're not going to see here um so
what I want to do is go back to this
repo so there's a link here I think
codes spaces doesn't I think last time I
was looking for and I couldn't find it
and so what we might want to do is look
at an issue and play around with Mark
down here so we don't have any issues in
this repo right now it's going to make a
new issue um and apparently we can link
to pull requests and other things like
that so I might need to do a little bit
more than just what we're doing here but
anyway I'll just say um GitHub fun or
sorry get or markdown
fun learning how to use markdown and so
what we could do here is make a list so
let's try the forward slash because
that's something they want us to know
and I mean we could use this for a few
different things adds a detail section
to hide and show Stu that's kind of cool
it drop that in there and we can just
say my to-do list apparently has a
summary didn't tell us that before and
go here see we have this nice drop down
um I don't know if we need this interior
P but what I want to do is make a list I
could try doing forward slash to see
what else we have here nothing really
interesting you can seert issue
templates that's kind of cool right
there we'll look at that later but let's
try to do this to-do list because that's
what I'm really interested in so I'll
just say um we'll say
lists
and
headings it's a little bit small I'll
bump it up I'm sorry
headings
and bold and
italics and we'll go ahead and submit
that issue let's expand that notice that
these are
now uh we can sort and move this around
and we can check these things off um
it's probably possible for us to link
issues to other issues I'm going to try
to make another is again I don't know if
this will work but I'll try it actually
before we do that let's do it over here
so let's say we want to do headings this
used to be on the left hand side now
they have it on the right whatever we'll
click that and it should make a new
issue okay so we do that and now it's
being tracked I guess so we go over here
let's see what happens if we close
it say this is
maybe we can reference this
references um this one here notice that
we have a link there for the repo I'm G
to try this Andrew WC
Brown and we'll say
GitHub I'm going try to write it exactly
the same here GitHub examples because
they said that would link it didn't
copyright we'll try that one more
time do that again
it really does not want to listen here
we'll try this
again GitHub example so I want to
see what we're getting here so this
isn't linking how I was hoping it would
I mean it says in the docs you can so
I'm not making things up here we'll just
comment on
that okay that didn't hyperlink
interesting let's go take a look at that
autolinks
GitHub
okay
um this might have been in
like gfm getting
started I have to kind of remember where
that is
GitHub and we'll go to this
here and I'm looking
for where that could be um no no not
this not this one
um like they had like a getting started
for
GitHub flavored
markdown here here it probably is there
we go and so in here they should have
things for like autol links I'm going
grab this so we don't have to find it
later on
um I'm just going to modify the file so
I have it go back over to our examples
here and into our
markdown and I'm just going to go ahead
and edit this
file in line because I'm only making one
line change we could do a lot from just
here but again it's a lot more
um uh efficient
to use
github.io
links
links Auto
links anyway I know that they're there
because I took screenshots and I and
like I wherever it was it's somewhere
okay maybe it's like Advanced
formatting that's probably what it might
have been code blocks autol link
references okay here we go so in
here we should be able to link the
repo reference
type I didn't understand
it over here oh maybe we got to put an
issue afterwards okay so maybe we just
can't link the repo by itself uh we're
saying a very specific repo so I guess
that is a minor mistake on my part let's
go back to our
issues
okay good thing we always double triple
check things if I go back to this then
maybe I do pound and then four on this
would that work there we go okay and
then it shortens it and then we can see
our to-do list here can we check off
from here that'd be cool if we could no
but uh let's close this issue because
what I want to see is does that close
that thing out so we go over here and
look it says one of four task completed
which is really cool um so the question
is if we were to check off all these
things would this all be
done this one this
one this one there we go okay um so
that's pretty interesting there's a lot
of little markdown things that we can do
um but I think that is sufficient uh and
we have a good idea how to work with
markdown um documentation is its own
little skill so you know getting as much
practice as you can is really great but
I'll see you in the next one uh
[Music]
ciao let's talk about uploading files on
GitHub because it's super easy the idea
is that you can just drag them into any
markdown box and it will generate out uh
that image tag we didn't do it in the
markdown section because I wanted to
leave it for this but what it will do is
it will have a placeholder and when it
finishes it will then U place a link and
basically GitHub is then hosting uh that
file that you uploading in terms of what
you can upload well there's a maximum
file size of 10 megabytes for images and
Gifts 10 megabytes for videos
surprisingly I didn't know they could do
videos uploaded to a repo owned by a
user or org of a free GitHub plan 100
megabytes for videos uploaded to a repo
owned by a user or org on a paid GitHub
plan 25 megabytes for all other files um
supported files would be PNG GIF
jpeg um SVG log files markdown files
Microsoft Word PowerPoint Excel text
files PDFs Zips and video so there you
[Music]
go hey it's Andrew Brown and this fall
along I just want to show you how to
upload files very quickly when you in
comments I don't know if this works in
uh GitHub dodev I don't think so but in
the comment boxes it absolutely will so
what I'm going to do is go over to our
issues and we're still learning how to
use markdown I didn't finish that task
and the idea is that we want to have
some kind of image so basically what you
need to do is download any kind of image
I got an image on my desktop right over
here and so what I'm going to do is drag
it on in and I'm going to drop it in and
notice that it's going to replace it
with this link format and uh so if I go
to preview you can see the images there
it say simple as that so that's all I
wanted to show you you can also go here
and upload directly it'll open up you
know your your downloads box but I don't
really want to do that I just prefer
dragging and that's it see you in the
next one ciao
hey this is Andrew Brown and let's take
a look at the GitHub user profile so for
personal accounts you get a GitHub user
profile to Showcase yourself as a
developer and that seems to be what they
want the focus to be as as you uh start
using it you kind of get that idea so
here's an example of mine on my personal
account and let's just walk through the
features of this profile so we have a
profile picture and bio uh that you can
provide there um um notice that the bio
is actually this little small tagline
that's under your account right here uh
we have user profile readme so that is
this readme file over here that you can
uh put whatever you like in it'll show
it'll showcase your repos including the
the ones that you've pinned as your
favorite you'll have the contributors
graph this is a graph displaying your
contributors over the past year you
might see an exam question on this I got
one uh for contributors graph so
basically what is it actually showing uh
it has commits PLL request issues and
cod reviews if you remember that stuff
like what's in it then it'll be very
easy to pick it out in a lineup you have
followers and following so this displays
the number of followers you have and the
numbers of users you are following I
didn't even know I had followers on
GitHub but apparently I do you have
stars so show repos you have starred we
have organizations so list the GitHub
organizations you are part of contrib
contribution activities detailed list of
recent activities on GitHub let's take a
look at these features in more a closer
view here um so the first thing is that
big um uh profile read me and you can
have your own all you got to do is
create a public repo with the same
username and uh the same username as the
repo name and the user trying to get my
pen tool out here that wasn't supposed
to be uppercase you know PowerPoint
likes to title titlee stuff all the time
but you can see up here this is what it
is and then I just have a read me and
that's what it's rendering out um so
that's pretty straightforward you can
change uh your profile photo your
display name bio URL in your profile and
your social social accounts URL so name
bio if you want pronouns URL social
accounts choose your public email if you
even want to show one uh so there's that
there if you're looking for a job you
can also say hey I'm looking for work um
you can pin specific GitHub repos that
best showcase your work so you know if
you want to say I made this video came
called Swap and pop a long time ago this
is like 2016 which was a clone of
testers attack so I wanted to Showcase
that really good skills or maybe the 100
days of cloud that was another project
that I had so there's other things like
that that you might want to
showcase um and it's very easy to pin
you just go there and say I want to pin
these repos or these gists if you don't
know what gists are we'll talk about it
in the gist section for uh contribut
activity this is going to show how
active uh your Prof uh public profile is
and so here we are seeing activity I
think these are all basically for public
rep
some people get really creative and they
try to um make their activity uh look
like a photo I'm trying to find my
there's my mouse so they might try to
make this look like something and and
into artwork by purposely committing
they might have like a bot that does
that I don't do that but uh that is
something that you can do but there you
go
[Music]
okay hey it's Angie Brown and we're
taking a look at GitHub user profile so
we do have uh this new user I created
but I want to show you what mine looks
like first because I want to just make a
call out uh to something that might show
up on the exam and I didn't include in
the lecture slides and it honestly threw
me off that they even bothered asking
this in the exam but uh they might ask
you about uh some of the
features uh in the profile and one of
them is about achievements so I don't
know why why they would ever ask this
but achievements are things that you do
um that you can earn uh uh these
pointless badges for doing certain
things okay what those things are I
don't even know I don't even think it
matters but the point is that they have
them here and they'll ask you on the
exam about achievements for some crazy
reason so I wanted to point that out but
you have an idea of what my repo looks
like or my profile looks like let's go
back over to the other account and get
set up so we already set up a um a user
profile photo for this one and before it
was it was showing the old one so we
couldn't really see it also I just
notice that we can set status here I
didn't even know that I don't think I
would ever do that this isn't a you know
it's not it's this is not a um uh what
do you call it a social media platform
but whatever they have everything under
the sun here but this is now showing up
here you've unlocked new achievements
with private contributions show them off
by including private contributions in
your profile in your settings and look
hey I'm already getting junk
achievements but just understand that
they're there um what we can do is pin
this here so we can go ahead and say
let's pin uh this repository here um
apparently we can pin this other one I
think it's CU we contributed to it
that's why we can pin it I'm going to go
ahead and just say GitHub examples and
save my own and it was already kind of
showing up there but now it's there we
can go over to gists for fun and make a
new gist and then pin
that just say uh
hello hello. MD and I'm just going to go
here and say puts hello H
world and we'll scroll on down and we
will create this as a public
gist okay I'm going to go back over here
I might already show up because we have
such few stuff here but I can open this
up and I'll pin this and now I have this
gist so maybe if you want to like have a
read me file and have more information
this is actually kind of a smart idea
would be to have like two of them up
here and pin them I never even thought
of that uh let's go uh ahead and get in
our uh read me page so we know that if
we create a repo with the exact same
name we can have that so I'll go ahead
and make a new repo I call this one
Andrew WC Brown and notice that we get
this nice little popup I like the little
icon or the uh pixel graphic here this
is a special repo okay make sure it's
initialized with the read me to get
started so go ahead and create a read
me and that's now there if we go over to
our
profile okay it's there so pretty
straightforward not much else to say
there um there you go okay we'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
ciao let's quickly talk about readme
files these are markdown files that
provide documentation and structional
information and a repo a GitHub repo
that has a readme.md or readme and all
caps or read me and all caps with. MD in
the projects rout will be rendered on
the homepage there's actually some other
markdown files that will also be
rendered there but it's really important
to remember the read me one as it will
probably come up as an exam question and
they'll actually ask you like what uh
where where should this be located it's
always in the root that's what's going
to render I don't think it renders
anything else but that one and they
might kind of trick you there um you do
get this nice little table of contents
on the right hand side so if you have uh
headings it will figure that out for you
there I remember that wasn't there
before so that's really nice um but yeah
it's as simple as that
[Music]
okay so GitHub wants you to know about
basic repo navigation what that means I
don't really know so I'm taking my best
guess to show you what that is uh So
within a GitHub repo you will have a
navigation bar with various features of
your GitHub repo and this is how you get
to all the cool stuff and the main one
is code this is where your code's going
to live um such as files folders things
like that um we have issues that's for
tracking problems it's basically a
ticket tracker we have pull requests
that's where we're going to be uh uh
when we're managing collaboration with
other developers and they want to bring
changes into our repo it's our
opportunity to check that work before it
gets merged in we have actions that's
for GitHub actions uh for projects
that's for GitHub projects uh for wikis
that's the wiki security is like a a
list or a um a checklist of things that
you should do I think it changes if you
are looking at the context of a uh as a
a user and you're not the owner of the
repo you're going to see maybe the
security policy or different information
but if you are the owner you're going to
have a checklist of things you should do
and it basically mirrors kind of what's
in the settings page under security so
it's kind of weird that they do that but
that's how they do it then we have
insights this provides uh statistics
mostly in the form of charts and graphs
about the repo sometimes this
information is public sometimes it's
private then you have settings this is
where you control all the settings for
your repo um the other thing is that
when you are using at least in the code
section you can navigate around files so
I showed showed you this in a a prior um
follow along but the idea is you can
search stuff you can see the contents of
file you can comment on code per line so
there you
[Music]
go so when you create a repo you can
choose which owner you want it to be so
right now I have it set as uh my
personal account but you could drop that
down and you could also choose an
organization that you belong to repo
names are scoped B based on the account
so you can have the same name uh for
different organizations other people can
have the same name if they're a
different user so just understand that
you can do that uh you need to choose an
available GitHub name again based on
that scope uh your repos can either be
public or private um pretty
self-explanatory you can quickly add a
readme file a do get ignore and license
it's very very important to remember
those three because you might get an
exam question asking about the three
things that you can quickly and easily
add if you're using the CLI you can add
it uh this way or create one we did this
earlier when we did the GitHub CLI kind
of demonstration and we found out that
repos require special additional
permissions or personal access token
permissions um that the GitHub Cod
spaces would not allow you to do but
yeah there you go that's a creat a
[Music]
repo all right let's go ahead and create
ourselves a repo I know we already know
how to do this but it gives us an
opportunity to talk a little bit more
about uh some of the things that might
appear on the exam you can create one up
here in the top right corner and I have
this double click problem so it's
getting a bit confused I can go to this
new green button that's usually what I
do and we can have a new repo so I'm
going to say my uh cool repo right we
can provide a description um this repo
is amazing and we can set it as public
or private I'm going to stick with
private for now and we'll add a read me
we'll drop down to get ignore we'll say
may we're working with Ruby so we'll get
that by default and we'll add a license
like MIT we go ahead and create that
repo um I want to point out that you
have other things that are rendered here
so that should be very clear um we have
releases and packages which we should
talk about at some point I'm going to
leave this repo around if we want to
play around with it um but uh yeah it's
pretty clear how to create a repo it's
not hard let's go take a look at a more
popular repo like Ruby on Rails um so
I'm just going to type this up here and
type in rails and we'll take a look and
see what they have um so if we go into
here you'll notice there are just more
things we have codes of conduct right we
have our MIT we have our security policy
if we go up here to the security tab
this is what we can see um so we have
the security policy being rendered out
here and then it's showing um possible
uh exposures probably based on one of
the scanners I'm not exactly sure which
one is showing that um but that is that
there if we go back to our own repo we
might be able to take a look at security
here hold
on uh going back to wherever that one
was we just made that repo it can be a
little bit of pain to sometimes find
your own repos I'm not sure why they've
never made that easier but just how it
is and if we go down we can find my cool
repo here and there's this security Tab
and notice that it's listing out uh
things that you should do for your repo
it's important to know what these are
because um
well if you have this uh the exam is
going to probably ask you like what's
what things can you access from here and
this is just from the public repo if you
have a private repo it's going to be
different sorry this is private public
can be different so let's just open this
up and make a comparison and see if what
kind of difference there is here so if
we go over to repo here and we go into
this public one over here what options
do we
get so we get a lot more going on here
so notice that this is the price private
and that is the public probably because
if you're if you had a paid version You'
then get additional code scanning and
secret scanning for public repos you
automatically get that stuff I just want
to point out that all this stuff is also
under your settings under uh Security
Options so they kind of just like repeat
it there you know so it's just what they
do but hopefully that makes sense and
that's all I wanted to show you so I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao let's talk about maintaining a repo
now what's unusual about this slide
content It's Not Unusual but it's the
fact that in the outline they have a
whole section for GitHub Administration
and uh for whatever reason I have it
over here as opposed into the other
section because of the way the outline
is designed so understand that I'm not
going to cover that stuff in that other
section because it's just repeated um
but anyway let's continue on and look at
maintaining repo so the first thing is
your name so you can change the name of
the repo if you do not like it as long
as the name is available you can
absolutely do that and a reminder that
repo names are scoped based on personal
or organizational accounts or
organization accounts I I keep writing
organizational but it means the same
thing uh you can change the base Branch
the default Branch uh you can rename it
um just so you know Maine is the
unspoken best practice for naming your
base Branch everybody does it the old
one was Master nobody calls it Master
anymore um you can opt in and opt out of
some features for your GitHub repo I say
some as a catch all just in case there's
features that do not show up or there's
ones that are locked in um but that's
pretty straightforward you just check a
box and you might have to do some
additional configuration then there's
the danger zone which contains actions
you need to think twice about because
they cannot be undone if you make a big
mistake and in the danger zone we have
the ability to change the repo
visibility um it's important to
understand what happens when you make a
a a repo from private to public the code
will be visible to everyone who can
visit at github.com anyone can Fork your
repo all push rule sets will be disabled
your changes will be published as
activity now will this show up in the
exam probably not I didn't see it but
that is something to consider um you can
disable Branch protection rules uh so
Branch protection rules are strict
workflow rules uh uh that just like will
do something like disallow someone from
pushing to Main and uh you can
temporarily disable them if you have to
apply quick fixes and you can't work
around those r rules easily you can
transfer ownership to somebody else and
they'll become the owner of the repo you
can archive the repo so it becomes read
only you can delete the repo so there
you
[Music]
go all right time for some repo
maintenance uh so what we're going to do
is I want to create a new repo I'm going
to make it in my other account uh just
because we're going to want to transfer
from one to another but I'm going to go
here and just say um uh under here Omen
King and I'm gon say my cool repo 2 okay
and I'm gonna just make this private and
I'm going to add a read me here um I'm
going to go ahead and create this repo
okay so now that this is repo created we
can go over to our settings and let's
say I didn't like the name two I need it
to be three because we already have
another one called two in the other
account I'm going to rename that and it
renames before we used to rename it used
to take time now it's instantaneous
which is really really great if we
scroll on down we could change the main
branch we could change the name to main
two um there are some uh limitations
there because it's not showing all of
our options as we don't have other
branches apparently it doesn't create it
instantaneously but it will change it in
a bit of time there it is so I think it
has taken effect if we go here and yeah
it shows that it's been renamed so that
sounds really good we're going to go
back over to settings notice that we can
checkbox and uh checkbox on and off
features let's let's get rid of issues
let's get rid of projects if we go over
here to our code notice that they have
vanished across the top so that is great
we'll scroll on down um we have more
abilities somewhere here in the danger
zone so we can change our visibility it
will give us a warning about it I'm not
sure why it's making it so hard I'm
going to make this public I'm going to
say that I I accept the changes and
we're going to make it public and then
apparently I have to confirm so I'm
going to get out my phone and it wants
me to enter a number into my
phone okay so 37 approve
great and I'll wait a moment for it to
take effect there we go so now it is
public um we can disable our Branch
rules so I'm going to go ahead and do
that uh we can go ahead and transfer
this repo I'm going to send it
to um a specific person so this is going
to
be I want to send it
to Andrew WC Brown which is the other me
and then I got to type in the repo name
so we'll go ahead and do that my cool
repo 3 I
understand okay so now it should be
transferred
um and I think the other person has to
accept so I don't think it's
instantaneous so if we go over
here h
do I have the repo now if I go up here
in my
notifications how do I see the repo
transfer I'm not sure I'm going to go
check the email for this account and see
if it shows up there okay all right so
in my email we can see over here that uh
there is a repo transfer link so I'm
going to go ahead and click
[Music]
that GitHub repo templates is a feature
for public repos that allows other
GitHub users to make a copy of the
contents of the template repo to use as
a starting point for their own repo and
I believe it's only for public I I
haven't checked for private but I don't
know why you'd want to use it for
private we set a uh a repo as as a
template by checking box on the template
repository and then you'll have this
option to use the template and when you
click use this template it will then ask
you to choose a new name and it'll say
what do you want to include and then
it'll show that that was generated from
that other template I use these in my
boot camps because I will create a
starter project and then you will start
from that template how are these how is
this different from cloning or forking
um the idea here is that um you're
starting with a clean repo you're not
having all the baggage of of stuff that
comes with it it is a really clear clean
repo and so that's how you're going to
go ahead and uh utilize it but that use
case that I explained for which is like
you know you want to have something like
a project that people are going to start
as a basis of that's where going to be
using repo templates okay
[Music]
ciao hey it's Angie Brown and this fall
along we'll go ahead and make a repo
template so um we have
here um let's go over here to our other
repo trying to find
it sometimes it's a bit hard to navigate
repos there we go that's a bit better
and so we have this my cool repo what I
want to do is convert this repo into a
public repo for now just so that we can
utilize this feature I want to go to the
top and see if we can make a template
actually it looks like we can I'm really
surprised because what would be the
point if um it's private you know what I
mean because we go here how's anyone
going to click that button it doesn't
make any sense so I really think that
that is a public feature and notice I
actually checkbox it on and it turned
off so I think it
is yeah it is nope okay it's on
now all right
I mean I guess you could use it to make
your own from it so I guess my thought
was it was always about other people
using it but I guess you could make your
own default template and use it for
yourself so I guess it's not just a
public feature but they're never going
to ask you on the exam so I'm not going
to fix the slides because of that let's
go ahead and uh create a new repository
from this template and we'll just say my
cool repo 2 and we'll make it private
and also we can include other branches
but I don't want anything else
and there we go so now we have this uh
repo that is making a copy of we'll give
it a moment and here it is you can see
it's generated from that one and there
you go
[Music]
ciao so in GitHub you can clone a repo
programmatically three different ways uh
we have the first which is https uh you
will have to supply a GitHub username
and password on the clone and you'll
need to set uh get to cach the
credentials if you don't want to keep
entering them in I didn't write it in
here but when it says password we're
talking about the um personal access
token because GitHub does not let you
use passwords anymore um but in the
documentation it kind of suggests that
you can use a password because it says
password protected oh not here but under
here would it would it would say that um
for
SSH uh you can utilize that method
you'll have to have an SSH key pair and
you'll have to upload that to your uh
GitHub account then we have the GitHub
CLI um so we can do that as well this is
going to use credentials uh when you do
GitHub login it'll actually use either a
personal access token or SSH we can also
clone repos in the GitHub desktop and we
can just download a zip it's not really
cloning but we can download the contents
of it um so that's pretty
straightforward there sometimes you just
want the the the codes repo um I want to
point out that we did all this in the
quick and dirty git and GitHub crash
course so if you're wondering how to do
these three make sure you have watched
that video and you've done it all okay
see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao you can add files to your GitHub
repo directly via the GitHub UI if you
drop down code you or sorry add file
you'll have create new file or upload
files so it's great for both text and
binary files um and uh the idea here is
that when you uh go ahead and add a file
if you need to have folders you can put
a for Slash and it will end up creating
as many folders as you want and then you
put the name in and you just create that
file there when adding multiple files
that you also need to edit you can also
quickly use
[Music]
there are lots of ways of creating
branches in GitHub and git um something
that you should really know how to do is
to use this single line command get
checkout hyphen B to both create and
check out a branch in one go you should
absolutely know how to do get push
hyphen U origin staging which is
basically The Hyphen U is short for
hyphen hyphen setup stream I know it
looks like a single hyphen there but
there's actually two
uh for this flag you can create branches
from issues um and then the branch and
issue will be Associated and linked you
can directly create branches in the
GitHub UI you can create branches in the
GitHub desktop and I'm sure you can
create branches in the GitHub CLI and uh
yeah there you
[Music]
go hey it's Angie Brown and this fall
along I want to create some branches
nothing super difficult to do but um
something that will take us just a
moment I'm going to go ahead and use um
our my cool repo and what I want to do
here is I want to go ahead actually I
want to clean these up I don't want to
have a bunch of uh junk repos hanging
around so actually I decided against
that and I just want to keep things
clean and keep with our single repo even
if it is U public so I'm going to go
ahead and type my cool repo here and
clean this up Andrew WC
Brown or man geez Andrew WC
brown brown my cool repo it's that
autocomplete that's messing it up there
we go and I'm just going to go ahead and
also get rid of this one and then we'll
just be really focused on what we need
to do at hand
here just give me a
moment
there we go okay so now let's just go
back to our GitHub examples and there
are a few ways that we can create issues
uh one is or sorry branches one way is
to go to the branches Tab and I'm pretty
sure we can just create them right here
so I can go here and just say uh feature
uh cool one okay and we can say what
we're branching
from so that's an example and there it
is uh another really useful way and
something I really recommend is you
create an issue and we'll and we'll make
a task saying create a branch from an
issue okay and then what we can do is
then go ahead and create a branch here
in development in the bottom right
corner noce is going to put the number
in here that's a very common pattern is
to have whatever your issued number is
and then a a a short name for the branch
okay then saying like what should we do
next code spaces locally I don't really
want to do anything next I just want to
um do nothing but I'll go ahead and hit
create branch and so then it gives us
like a button where we could click to go
ahead and play around with it so that is
something I do a lot when I teach boot
camps I show this a lot this is a very
common workflow and something you should
absolutely remember uh that you can do
um let's go ahead and launch up this in
code spaces going to go here and uh we
have this one here sure I'll launch up
this old one sure why not and once this
is launched up we'll take a look and
learn how to use a very cool shorthand
for um
implementing uh checkout
and creating a branch in one go okay so
just back here when this is ready all
right all right so this is back up and
running and notice that we are currently
in the main branch we can type in get
Branch to get a list of br branches and
so what I want to do is I want to create
myself a new Branch here and actually
there are other branches it's just not
showing them if we do get
pull um it might show us those other
branches there we go and now if we type
in get
Branch it still doesn't show them but
that doesn't mean we can't check them
out but uh our um our uh uh program is
aware of it we might also be able to
create branches within a git graph these
were things that we installed earlier so
they might have the option to do that
here I'm not 100%
sure see create Branch so we could do
that as well I'm not going to do that
but what I really want to show you is
something that will show up in the exam
I'm actually really surprised that it
did but it is a really good thing to to
um uh to know is that normally when you
create a branch you'd have to type in
get branch and I'd say my new Branch
like this and then I'd have to do get
check out my new
Branch okay and so that's something you
can do
but what is more efficient you go check
out back to main is we can do that in
one call we can see get checkout hyphen
B for branch my new Branch 2 and that's
going to create that branch and check it
out so really make sure you remember
this one because it will absolutely show
up on your exam it's absolutely
something you'll use every single day I
strongly recommend it the last thing um
I want to go over is just pushing to
origin so what we can do is is set um
Upstream but think that U is a lot
easier to do we say origin and we just
say my new Branch here two and then that
will push that Branch up there because
you really want to know how to set that
origin so that's all I really wanted to
show you and um yeah we can just stop
this environment so we'll go ahead to
command pallet just say stop current
code space and I'll see you in the next
one okay
[Music]
CIA so starring repos is uh something
that we can do and it's similar to
bookmarking uh for a repo that we're
interested in keeping track of and so
stars are public and everyone can see
them and usually this is an indicator
whether something is really popular in
fact GitHub might take notice uh in
their community and do something nice um
so a lot of people seem to care about
star counts and uh make it their goal to
try to get as many as they can if you
want to find um starred projects that
you have starred you can go to
github.com
stars and there's a few other things
that we can explore um and you know in
the exam they might actually ask you
what that URL is to get to uh your
starred um uh uh starred things that you
have starred so just make sure you
remember that URL
[Music]
okay hey this is Angie Brown and this
follow along I want to take a look at
starring Repose so what we can do here
is just go into our own project and I
think we could star our own which is a
little bit silly but it's something we
can do we could also put it into a list
so let's go ahead and hit start and I
might also want to say this is for
inspiration and so now that I've started
that stuff let's go take a look at our
actual start pages so we could type in
Stars at the top here but I think also
on the right hand side we can go to your
stars and um I mean this is
showing stuff that we've starred and
this has a list but that wasn't the same
page that I saw so I'm actually
surprised this is different and maybe
there's actually two there's this one
and another one so let's go ahead and
type in Stars at the top
here yeah why do they have why do they
have two different pages they got this
one and then they got this one and to me
it's like the same
thing okay whatever I guess maybe one is
specific to the repo so this one's for
Andre Brown Stars so is that like public
ones that everyone else can see what if
I go up to here to my profile you know
what I actually never noticed these tabs
up here before so yeah I guess this is
your public profile one of things that
you have started if you want to show
other people I didn't realize that and
then we actually have this other one
which is the Stars
okay um I could probably show you
something a little bit more because in
mine I have a lot more starred stuff not
that I remember what I have starred but
if we go here to Stars you can see a lot
more uh stuff here and it shows you
could jump to a friend we have
categories which is kind of cool I don't
really see the list
here but I suppose that's more for the
profile uh but yeah that's about it um
and maybe you might want to remember uh
over here you all for this okay because
like I remember just on the exam they're
asking about like the star the star URL
and I know that's supposed to be Stars
okay but we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao another thing we can do is watch
repos and this allows you to stay stay
informed about activities occurring
within a repo so the idea is that you'll
hit watch and then you can say uh to
what level of notifications you want for
watching and notice that if I go custom
I can say exactly what I'm looking to
watch and in then your GitHub account
you can specify how you want to be
notified so there you
[Music]
go let's take a look at watching repos
and I actually can point out a repo that
drives me crazy because um somehow I got
I got subscribed to it and they update
it so often and it's Wing Lang and I'm
not saying it's a bad project I'm just
saying like they really shouldn't have
opted everybody into the uh to the
alerts because it it's driven me
crazy um so like notice here I said stop
ignoring because I I was like tired of
getting updates for this and the reason
why was that in order to get access to
this project in the beta they had to add
you uh in some in some manner I'm not
sure if it was a contributor or
something else but all I know I was
really getting sick and tired of getting
alerts on my phone so cuz it'll it'll
have in summaries and it'll it'll fill
up these digest emails and it gets
annoying so I ignored it okay but let's
go ahead and I'm going to pretend that I
want to uh watch another project here
from Andrew Brown and we can go over
here to GitHub examples and then we can
go ahead and click watch and um we can
say all activity right we go to custom
change maybe we just want
issues okay I'll go back and say for
everything here there we go and I just
want to point out if you go to your
settings uh your settings over here and
then we go to Notifications we can
control you know what we want to see for
notification specifically for watching
we can say here on GitHub or email you
say I don't want the emails okay so very
straightforward um is there a place to
see all of the stuff that you're
watching
probably uh we could try
like I think it's under notifications
it's like notifications maybe it's like
watching I know this is another slide
later on in the course here it is and so
I can see everything that I'm watching
and I could just say stop watching all
the stuff notice that I'm automatically
watching stuff for my own repo so
automatically you're always set to watch
all of them if that makes sense but
there you
[Music]
go feature previews allows you to enable
or disable features that are in beta in
your personal accounts so the idea is
that we have feature uh feat previews
and we go over here and then just kind
of enable it is what we want to have um
some of them might be already turned on
some of them you might want to turn off
but let's go take a look at it
okay all right so I'm in my count and I
want to go ahead and take a look at fe
uh feature previews I don't want to
meddle with my main account but I'm
going to go here and go to feature
previews and here we can see some stuff
so let's say we wanted the command
pallet that sounds really cool I'm going
to turn that on actually I think it's
already on I didn't even know that we
could do that and it seems like we would
have like this Global search thing we
could turn off slash commands if we
wanted to so we say disable or enable it
let's go take a look at command pallets
because I even know that we had it says
here contrl K I'm on a Windows machine
right now so we have control all K or
control K I'm going to give that a go
and so I'm going to try this contrl
K oo look at that that is smooth and so
then we can jump to something uh what if
I type in
gists no but I mean like maybe we could
find stuff really quickly I mean that's
kind of nice like P personal access
token uh let's say I want to go to
Andrew or let's say we want to go to uh
examples oh yeah I'm going to use that a
lot more you might see me doing that I
might tell you that um I really hope
that that becomes a main feature because
it's really nice um feature previews I
assume this is beta um I don't think
Alpha features ever get shown but that
is really cool I'm surprised they didn't
put that in the exam anyway we'll see
the next one okay
[Music]
ciao so tagging is used to capture a
point in history to Mark version
released of your codebase and GitHub
makes it easy to explore tag versions of
your git Rebo so here's an example of
Ruby on Rails and you can see they have
516 tags and if you go into the drop
down where your branches are you can
switch over to the tags and you can see
the versioning um tagging is not
specific to GitHub it is a feature of G
um and just a good practice to know
these are common uh git commands get tag
commands you absolutely should know
they're super useful uh to utilize and a
very common um workflow is if you have a
production Branch to tag when you tag a
release that would be the thing that
would trigger it out and send it uh to
uh your production compute so um yeah
tagging is super important um and often
when you see milestones in GitHub
they'll usually correspond to tags and
we looked at milestones we saw that they
were verging them based on or the names
of them were based on tag releases that
they're they're working towards um so
yeah I just want to get you some
practical knowledge with tags even if it
doesn't show up on the exam
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and this
fall along I want to show you tagging
and if you're hearing my uh heater in
the background it is super cold in my
office it's like -10 cels I do not have
heat and I'm doing the best I can so
sorry for the background noise or the
shuffling of the snowsuit but let's go
ahead and learn a bit about tagging
because tagging is such a useful skill
um that there's no way I was not going
to show you this so what we'll do is
we'll go over to um let's say our GitHub
our GitHub examples repo going to go
over here
and um yeah we'll go into this one here
and what I want to do here is I want to
start making some tags and what we'll
need to do is launch up a new code
space okay we'll give it a moment to
load up and I'll be back in just a
minute you know what I think what I
ended up doing was running the exam Pro
GitHub example so I'm just going to go
back because this one's never going to
work for me and I'm going to make sure
that I'm in the correct directory so
it's this one that I want and we'll go
back up here I'm going to go ahead and
uh well if I already have an active one
I would probably rather use that so I'm
just going to open this one you just got
to get your code space up however you're
going to get it up um but I just want to
get in here and get working so I'm going
to launch this one
no that was the one that was building I
think yeah I'm not sure sure exactly
what's wrong container build failed
checking troubleshooting view
logs uh I didn't know you check the logs
as it's
building Docker build X build
failed it's it's uh failing with
terraform so um I thought we uh I
thought we fixed that so if we go into
this is this still having the terraform
code in here it is so what I'm just
going to do here just to
um you know what I think it is um
because sometimes it works and sometimes
it doesn't and what happened last time
is it ran out of
space uh is what I noticed it was really
a weird thing that happened so what I'm
going to do is just stop this code
workspace go up
here stop stop stop let me stop it
please
you ran out of space that's fine I get
it let me stop the
workspace okay and what I'm going to do
since this seems to get us more reliable
results is always deleting the code
space I'm going to go ahead and delete
this here and I'm just going to go ahead
and make a new one okay so go all the
way back here
to the Andre Brown one here and we'll
make a new one and unfortunately that's
the most reliable way to use codes space
again I really prefer giod I don't have
these issues with giod ever but we'll
let this spin up and I'll be back here
in just a moment okay and this
environment is still failing to build
it's really bizarre what's going on here
um and I'm not exactly sure why it's
failing but
uh okay what I'm going to do I'm going
to go back to view logs here because
maybe it's messing up on that terraform
again it is Terron it's like download a
bunch of stuff I don't need so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go in here
and I'm just going to ignore this I'm
sure it's going to continue spinning up
I'm going to click into my Dev container
and I'm going to edit this and for
whatever reason it's just not working so
I'm going to comment this out for
now and we're going to just pretend
terraform doesn't
exist was working fine so many times but
if that fixes it that's good enough for
me okay so I'm going to go to our uh
code spaces again go ahead and delete
this
one and I'm going to go back to that
repo if I can please make sure I'm on
the right one and we'll go ahead and
launch it and then maybe that must be
old Let me refresh that I thought we
stopped it there we go we'll start a new
one and then maybe this time we'll get
into code spaces so see you back in a
second okay all right so this
environment finally worked I guess
terraform was giving us trouble and you
know I thought these these these
packages were pre-built
um but I guess there must be compiling
at the time of source code and there's
some issue that's happening so it might
not have that we ran out of space it
just might have not worked and totally a
detour to what we wanted to be doing but
what I'm going to do is go ahead and
create a new folder here and this one's
going to be called Tags as we want to
just work through some tagging
stuff readme.md
okay and uh there's a few things I want
to show you how to do the first thing is
how to tag so like we could say version
1.0.0 we could push our
tags we will check out we could check
out a tag at some
point I mean that's pretty
straightforward I don't think I need to
show you that but I'm just going to
write it out here so you can see it
1.0.0 we can do get tag hyphen d one Z Z
to delete our tag and then we can uh
delete
our remote tag those are the three
things I want you to know so before we
do this I want to talk about
semantic
versioning because semantic versioning
is a
way
of tagging okay and most repos use this
if you see a v in front of it I know I
used v as an example there uh in in the
actual slides I I put a v in front of it
but uh generally this is the format that
a lot of Open Source projects and places
like to use um depending on how old the
project is they might have just stuck
with the v in front of it and use
everything else with that we can take a
look here and see what rails does as an
example
repo
rails and what I want to do here is just
take a look at how they're tagging so
see they have a v in front of it and but
they've been around
forever and um I'm just telling you like
at one point this page did not exist
there there was this idea of semantic
versioning but whenever it came out you
know some of these projects existed
before then so that's the reason why you
might not see it um but anyway we'll
come back all the way over here and I
like to stick with semantic versioning
as best I can as long as I remember how
to do it and so the idea is uh we want
to apply tag to a particular commit and
just to make things a little bit easier
let's get into a dark theme and the
other thing I I'm going to want to have
installed here is get
graph all
right and I think that if we have this
installed oh looks like it's already
installed did it actually remember my
settings remember I complain about how
often it does not remember my settings
it might actually worked in this case so
if I go down below here I have git graph
and grit log they're actually both
installed but why the theme didn't
persist I don't know and the idea here
is that I want to be able to apply a tag
um and the way we can do that is we're
going to go ahead we have some
uncommitted changes going just say
tagging whoops we'll just say uh
tagging here and we'll go ahead and
first try to apply a tag so we'll say
get tag
1.0.0 and it should show up here there
it is okay great but understand this tag
is local if we go over to our
repo and we give this a nice
refresh it's not here zero tags okay so
if we want that tag to go up have to go
get push hyphen hyen tags okay when you
do your regular push you can add that as
well you can see that it's been pushed
we'll go back over to here here we'll
give this a nice refresh and now we have
one tag we go over here one tag so good
shape right um and the idea is you can
switch over to it just like a branch you
can check it out just like a branch um
and so that's something that is really
useful if we go back over to get G graph
we can now see uh it actually doesn't
show you if it's pushed which is U one
thing I think is a bit sad but uh it
doesn't show you when it's pushed so
that is one indicator that can be a
little bit confusing here um and
actually when we did push push tags it
didn't actually push the uh the commit
so I always thought it did both but I
guess it only does the tag when you do
that so we'll type in get push and make
sure that that's pushed as well there we
go they're all over here now let's say
we made a mistake with their tag
sometimes you do this you might uh
someone else tag something and then you
tagged it the same and you got to delete
your tag so we have to delete it in two
places we have to delete it locally get
tag hyen
d10 okay okay but if you go here it
still exists so I'm going to give this a
nice hard
refresh and this absolutely exists so if
we want to get rid of this one we're
going to have to type get tag hyphen
hyphen delete origin one0
Z okay um and it didn't work
there I mean that's the oh you know it's
push it's push sorry it's push we'll say
get push delete origin 1.0.0 point0 and
so now it's deleted it we probably
should have took a look at the um uh the
GitHub config file that there might have
been something interesting there but uh
we didn't I'm going go ahead and give
this a nice refresh
here and I'm just curious what would
this is rails it's not us but if we go
back here and give this a refresh this
should now be
gone I'm just going to tag this one more
time okay so I'm going to go ahead here
and say get tag 1.0
.0 I'm going to say get push hyphen hyen
tags if you wanted to tag some other
place you have to check out that commit
using the shot code and then tag it I'm
not going to do that here let's go take
a look at the um the git directory
because in that git directory it might
show us
something interesting in the config file
so we go to
settings and we know that we have
to tell to unhide certain
stuff
okay so I'm looking
for hidden files in here it's somewhere
in
here put type in dogit could find
that
dogit here it is it's under exclusions
so I want to just take that out so I can
see it and we'll go ahead and open up
our config directory because what I want
to see is if there was any tagging
information in here and there's not so
so there's nothing new here to see I
just thought there might be but yeah
that's all there is to tagging and uh
we'll call this one done and I'll see
you in the next one um okay so
[Music]
ciao so GitHub releases allows you to
create releases with release notes and
linked assets such as zip sources or
binaries for specific platforms so in a
get repo you'll see releases and from
there you can read about the release and
see all the stuff that has changed
and there might be the source code or
binaries if you if this is something
like um I'm trying to think of an
example like let's say you like to play
video games and there's an emulator uh
for like the PlayStation uh they'll have
like builds here for Windows Mac and um
other things here uh maybe you make a
video game in general you could
distribute the binary here it's anything
where you're Distributing the binaries
or the SCE source code but you're making
very clear what has changed as a release
um and often like when I'm having issu
issues with something I will actually go
through and read the releases when let's
say um like react router have you ever
used react router Dom and they've
changed versions I'm trying to
understand like what compatibilities
have changed what does not work anymore
maybe I was experiencing a bug and if
they do a good job with the
documentation it will be in there so
there you
[Music]
go hey everyone in this fall along I
want to take a look at GitHub releases
as it is a very useful feature to let
people know about changes that are
happening in your repo um so before we
do let's go take a look at some other
project that might have changes I'm
trying to think of something interesting
like maybe an
emulator um so I'm just typing emulator
in here I'm just looking for one here's
a Nintendo switch emulator or maybe PS
PS2 I'd rather do PS2 I feel like they
might have good uh information about
changes like PCS pcsx2 and on the right
hand side you can see we have releases
and if we open up the
releases um they do not tell you much
okay so that's not a great example so
we'll go back to another one and we'll
try another uh video game emulator maybe
we can just try putting the word
emulator you know and people can write
whatever kind of releases they want this
doesn't have
releases uh we'll try the 3DS emulator
this one doesn't have
releases we
have
um this one here do they have
releases no well they do they do no just
tags okay so I guess we're just going to
not get really good ones here but I
guess we could just go to rails because
they seem to always have enough for us
but I just wanted something that was
written a little bit more uh nicer so
you could see a good example of a
release but here is one where um you
know they're talking about different
versions I feel like if there was a
release for a specific uh tag
version right that uh we get better
information like when rails first came
out like 70 probably would be a good one
so I'm just scrolling through here I
mean these are pretty good but again I
just want to try to find a major release
one is this this
1.0 seven I'm going to just type in
7.0.0 might have to scroll a bit to get
it to load
08 there must
be where is it what it just skips over
it
okay well I mean 71 was pretty good so
we'll go over back to
71 and uh yeah like here it's telling
you about all the libraries and things
that are Chang this one's a bit better
because it's showing examples of things
that have changed so you can p whatever
you want to release and it's just to
help communicate what the differences
are because a lot of times you just
don't know so we did do some tagging and
that's a great opportunity for us to
create our own release in our own repo
so what I'm going to do is go back over
to our home I'm going to find find this
repo that we have I'm going to go over
to releases and we're going to create
ourselves our own release and we'll just
say version uh 1.0.0 ready for the
world the best GitHub example materials
around my hands are cold if if you can't
tell I'm
uh sorry but I'm in like full snowsuit
right now and I got the heater blowing
so if you hear the heater I apologize
but it's just how it is right now in my
office anyway we you can choose a tag
which is great and then um you can then
attach the binary so the idea is we
would download the zip and then
re-upload it again I'm not going to do
that because that's pretty
straightforward we'll go ahead and do
that and so there's our release and
that's all I really wanted to show you
for releases apparently there's a
compare button I didn't even know that
so that might be kind of cool to do but
um yeah there you
go
[Music]
so GitHub packages is a platform for
hosting and managing packages including
containers and other dependencies and
the things that it can uh host in terms
of its package registry or repository is
Javascript packages ruby gems Java Maven
and Gradle packages net packages and
Docker images and the last one I think
is going to be the most common uh one
that people can utilize um they have a
free tier they have a pay tier so you
can start using this right away and we
will go give it a go
um probably the easiest thing we could
do would be to create a Docker uh
container and then push it to GitHub
packages so that's kind of the code that
we'll have to go through we can make a
simple hello world Docker file run it
make sure we build it and uh GitHub
actions could be used to build and then
publish I put I wrote the word public
but publish packages to GitHub pages so
there you
[Music]
go hey this is Angie Brown and this fall
along what I want to do is is go ahead
and create a GitHub package so what
you're going to need to do is start up a
code space I actually already have mine
running I think by this point you
probably know how to do that I just uh
was working on the video earlier and I
had to close out and restart so that's
where we are now so anyway I'm going to
make a new folder in here this will be
for uh pack GitHub GitHub packages
okay and you're going to try to spell s
if you hear a bit of noise in the
background it's cuz I'm running the
little space heater near my feet so my
feet don't freeze I'm in full snowsuit
right now okay but anyway what we'll do
is we'll go
into the package of directory and we'll
make a new file and we'll call it Docker
file okay and from here um we want to
create this little Docker image so we'll
say
Alpine uh latest this isn't a Docker
course I'm not teaching all this but
just follow along with me here or just
copy paste it from my repo whichever you
want to do
Echo we'll say hello world okay so I'm
going to go ahead and save that file and
now what I want to do is go into that
directory and build
it so what I'll do is run Docker build
hyphen T hello world
period we'll build
that okay and and now we'll try to run
it make sure it
works there we go that works
okay and so we're in good
shape uh the other part here I would say
is now that we have our Docker image
built we want to now push that so um I'm
going to make a new read me file so I
just have a little bit of room to work
with
here and there's a few things we need to
do we need to set our username so I'm
going to say
username here I'm just going to set mine
as what I am Andrew Brown WC Brown
that's the count that I have
here okay and I'm going to put export in
front of
it so I can export
it and yeah I want allow pasting good
and we'll hit enter it actually double
pasted it so I got to be careful there I
imagine this is a bit hard to read so
I'm just going to bump up the font a
bit and so that should be set the next
thing is I'll need a personal access
token so I'm going to go over here and
we've done personal access tokens quite
a bit in this course and we'll go down
to developer settings and we'll make a
new one and this one is going to well I
guess we got to confirm with GitHub
mobile
first get my phone out
here and uh it wants me to enter a code
in one
two okay this one's going to be for
GitHub
packages oh I'm not registering an app
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa let's go back
personal access tokens there we go
there's an old one I'm going to delete
that and I'm going to generate out a new
one we'll
say uh GitHub
packages I want this only to be for a
day just in case I forget it and someone
tries to take
it and this is going to be
for a specific
repo so we'll go down
here and say this
repo and then for permissions I'm
looking for
packages packages it's under here
maybe packages let's search for it
packages it says we need a personal
access
token um
so I'm not seeing packages in here and
this makes me think that we should
probably use a traditional one I don't
normally do this but because I cannot
find it I'm going use a classic
token so that's what I'm going to do um
I'm going to go here I'm going to
generate a new token really wants to
make make a new one and just say GitHub
packages and so it's really similar um
very similar to the other
one well I wanted expire and I'm looking
for
packages here it is read and write
packages delete packages so I'm not sure
where that new one is in the new one
maybe it's not and we just have to use
the classic token we'll go ahead and
generate that token out I now have this
token I'm going to bring it on over to
uh uh here and I want to set this as our
environment variables I'm going to say
GH token and we're going to paste that
in okay we'll we'll copy this good I'll
paste it in and hit enter so now that's
set um I need to set the image
name I'm just going to keep putting the
GH under it image name just so it's a
bit easier for me to find them when I
want to find all the environment
variables later hello world we'll go
ahead and do
that and copy that and paste it in hit
enter uh I'm going to put export in
front of that just in case that didn't
work and then I'm going to do export
my hands are really
cold it's really cold in here uh I think
it's
like7 it's because my shed uh has a um
oil furnace or gas yeah oil furnace and
I have to go drive out to um The the
Reserve to get some gas and it's just
really bad weather so I'm just trying to
get this done so you folks can get this
course as quickly as possible so we've
exported those values so that's really
good I want to make sure that they're
set so I'm going to type in EnV GP GH
and there they are okay so now we need
to write some code the first thing is we
need to log into Docker and so Docker
somehow talks to GitHub I'm not sure how
that works but we'll just go ahead and
work with it here so I'm going to say
Docker login U we're going to say g c
say GHC so that's for GitHub container
repository I'm assuming hyphen U and
then we'll say GH username and then
we'll say password STD in okay so
that'll pass the password that's what
that pipe
does and see if that works we'll hit
enter uh doesn't know what that flag
is did I type it wrong I
did and we'll copy that and we'll paste
that there enter and so now we're logged
in so that's step number one step number
two is we need to tag our Docker
container so we'll say uh Docker tag and
I want my image name and then my
version uh this will be GH version and
this will
be GH I mean we could just write it out
if it's a bit simpler for everybody so
we just say hello world one0 and then on
the other side be
GHC doio and then that would be our
username so I could just type it in here
it's up to you whether you want to use
environment variables or not I'm just uh
I just want it to work so I'm just going
to write it out in full even though we
made environment variables up here for
this particular use case but that's okay
one z z so the idea is we're going to
tag um our Docker image we built is uh
for 1.0 to map to here okay we'll go
ahead and copy that hit
enter um no such image I mean there is
no tag called 1.0.0 on it we do Docker
list or Docker
images it's called latest
so we'll change this to be
latest we can make the other tag latest
as well but I I'm going to make it 1.0.0
I'm not sure why I'm just going to do
that so how it's going to be we'll go
ahead and enter and so now that's tagged
and so now we should be able to push
it GHC doio slash say
Andrew WC Brown for slash hello
world colon
1.0.0
copy
enter um so it says an image with the
tag does not locally exists with that
tag so maybe I tagged it wrong THC R
iio I spelled it wrong yeah and we could
have just copied this one here to get it
all right it enter and there it's
pushing it okay so pretty
straightforward uh we could have even
done this we could said like uh
export um tag
name right and we could have done
this right and then we could just done
that and we could have done that I'm
just cleaning it up doing that uh post
post refactor here and um here we could
have just put these in as such so we
could have done
this
and then this would have been
GH uh image name and then this would
have
been GH
version and so you get the idea there so
that's pretty much it let's go take a
look and see where this actually is I'm
done with this personal access token so
I want to delete it so nobody else is
using it
and um this revokes all personal access
to in class classic just in case I'm
going to do this so I'm going to say
Andrew WC Brown I think they're all
revoked but just in case they not let's
do that anyway and we'll go over here
and we'll take a look at our profile
because it might show up under packages
here I'm not exactly sure how you set
public packages oh there it is it's
private all right
and I'm not sure if it's specific to a
repo link this package to a repository
so I guess if we wanted to link it we
would have had to
apply a label and so I guess labels are
what you think they are they're labels
and that way we could associate it I'm
not going to that here today I think
that's fine but I will copy this just in
case anybody else wants to do
that and
um we'll go ahead and save our
changes
okay and this really doesn't want to
push here today I'm not sure why get
push
what doesn't it
like um oh push protection okay it
detects something
here oh is my token in here wow that's
cool it actually detected it so that
because we turned on security scanning
earlier it would not let me do
that that's awesome I wish we I I
thought I was showing that earlier so
don't show token actually what we have
to do uh is we can even just push the
old one we have to amend uh the last one
we had so if we go over
here uh I'm going to have to go ahead
and amend
this so I'm trying to figure out if
there's a way I can just quickly
amend um I'm going to get rid of this
change here first I'm just going to say
discard this
change and I'm going to type in get
commit hyphen hyphen
amend and so now
uh what I should be able to do is go
into here for all
changes right and I should just change
it actually no that'll just amend the
message sorry that's not going to do
what we
want uh what we actually need to do here
is we out of amend mode I think we are
yeah um I'm going to do get
reset uh
soft head Tilda one and what that will
do is bring the changes back into here
and so now I can go back and fix that
but that's really good that uh I had the
the secret scanner turned
on do not commit your GitHub token but
we did also delete it so it's less of a
problem as
well uh GitHub
packages so just be really really
careful with that stuff
okay and there you
go so I'll see you the next one okay
ciao
[Music]
so for a GitHub repo under the insights
tab you can gain lots of statistical
graphs about the repo and so insights
contains the following tabs we got pulse
this is an overview of recent activity
contributors a list contributors and
their activity stats Community standards
uh commits code frequency dependency
graph Network forks and I want to point
out that on the exam they definitely I
had to know the contents of some of
these which I think is really silly but
that's how they did the exam and so it's
important that you pay close attention
here of what kind of stuff can show up
on these pages so you can identify uh
which uh category of um graphs they're
talking about here or charts or whatever
you want to call them um and I noticed
that repo insights is not listed as
available in the free tier but I think
if it's a public repo it shows up so
maybe they're talking about for private
repos I didn't thoroughly test it but I
just wanted to point that out about um
about that there let's go take a look at
all of these in more detail the first is
pulse this contains poll requests open
close ratio issues open close ratio
summary of activity uh graph of top
contributors list of merge pull requests
list of issues closed list of issues
open list of unresolved conversations
remember this one because this one will
help you narrow down or rule out the
rest because this one is a little bit
more complex than other ones uh then we
have contributors this contains a graph
of all commits over a time period a
graph of a specific contributor commits
over a time period then we have
Community standards this is a checklist
of uh of recommended I spelled that
wrong but recommended Community
standards and how much a community
profile has completed this graph will
only show for repos that have Community
profiles so Community profiles are open
source projects on GitHub and I think
you have to turn it on to turn yours
into uh Community profile file okay we
have repo insights so this contains a
number of commits per week for the last
52 weeks for a year that's how many
weeks there are in a year so that kind
of makes sense the average number of
commits by day uh of the week uh for the
selected week then we have um code
frequency this contains the amount of
additions and deletions of a code uh a
code repo or sorry of code to a to a
report per month I really wrote that
weird but you get the idea that you have
additions and deletion over time and I
noticed that for really large repos they
can't even render it so this is not
really useful for large open source
projects but um you can see it in
smaller projects and that's what I I
said right there down at the bottom uh
we have dependency graph this contains
list of dependencies list of dependence
and Export software bills of materials
also known as
sbmo
SB so security and compliance teams
increasingly request software bills of
materials to identif ify open-source
components of their software projects
they assess their vulnerability to
emerging threats and verify alignment
with license policies so sounds like a
good thing for security folks um then we
have the network graph this thing is
super useful um especially when you're
working on uh like or you're utilizing
an open source project and something
goes wrong I will jump into this and try
to find uh other commits from other
other branches or Forks to to get the
functionality that I need in my
application so this will show The 100
most recent pushed Forks you can read
the commits to determine the difference
of these Forks um then we have Forks
itself so this contains a list of fork
filterable Forks very similar to the
last one but this is just a a list of
forks and the other one is over um over
time and it's visualized but yeah I just
want to point out that you do need to
know these ones uh even though again I
think it's a bit silly but but yeah
you're going to have to know
specifically like what they're doing on
these um on these on these Pages or
graphs
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown and in this
fall along we're just going to take a
look at repo insights so what I want to
do is go to a popular repository like
Ruby on Rails that has a lot of activity
and take a look at what their insights
look like so the first is puls and you
really need to know pulse because again
on exam they might ask you about this
one in particular uh if you notice here
we can change the scope so we can say 1
month 24 days um this one's going to
show us here um open versus closed I
believe so we have open and closed pull
requests and open and closed issues red
being closed I'm going to ass purple is
closed and green is open now we have
some summaries merged pulled requests
open pull requests close Issues new
issues these here are all listed down
below so if you click click on this it's
going to just jump to that location okay
so that's how you know what's all down
here these four things are listed down
below the nice thing here is this
summary so excluding merges 75 authors
have published 240 247 commits and 388
commits etc etc so that's kind of like a
thing you can put in a PowerPoint then
these are your top contributors so the
person that was uh doing all the work
here is
Jonathan Hefner so good job John uh keep
up the great work um let's move on so we
have
contributors these are people that are
contributing code and so it shows kind
of a histograph of or ticker ticker tape
or whatever you want to call it of the
amount of commits that they are
committing so we have a good idea there
and this is for everybody across the top
so in 2014 you can see a lot of stuff
was happening probably a major refactor
was occurring and that's probably why
that's so huge there um probably again
other Peaks where you're seeing very
large things is is they're preparing for
new versions of Ruby on Rails we'll go
over to community
standards checklist cool we'll go to
commits um shows us that there was a lot
of activity this year in December so in
December I mean this we're in January
right now at the time of this video but
in December you can see they did a lot
of work for Christmas and then back here
in February they did a lot of work for
some reason you can see Monday seems to
be the busy day but I'm not sure oh you
clicked find out okay before I didn't
know like if this is over time but I
guess it's like you click it and then it
shows you okay code frequency won't show
us here okay dependency graph uh things
that it's dependent on makes sense
Network this will take a little bit of
time because this has at least 100 forks
we'll give it a moment but I'm telling
you this thing is super powerful and
I've used it since the day it's existed
and it's been around for very long long
time um but when you're working on open
source projects and you're having issues
you can bet your buttons that somebody
else is already fixed it and you can
just go look at their commits and figure
that stuff out so yeah we'll let that
keep loading and while that's loading
we'll open a new tab we'll take a look
at Forks so here's all our
Forks okay we can sort based on stuff uh
and hopefully the exam won't ask you
about what you can filter by they they
do that for issues for some weird reason
but uh come back here and so we can see
this is rails right and so if we go over
here we can see oh this person's doing
something make the this relation model
delegation strictor they have a work in
progress here we go down here add a read
me something in another language update
screenshot and getting started with
rails but sometimes yeah fix style code
sometimes people find like bugs and
before they even get fixed they'll be in
someone else's fork and so you can grab
them and just keep working but uh yeah
that is um insights we can take a look
and see if we get any insights in our
teeny tiny repos we'll go to this one
here and we get
insights and so we already have some
stuff here we can see a few different
Andrew Browns notice here that shows
exam Pro Dev the reason why is that you
can have
um uh you can like if I'm on my computer
my computer which is here uh it can have
a different get email and name set so
even though it is from this account
which it was it can show a different
person was contributing so just be aware
of that but anyway yeah that is repo
insights see you in the next one
[Music]
ciao so in GitHub we are able to create
ourselves issues and it's pretty
straightforward you just need a title
and description and we can also create
it via the GitHub CL Li um there's not
really much else to say about creating
issues um but there you go
[Music]
okay all right let's do a comparison
between issues discussions and poll
requests it's very important to
understand or distinguish these three
things because they seem kind of similar
but uh they're not um so the first is
issues they are for tracking tasks bugs
enhancements and other actionable items
then you have discussions these are
facilitating conversations and q&as
about a wide range of topics related to
uh the project and then you have P
request proposing reviewing and merging
code changes in the codebase so on the
issue side this is often linked to code
changes and can be linked to PRS for
discussions you have categorized by
topics can be converted to an issue but
really it just creates an issue with a
soft link to the issue so it doesn't
really have the same kind of
relationship that an issue would have
with a PR um it's not directly linked to
code changes um so again discussions are
really for as it's implied Community uh
engagement or uh conversation around
your repo um we have for pull requests
directly linked to code changes can be
linked to issues now I should point out
that when you have the numbering for
issues it has like one 2 3 four five
your poll request will I think pull from
the same pool of numbers we'll test that
to make sure that's the case um and so
uh just understand that when you
reference issues or pull requests um
they're pulling from the same number
pool okay there you
[Music]
go so what I want to do in this video is
I want to prove a theory that the issues
and pull requests are pulling from the
same number pool in terms of when
they're incrementing so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go over uh to our
GitHub examples repo um and I want to
create a new issue and make note of the
number that is is used so we're going to
go here and I'm just going to say uh
create a
new um issue okay and we'll create this
and notice that we have the number seven
okay so we have the number seven so the
question is if we were to use a new poll
request create a new poll request what
would we get so I'm going to make a new
pull request and I technically have some
code that I can merge it if you don't
then you'll have to make some but I'm
going to go ahead and create this new
pull request and this will be Andre
Brown into the exam Pro repo go all the
way down the bottom or maybe all the way
to the top sorry and we're going to go
ahead and create that new portal request
and just say more changes okay and let's
make note of the number the number here
is five we go over to issues the last
one that we created in our
um oh sorry the PO C over here is five
Okay so
that didn't make for a very good example
because it went the other
way so what I'll need to do is I want to
delete this pull request this one's kind
of useless we'll close that and what I
actually need is I need some kind of
change in this repo to go the other way
all right because I need to see if that
other number is going to increment we'll
go back to this main repo and remember
we created this issue this issue number
was seven and so I want to see what the
next PR in here is going to be we did
just close this
one but maybe we need a PR for just
something locally not something across
across uh Forks okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go ahead and go to
code and I'm going to go to
branches and I need to just move over to
another Branch we have some junk
branches here I'm just going to go ahead
and delete
them okay and I'll even get rid of this
one here we don't need that I'm G to
give this a
refresh and so now what I want to do is
create a new branch I'm just going to
just say um number test and so this will
be off of Main and then what we can do
is go over to our code and I just need
to make some kind of change so I'll I'll
switch over to number
test and what I want to do here is I
want to just change something so I'm
going to go into our get crash
course go our hello and I'm going to go
edit this
file I We'll add another X
Mark we'll commit those changes and so
now we have a reason to make a pull
request we'll make a new pull request
and this one I just want it to be in the
current repo I don't want to go uh
somewhere else so very straightforward
here here to there and let's make note
of the number that is used so here it's
using the number eight so I want to show
you this
is seven and this is eight so they are
indeed pulling from the same number pool
so so just so you know like you might
expect clean numbers as you're going up
with your issues and you're like what
happened to this number is it unlucky
number did GitHub get rid of it no it's
probably over in your pull request okay
we can also link pull request we'll
probably do this later again but you can
link your issues to your pull requests
um if you go to development here on the
right hand side you can just click here
and Associate this way so I can go here
and then choose a poll request it's not
showing up for some reason do we not
have a requests over here we do it's
right here yeah go back over here
development oh did I click the I clicked
the wrong repo that's why and so I can
choose this one here and we'll apply it
so now this is linked um to that there
and it shows the link there as well you
might able be able to link them up here
as well I'm not exactly sure so what I'm
going to do I just want to unlink that
for a
second okay and I want to see what
happens if we were to um
if we were to go and update this and
then put
in like it says
closes eight right and we do this would
this link it I mean we have eight here
it's showing
there
okay
and Link a poll request that it now is
closed so did it just do that like I'm
not 100% sure did it do that I'm going
to go ahead and just delete this for a
second
edit
update because I can't
tell but that's what I want to know so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
this one more time and delete this issue
okay and I want to see if that takes any
kind of effect so we'll make a new one
we'll just say uh cool
issue it'll say closes pound
8 okay I just want to see if it's linked
in any way so it doesn't look like it's
linking any way there but it could be
that um a particular commit could close
a ticket for sure um but I thought
something with poll requests would
happen here but anyway what I'm going to
do here is I'm just going to edit this
to say my cool issue and what I want to
do is I want to see when we close this
poll
request when we close this poll request
will it close this ticket okay so a link
of poll request now that will close this
ticket so we'll go over here and I'm
going to go here and I want to
merge and Pull and confirm now we could
just close it but I don't think that's
the same thing so I'm going to go over
to our
issue and I think our issue's now been
closed so it was closed when we
closed that pull request another thing
we we should check is is using
keywords there's something called
keywords issues I think could also be in
PRS
GitHub using keywords in issues and
polar request suggesting that it could
be used for either or so to link a poll
request to an issue show the fix
automatically closes when someone merges
the poll request type one of the
following keywords followed by a a
reference issue so close the issue when
someone merges the poll
request okay so that's something we
could try
doing when someone merges the poll
request so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to reopen this
issue
and um by the way just because we have a
pull request doesn't mean we can't you
uh push to It Again by like you can use
a p request and push well we'll talk
about that when we get in the pull
request section I don't want to confuse
anybody here so I'm going to go back
over to uh here I'm going to switch back
to number test and we're going to go
into get crash course and we're going to
go into hello we're going to
edit uh I guess it's already here can we
just edit it right there no edit another
exclamation mark commit the changes
commit it good we're going to go over to
PLL request make a new pull
request and uh keep it real simple we
want to go to the keeping the same repo
and we want this to be number test we'll
create that pull
request and I mean I want this to
close but it says when we merge here it
says to link a request to an issue show
that the fixes in progress or
automatically closes the issue when
someone merges so I'm going to say fixes
I and we're going to put a pound here
this will be cool issue that's our new
one and I want to see if that links it
in any weird way it's not weird but in
some way so I'm going to go back over to
my issues we'll take a look
here and notice it says link a poll
request now that will close this issue
so you know it was saying that it had to
be at the time of merge but did does it
really because it looks like it just has
to be somewhere in the comment here to
link it so links pull request to issue
but not the other way around right so it
has to be in in that uh Direction okay
um so I think that's really important to
note the other thing is that the exam
will probably ask you to remember these
words notice we have close fix resolve
close fix resolve if you can remember
that then you'll be able to pick it out
in a list because they might show like
just closes and then fixed and then
resolves and try to mess with your mind
uh but understand those three there but
hopefully that gives you a little bit
more uh information about issues um very
obvious things you can assign people to
an issue you can apply labels to an
issue if you want you can uh associate
to a project you can associate to a
milestone and we saw that it can be part
of a branch and a pull
request um all pretty clear stuff we can
pin issues I'm sure we'll talk about
that later on but if I pin it it will
then go to the top here if I go back
over to my issues here it is a few other
things things um is the the Sorting
stuff here you really should know how to
filter uh filter with some of these
options here and I'm going to just tell
you on the exam they they said Hey how
do you filter issues like what options
do you have to filter and they gave you
a list and you had to pick from them I
really didn't like that thought it was
kind of a dirty question but that was
something you might have to answer you
might have to know this query language a
little bit so just understand that those
might show up on the exam but definitely
linking is something that we show in the
exam for
sure um and creating a branch okay so
hopefully that gives you a better idea
of issues there all right
[Music]
ciao so something you can do is you can
create um a branch from an issue and or
you can associate an issue to a branch
uh what you can do is you can go ahead
and create a branch on your issue then
it will allow you to uh name the branch
notice that it's going to have the
number of the issue in front of it which
is a common convention when making
feature branches so people know what
issues or ticket it goes back to this is
not just with GitHub this is with any
project tracker that has to do with code
a common workflow is creating feature or
bug uh branches but Define your issues
up front and then you quickly create
those branches and that way you don't
forget to make those branches creates
great habits so you define the feature
bug then you go ahead and you make the
branch there you
go
[Music]
hey this is Angie Brown and this fall
along I want to create a uh Branch from
an issue we've probably done it before
but let's do it again because maybe
we'll learn something different if we do
it slightly different um and it seems to
be a very important topic for the exam
so we do have this issue from before I'm
just going to go ahead and close this as
this one is uh done and I'm going to go
back up here and we'll make a new issue
we'll call this
issue cooler issue issue right cooler
issue and what I want to do is I want
to create a branch so what's interesting
is you can link a branch you can link a
branch or a pull request I think we've
created a branch this way but we've
never uh done it the other way so let's
just go ahead and create a branch and
you can see that's pretty
straightforward I don't think that's
super exciting um notice that the branch
has to be one of the branches you have
here uh so sorry I guess you could
actually associate to an existing Branch
so um repository
destination change Branch Source oh
sorry what you're branching from okay
that's what that's for but yeah we can
create a branch there pretty
straightforward uh but let's do this the
other way we're going to go ahead and
create the branch first and then connect
an issue to it so I'm going to go here
and I'm going to say
new super cool
Branch super cool and we'll go ahead and
do that we'll go ahead and create our
issue this will be
whoops this will be our super cool
issue
right and I'll just put cool in here
that's emojis that's how you use them
and uh what we can
do here is then click here and it says
link Branch or poll request most times
we've been doing this with poll requests
but we'll do this with um uh a branch
now and so look at the icon that tells
you what it is so these are um these
blue
ones I I pretend like I know these blue
ones are our um branches these purple
ones are our pull requests and this
green one here is I have no idea is that
another issue can you link issues to
other
issues can you no that's not that that
is so that's something what is that is
it like an old one no I know we made
that what is it number
test number test what is
that okay we should find well what that
is we'll go here and so now we've
applied a branch the other
direction okay but uh I really want to
know what that number testing is it's
another Branch okay so then why was it
colored differently that's what I want
to know
maybe it was a branch maybe it's a
branch that's been merged in before
that's probably why so that's probably
what they're doing so they're both
branches it's just that branch has
already been merged again so you'd be
using an Old Branch that You' that
you've already done I think that's what
they're trying to indicate there they
don't really like tell you about these
uh icons anywhere if they are in the
documentation they are super hidden but
I want to go back here and take a
look see now this one's blue this one's
blue yeah so these ones I think are ones
that have been
um number test green so green is it's
already been merged in you can see the
icon it shows that it looks like it's
been merged in and it shows that it's a
branch so this is actually a uh a branch
that has been merged okay but uh yeah
hopefully we learned something new or we
got a bit extra practice and I'll see
you in the next one okay
[Music]
ciao so with search and filters you can
quickly sort through a lot of your
issues there's a bunch of predefined
ones that are there or you can use a
syntax language uh called the advanced
search syntax and roll up to find uh
something more advanced the exam at
least for me absolutely asked me both
the syntax and the predefined filters um
and specifically they use the filter
names that were here so
um with those but there's also sorting
right so I'm not showing that here but
they I also got an exam question asking
me about what you could sort by uh but
uh yeah you definitely need to know all
those three things and we'll take a
close closer look on maybe a bigger repo
so that we can get some practice
[Music]
okay hey it's Andrew Brown and this fall
along we're going to look at how to
search and
filter issues so I'm going to make my
way over to rails because they should
have a lot of issues 49 455 that's not a
small amount and let's take a look at
what we can filter by so we have open
issues and pull requests so we can do
that we have your issues so things that
your assigned to we have your pull
requests which I'm confused why oh you
know what it is it's flipping between
the two things so it's suggesting that
these interfaces are the same I didn't
even notice that okay so your pro
request notice we change tabs we go back
to your issues over here we have
everything assigned to you and then
everything you're mentioned in okay so
assigned
mentioned the ones you opened and then
things that are open for po requester
issues it's weird that like they have
this one join but this one's separate I
have no idea why um another thing that
we should make note of is these filters
here because they might say hey are you
able to filter based on Project hey are
you able to filter based on aign or sort
or filter so these are basically um
these are broad filters and then these
are um very specific filters like very
very specific and then we have our sort
over here where we can sort some stuff
but yeah you'll need to know this
stuff uh this and the advanced search
syntax so I I have some written out here
we can play around with it a bit and see
what we can do so let's see what we can
do we can say is
issue and that seems to be a thing so
we'll go ahead and hit enter there so
yes it's an issue um we could say no
assigning okay so nobody's assigned to
it we could put
label active support so we're filtering
based on this one here let's see if that
works cool and I wonder if we could do
like some generic text search um so
maybe we could just say replace on the
end
here and notice that it's picking up I
think that like let's try
caches
caches okay so we're kind of getting
that it might be the contents of it but
it is trying to search for it we could
also say something like there's zero
comments so let's say comments
zero so those ones have zero comments
and so that gives you an idea of how uh
that works um so you know hopefully that
is pretty straightforward but yeah the
filters is the same for pull requests
and
issues um and you know if there's more
to it we could click here and you can
read through all the options uh but for
the most part you can pretty much figure
it out and guess based on what kind of
options you have over here that you
could filter by but you'll see you in
the next one okay ciao
[Music]
so issue templates are markdown
templates that are pre-loaded for new
issues they help ensure users creating
issues provide all relevant and expected
information and if the exam if want to
use the exam language there was a exam
question that says you can coarse
terrible word but cerse people into
writing what you want them to write so
here is an example it's a markdown
template that's all it's really doing is
loading in that markdown template and
the idea is that they you can have
different issue templates so a new
category will appear here of issue and
then people open it up from there some
of these are kind of linked to stuff so
like that report to vulnerability is not
necessarily an issue template um but bug
report and feature request are but
they're like built-in ones I should
point out that on the exam they'll
probably ask you what are the three
default ones and these are the three so
you should remember report bug or bug
report feature request and uh report
security vulnerability because now that
they remembering it they def definitely
asked me that um you create issue
templates here in that folder so you
make a folder called issue templates all
in caps and you put them in there
originally used to just have one called
issue template. MD some older projects
still have that but everything goes in
that folder and we're going to find out
that issue forms also go in there as
well which is the beta replacement for
this feature that I never could get
working um G GitHub has a wizard guy to
easily create issue templates so you
don't really have to write um
uh markdown there but uh it will spit
out markdown but we'll take a look at
what that looks like uh since I haven't
used it in a while but we'll find out
here shortly
[Music]
okay let's take a look at issue forms
this is the evolution of issue templates
and it uses a yaml formatted file to
create issue forms for stricter entry
for issue information as the time of
this video this is a beta feature so it
might go away what's odd is that they
want to include it in the exam so beta
features can can appear in uh GitHub
certifications which I disagree with but
that's what they're doing and so here is
an example of the template I don't think
they'll ask you the format of the
template um like GitHub actions they'll
definitely do but not for issue forms
because it's so new and that's kind of a
visualization of what that would look
like so there you
[Music]
go hey this is angrew brown and this
fall along we're going to take a look at
issue templates and we'll try to do
issue forms I never got working the
first time I tried it but maybe it'll
work this time around let's go take uh
uh a peek and see who would might have
some existing uh issue templates I know
rails does but the thing is rails is
such an old um or mature product that
they've had this template this issues
template file in here forever and they
don't have it in the uh the place where
you expect it to be so it would be in
the dock GitHub folder but it's right
here they don't have a a um a folder of
them so this is actually the old way so
they say you're using an old version of
issue template use the new way of doing
it so that's not recommended anymore
okay but um maybe a better project might
be like
Forum uh if forum's still around and
kick in because I feel like they would
utilize this if we go over to our issues
let's say we want to make a new
issue we have
um this one this one looks like a
template okay so maybe this is a
template that they're using and we have
that format there and we might just
steal this so we can save some time
later on so I'm going to leave this tab
open I just don't feel like making a new
one and if we go over to their code
let's take a look and see what they have
in their GitHub folder and in here they
have issue template and there it is they
also have a config AML so there's a
little bit more going on there than than
I thought um is that is this the new
style that looks like an issue for
I think that's an issue form okay well
maybe we'll grab both of theirs and see
if we can get these both to work but I
didn't see that when we opened an issue
let's go back here and take a look new
issue
um I don't see it so I'm not 100% sure
on
that but if it's a yaml file then that's
what it should
be unless that's something else and I'm
just maybe it's something else I don't
know so anyway let's go ahead and do
that for our own repo so I'm going to go
here into GitHub GitHub
examples and I'm going to actually open
this up in GitHub Dev I can do that by
hitting the period by the way if you hit
comma it doesn't do anything um just
going to try that I don't know I'm just
convinced maybe a comma does something
it doesn't do anything we'll hit period
and that's going to open up
here and I want to go onto the left hand
side and we're going to make a new
folder here we're going to call this dog
ignore or sorry dog ignore
doget
Hub that's a file that's not a folder
let's try that again we'll say new
folder. GitHub and then inside of that
we'll make a new folder called it
issue
template is that what it's supposed to
be called issue template yes yeah and
then I'll make a new one in here and
we'll say
um I'm trying to think of something
secret we'll call this secret MD and I
mean I said I was going to copy this I
guess we don't really need to we just
make our own and I'm just going to put
anything in here so just say welcome to
the
secret uh
submissions submit to Secrets
okay I don't know if that's a
thing I'm just going to put cool here I
think that should render out because
that's uh that's something there and I'm
going to go ahead and add
this commit or add issue
template go ahead and commit and pull
good I want to go back to this repo I'll
open another tab here and if I go open
an
issue do we have
it it didn't show us uh
options must have done something wrong
let's go back
here do GitHub issue
template do GitHub issue
template I made an MD file
yeah I don't
understand it looks right to me
okay so we'll go back over here maybe we
got something wrong that's okay and
we'll rename
this I mean I don't think
so secret.
MD what if we um refresh the page I'm
just going to do a hard refresh here I
just don't trust
it new
issue R up to any issue templates
okay let's go to our settings well hold
on is this repo private or public
because that could
matter this is a
um oh this is a private repo I think you
cannot change the visibility of this
Fork is this public or
private no it's it's
public oh I'm
um
I've added this here this is my Fork
yeah it is here but it's not showing up
here maybe it only works if it's on the
the main one so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to make a pull
request and uh we're going to just
create a new one and uh update and just
say update here going create that one
and maybe that's going to resolve our
issue I don't want to get confused no we
only have one pull request and we'll go
over to this one I think it's because
it's a fork and so maybe it only works
on the the top level one and we'll go
ahead and we'll just merge this P
request and now we'll take a look and
see what happens so we'll go to Issues
new new issue no it's not showing us
anything it's a public
repo it's in the right
folder what else does it want from me
let's go
here
um
yeah what could I be doing wrong that is
a good
question is because this is not a
community
project okay issue templates not
working
this is a legacy workflow to create
issue templates we recommend using the
upgraded issue template Builder okay if
you use a legacy workflow to manually do
that well let's click on
that create an issue template you can
create an issue template as an issue
template subdirectory uh in any of the
supported folders to contain multiple
issues so it can be in multiple
folders
okay do
GitHub I swear I've done this before to
make it issue template visible in the
repository do this commit the
[Music]
changes I'm like going crazy here
because I definitely I made it um and
use the template query parameter to
specify the template that will fill the
issue
body okay do we need maybe a um a like
maybe we need a yaml file let's go back
over to
form I don't think
so do we need some front matter maybe in
the yeah that might be something we need
in the in the file here yeah okay you
know what we're missing we're just
missing some front matter that's what it
is that's what it is okay so I'm going
to go back over
to this one I guess and what we need is
some front matter in here and that's why
it's not working front matter is um is
this it can go into yaml files I think
or maybe not markdown files and this is
like yaml stuff you put the top here so
just just say secret secret uh secret
issue
submits a
secret um and I think the idea here is
you can automatically assign labels so
maybe we have like a secret label we'll
have to make a label for that because we
don't have one uh want to go back
to oh let's use that command I'm going
to do control K there we go I love this
and I'm going to type in um examples
just like a fast way to navigate to
stuff I got remember to do that more um
and we want to make a new label over
here I'm going to call this one
secret I'm on the wrong
repo control
K I'm G to try this again
example I want
mine why is it only showing this one all
right well I guess that feature is not
as great as I thought it was we'll go
over here and I'll go to issues and then
I'll go to labels and I'll add a new one
called
secret
and choose something crazy maybe
that okay so there's our new
secret I don't need any signies we'll
leave that blank we'll save that
update issue
template commit and
push we'll go back over
here and now we go to issues and we say
new issue there we go now what's
interesting is that we weren't getting
those three default ones which I'm
really surprised if we go to edit
templates okay they go there but they
usually have like a
builder I remember them having a builder
before and I don't know where it is now
so that's really
interesting well we can go back to the
other one like this works I'm sure this
works we fill it in there it is what I'm
surprised is we don't have those three
default ones there and I know again on
the exam they showed that and I could
have swore that they would have set you
up with that but maybe it only happens
if this is a community project which
again I'm not even sure how to uh set
that up um I kind of
forget so place to set community project
Community
project yeah I'm not
sure um
insights
Community oh here it is to enable
discussions uh enable discussions to
unlock Community insights okay sure
we'll enable
that I don't really want to enable that
right now but maybe that's what would
bring those issues in later we can go
check I'm just again I just want to see
why I can't see those default ones
and we'll go
here and we'll go back to this
repo uh
GitHub
examples
and well first I just want to open an
issue over
here no templates fine let's go over to
community
again issue templates add what if we
click it here okay so this is where the
Builder is it's weird that um it didn't
show another place okay so here's some a
couple of the default ones so we can go
here and do this and then there's custom
template so maybe these are the three
ones because I said the other one was
like vulnerability one but maybe it's
these three because it was trying to ask
you like what were the default ones that
were there so I think maybe I was wrong
in that slide and it's really custom
template we'll go ahead and we'll just
propose those changes and say continue
and now if we go over to
issues all right that looks fine I
wonder have a little icon there maybe
there's some way to do that now we can
edit the templates over here not really
though I thought we could do a little
bit more there but we now have uh those
in here secrets in here as well but of
course this one doesn't have a front
matter that's why it's not working we're
going to go back and switch over to our
old one
here and
um what I want to do is I want to try to
get that issue form work because I've
never gotten one of those working before
so I'm going to look up issue
form and I want to just give it another
go on GitHub here issue
form I'm just looking for an example one
so here's an example of one I'm going to
grab this whole one here I'll copy it
I'm going to go back over to here and
I'm going to make a new one we'll just
call this one extra MD it's actually
yaml okay we'll paste this in we'll save
it and we'll just say extra bug report
at the top so it can distinguish it from
the other
one and we'll go ahead and Commit
This try and
add an issue
form like I like the idea of issue forms
but uh you know again beta feature so
why why is it in the exam um and we'll
see if we can get this to work this was
committed on this one here so I'm going
to go back over to uh
this
one come on let me I have like a my my
mouse is sticking that's why I'm getting
a double click okay and actually I'm in
the count that I want to be I'm just
trying to get to that repo again so
click over
here and we'll go back into
ours and now we'll go to issues and I
want to see if that other one shows
up it does okay finally and now we
actually have those fields so that's
pretty nice um before I had like the
hardest time getting this to work but
now it's working no problem so I think
that covers it for issue forms and issue
templates and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]
ciao so for GitHub issues you're able to
pin them and you can pin up to three
once you pin them they show up the top
and it makes it really easy uh to find
the most important issues that's pretty
much it
okay
hey this is Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at poll requests often
abbreviated as PR and you'll see that a
lot it's very common uh is a formal
process to put forth changes that can be
manually or automatically reviewed
before it's accepted into your base
Branch your main branch here so here are
pull requests in GitHub and the benefits
of pull requests is collaboration review
or collaborative review so enhances code
quality through team discussions and
peer feedback chck it it tracks changes
says change tracking but tracks changes
provides a record of code changes and
related discussions automated testing
enables integration with tools for
automated checks and tests controlled
integration manages safe and reviewed
merging of code changes open source
friendly simplifies contributions and
collaboration in open source projects I
want to point out the poor request is
not necessarily A git feature but a a
workflow and GitHub has built a bunch of
features around pull requests pull
requests aren't unique to GitHub um it's
just part of the workflow and and
whatever they want to build around it
they can build around it and that has to
do with other tools that do this like
Jura and bit bucket or whatever other
tools like gitlab and stuff
[Music]
okay so we can create pull requests
using the GitHub CLI uh that's one
really cool way of doing it the other
way is using uh the GitHub website so
you go to the pull request Tab and your
repo you create a new pull request and
there it is I'm sure you know by now how
to create a pull request because it's
almost impossible not to show you that a
100 times over before we got to P
requests here but that's how you create
them one thing I want to point out is um
uh that we have to set a base this is
who we're going to merge into and ahead
who uh the changes that we're going to
pull into notice it says compare and
we'll talk about that in the next slide
about base and compare
okay
so base and compare determines the
direction of the merge for a pull
request and the idea is we have the base
so is who you want to merge into this is
usually the main branch or an
environment specific Branch doesn't have
to be main but usually main is base
right um then we have compare this is
what will be merg into base uh compare
is choosing the head reference so notes
before I called it head and if you look
very closely it says choose the head
reference so that's what compare is is
this is usually a bug or feature Branch
another thing that I need to point out
is that you can compare across Forks uh
this is useful if you're trying to
contribute to an open source project so
you're going to have the option to Cho
the base uh repository um and the HUD
repository to different uh repos from
different owners so there you
[Music]
go so a draft pull request on GitHub is
a feature that allows you to open a
requests but Mark it as a work in
progress uh the use cases for draft pull
requests would be indicating work in
progress so communicates the pull
request is not ready for review or
merging preventing premature merging
ensures incomplete work is not
accidentally merged facilitating early
feedback and collaboration so people can
talk about it continuous integration
testing so maybe you want to just run uh
a test code because when you have a pull
request it's automatically going to
start doing that transitioning to a
ready state so easily switch from a
draft to a ready for final review and
merging organizing work in priorities
help in managing and tracking ongoing
work in large projects um draft requests
draft pull request is a feature only for
GitHub organization teams I believe you
can use it in the uh free um free
organizations that are public so we'll
take a look and see if that's even
possible uh if if I don't make a video
then you know that it wasn't um there
are two things you need to remember for
this for the exam uh draft P requests
cannot be merged code owners are not
automatically requested to review draft
pull requests okay so remember those two
things because they will show up on your
exam
[Music]
ciao hey this is Andrew Brown and in
this fall along I want to take a look
and see if we are able to open up a
draft PLL request in our GitHub
organization free account that we
created so what I'm going to do is make
a new repo because we're going to need
to need we're going to need to have one
in our um our one here and actually you
know what I'm going to do no no no I'm
just going to uh I don't want to make it
too complicated I'm just going to make a
new repost so just say uh like fun repo
we'll say fun
repo okay and this can be public we're
going to make it public so just in case
we need to have that so we can have that
functionality because a lot of times
public allows us to have um that paid
functionality for free so what I want to
do is take a look here and create a new
pull request and see if we have the
option we don't have any code so we'll
need to create ourselves a new Branch
I'm going to just do that in here in the
UI and we'll just say uh Dev and we'll
create that branch and then from here
we'll go over and I want to switch over
to Dev and then I want to edit the read
me here and I'm just going to put in
some exclamation marks we're going to
commit that change looks good to me and
then we're going to make our way over to
pull request and we'll make a new pull
request and what I want to know is if I
can make a draft pull request so we'll
say create new pull request and we'll
drop this down and there it is okay so
that's all it takes to create a draft
pull request if there are code owners
assigned they can't touch it noce I
cannot merge it I'm clicking like a
maniac it's not going to happen and that
is draft pull requests so there you
[Music]
go let's talking about linking activity
within a poll request so you can link
issues to a poll request
so that the state of the poll request
will automatically close the issue we
actually already did this before we
looked at issues during we looked at
issues and we're looking at it again so
the idea is that you go up to
development on that Cog and you choose
um the issue or sorry the PLL request
and then they're linked okay so that
will close it the other way is via those
supported keywords so if you have any of
those words you put in the comment of
the actual poll request um then that
will close it it says the poll request
EST must be on the default Branch okay
the poll poll request must be on the
default Branch for it to work I don't
know if that's true I mean it worked for
me when we did it but um however we did
I guess it was on the default Branch but
um uh anyway that's that I don't think
there's any point of us showing this
again because we've done it so many
times but hopefully you know that you
can do that and the direction to which
it happens you're putting it in the uh
body the description of the poll request
um so it links to the issue okay
[Music]
ciao let us take a look here at the
different statuses a poll request can be
surprisingly this isn't an exam question
but it's something you should know so
let's go through them all the first is
open the default status when a pull
request is created it's open for
discussion review draft indicates the P
request is a work in progress and not
ready for review close the P request has
been closed without being merged this
status is used when the proposed changes
are no longer needed or the branch has
been rejected merged the pull request
changes has been merged into the target
Branch the status indicates a successful
conclusion of the pull request process
change is requested this status is used
during the review process when a
reviewer request changes before the poll
request can be merged review required
indicates that the poll request requires
a review before it can be merged this
status is common in repos where reviews
are mandatory part of the work flow
approved the pull request has been
reviewed and approved for merging by the
required number of VI of reviewers
conflict indicates that there are
conflicts between the PLL request branch
and the target branch that needs to be
res resolved before merging ready for
review a poll request initially marked
as draft can be changed to this status
once it's ready for review so that gives
you an idea of the functionality of it
and you kind of figure this out as you
are working with PO requests but there
you
go
[Music]
so commenting in pull requests which is
basically saying reviewing in pull
requests because comments really do link
up to reviewing but the idea is that uh
you can um make a comment and in
particular you can have it so that it is
reviewing changes so when you are
reviewing changes a review change a
review can be a comment it can be an
approval it can be request changes which
has a comment attached to it so
hopefully that is clear um that when
you're doing P requests a comment is a
review in sense okay it's submits
General feedback without explicitly
approval okay um another thing I need to
note is that you can uh Mark comments on
specific lines of code that could
require a review to begin so there could
be one where you're just saying
something about the code or you could
literally be saying hey you have to do
something about this before we'll accept
it
[Music]
okay so the code owners file is a GitHub
specific file that defines individuals
or teams that are responsible for
specific code in a repo and so the idea
is that they have the syntax that's
similar to get ignore and when a polar
request is open that modifies any files
matching a pattern in the code owner's
file get help automatically re request a
review from the specified code owner the
code owner files go in either the root
project root. GitHub folder or doc
directory um and so yeah I think this is
something that is a paid feature it
probably could be in free if we're
talking about um organizations teams or
sorry like free organizations that have
to take a look but yeah it is a very
powerful feature
[Music]
okay so when you're merging a poll
request there are a few options so we
have this drop down where we can either
create a merge this will bring all
commits over into the repo we have
squash emerge which will have one commit
to be added we have rebase emerge which
will be added it and then do a rebase
the third one is a more complex one so
if you're not familiar with rebase
you're probably going to be looking
towards squash which is a good one uh
the use case depends on your team's
workflow they may prefer only a single
commit uh added and so that's why you
would want to have squash or rebase um
but you do have a lot of options there
for how you want to bring code in uh to
your uh your base um your base
[Music]
there required reviewer is a way for you
to explicitly say hey these people have
to review this code otherwise it won't
be accepted um and so you can assign or
allow multiple required reviewers before
code uh gets into a repo and a lot of
times you can say it can't be the same
person uh that submitted the code and
it's not uncommon to have like four or
five people that can be required
reviewers and two or three have to um
look it over before it gets accepted so
here um I would be assigning myself and
saying okay Omen King this this user has
to um review the code and then from
there as that user I would have to
approve the changes and then from there
it would change it to saying okay Omen
king or angre brown approve the changes
and so now you'll be able to press that
merge button okay so there you
[Music]
go hey this is angrew brown in this
video I want to uh do a little bit more
with polar requests terms of code
reviews and maybe we could try to get
that code owners file to work or um you
know just things that we didn't get a
chance to really get Hands-On with as we
have made PLL requests quite a bit but
not from a reviewing kind of code proper
way so what I want to do is I want to
make my way over to our um uh our
pretend organization and we're going to
go ahead and create ourselves a new repo
unless we already have one like the fun
repo does that still exist it does so
what will we'll do is go ahead and use
this one and what I want to
do before we do anything else is I want
to add um or make sure that the
collaborator is added uh to this repo
here and so I'm going to go ahead and
add Omen King
okay and there I am and I'm going to go
ahead and say this person can maintain
this repo all right and now they're part
of this repo so they're there and the
reason I was able to add that very
quickly was because they were already
part of a team so or sorry that they're
already part of our organization so I
didn't have to send an invite and
confirm they're not external from that
so that was very easy um the next thing
I want to do is I want to go through and
uh create a pull
request it looks like we already have
one here so if we already have one I'm
not going to make a new one if you have
to you make a new one but here it says
this poll request oh this is that draft
one right so we can't do anything with
this one right now uh so I'm just going
to close that poll request I'm going to
go over
here a poll request I'm going to try to
make a new poll request because we still
might
have yes we do from earlier and I'm
going to go ahead and create that pull
request okay and so we'll create that
one and I want to say that this has to
be reviewed by Omen King as soon as I do
that notice we cannot proceed
forward until that's uh ready there's
another thing here that says ready for
review so this pull request is still a
work in progress so it's suggesting that
this is a draft I guess I didn't notice
but um it probably was still set to
draft and so I ready for review okay so
now uh Omen King should know that they
need to approve it for this to work okay
another thing that we could do is we
could uh um require other things for
approval so we could go ahead and add a
Rule and Rule sets allow us to do that
so there might be some things in here
that we could set
um require status checks to pass so that
might be something that we might want to
do and right now we don't actually have
any status checks and so that's the
reason why we can't we can't add that
there so if I go
back
okay it would be nice to get some checks
in here because that's the real value of
pull request is having some kind of
automation thing in here but I suppose
we'd have to have like GitHub actions or
something else so maybe we'll leave that
for when we get to GitHub actions and
integrate it there and we'll just
continue on with the reviewers here so
um I'm going to switch to my other
account and I'm in this uh repon and
saying oh I need to add a review so I
can go here and let's say I don't like
this change I'm G to go here and say
request changes I don't like it make it
better and so if I do
this okay now it's saying in red hey you
got to do something I you like it's not
allowed to go through um and by the way
it show it still shows merge pull
request and I really don't want this to
show up unless I've accepted it so maybe
there's a setting that we can do in here
I thought it would been that rule set
that we could do that maybe there's
something else that we can do to protect
it always suggest updating the pull
request branch
no operation options I might not be able
to do it because I'm not the admin so
I'm going to go back and switch over to
this I'll go back to settings and what
I'm looking for is the option to say
that it
requires uh reviewers or otherwise it
cannot be
merged um and so that's what I'm looking
for right now maybe it's under uh
rules could be Branch protection as well
let's take a look here require a pull
request before
merging um
I really thought that there would have
been a rule for
this the reason I think that is because
I'm used to
um I'm used
to uh
using jira and and bit bucket and and
they'll let you do that so maybe I can't
set that I'm not sure restrict
creation yeah so I'm really surprised I
can't find that maybe it's there but I
can't find it and that's totally fine
let's go ahead and
pretend uh you know we're going to go
fix this issue so we go here and it says
I don't like it make it better so how
can we um submit that fix right and the
way we're going to do that is we'll
actually have to go to this branch and
change something so we'll go
here and make sure we're in the correct
branch and in here I'm just going to go
ahead and change it
again okay commit the change commit and
so now if we go back to the poll request
we should be able to up update this poll
request so I'm trying to do that
here FSE
changed normally what happens like and
again it's because I'm thinking of jur
and ATL scene is that you'd open another
pull request and it would be the same
one the same spot so I'm not sure if we
can do
that uh if I go Dev
here because it's the same Branch right
so if I do this it says view pull
request
how do I do
this
um and again it's because I'm expecting
it to act like uh another piece of
software and it's not doing what I think
it's
doing review changes I mean I could
review my own that makes no sense review
in code
space so I guess the way it's going to
work I really thought there'd be a back
and forth there but I guess there's not
is I suppose I would just have to go
here and then approve
it looks great okay so yeah I guess
there's less process there than I
thought and now that I'm happy with it I
can go ahead and merge
it so next question is can we make a
code owner file and see how that
works because I think that would be kind
of unique to
do sorry and so I believe that file is
called code owners and uh what I'm going
to do
so I'm going to go ahead and create
myself a new file here we'll say new
file I'm going to
say code
owners and I'm just going to put an ason
here and just say omen King and so the
idea is that
anytime anything changes it should
assign it to Omen king that's what I'm
thinking anyway so what we'll do is
we'll go ahead and commit to these
changes and we'll do this
again okay and the idea is that if
anything changes from that other person
they they send a poll request I'm hoping
that it's going to Auto assign now this
might not work because it might be only
a paid feature I don't know but we're
going to try anyway so I'm going to go
in the de
branch and before I do anything I'm
actually going to merge it the other way
um I'm going to do that by opening
up uh code spaces on dev and I'm just
going to merge it back in into the
direction because I'm not going to make
a p request that goes in the opposite
direction I'm not going to do that that
doesn't make sense P requests are
supposed to go into your main branch
right so I'm just giving this a moment
here and what I want to do is do get
whoops get merge
main I'll do get pull I'll do get check
out main get
pull just in
case we'll say get check out
main get merge main get push saying it's
all up to date I'm not sure if I I'm
convinced so I'm going to double check
uh it's not showing our tree here so
let's say get
graph I really wish it would persist
changes but hey it's code
spaces
and I'll go back over to here do I have
this
now and show it shows that uh Maine is
ahead of death so it's totally lying to
me they're definitely not in sync I knew
this was not the case oh you know what I
merged when I was in main so that's
probably why uh get check out um Dev get
merge main it's always great to have
this open so we can see I'm going to go
sync those
changes okay just in case that didn't I
can just get push just in case great
that is in good shape I want to stop
this
environment
stop good we're stopping
it okay I'll go ahead and close that Tab
out so now I have confidence that this
code owners is in both I I just had a
feeling I need to do that for some
reason going to go ahead and just change
this and we'll do
that I'm going to go ahead and create a
new pull request and I want to see
whether it auto
assigns we go here Dev create a pull
request and look it auto assigned it so
it says awaiting request a review from
Omen Kang Omen Kang is a code owner Omen
Kang will be requested when this pull
request is created so that means the
code owner file is working I don't need
to create this pull request to know that
and I think that's sufficient um the
only last thing I would say is that you
know people can comment directly on
specific lines just remember that
because they might ask you on the exam
and that's about it we'll see you in the
next one okay
[Music]
ciao hey everyone this is angrew brown
and this fall along I want to show you
uh some of the more advanced options for
poll requests um in terms of the merge
options and why you'd use one over the
other um so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go into our GitHub examples and
in this case we do need to open up uh
some kind of
editor I think we could get away with
using
it on my keyboard and that's going to
open up the editor we're still going to
need the repo open so I'm going to go
here and wait for this to load and go to
repo and so I I'm going to want to go
over here for a moment I'm going to get
rid of this um pull request so we're not
getting mixed
up and um I really want to be
on development and I actually don't even
know if I'm on that so I'm actually
going to just close this stuff out I
might have mucked this up and we'll
close this out because I need to be on
the correct Branch for this to work
work
and I mean we can do this and get up
examples I'm going to do this in our
other repo sorry I know I'm all over the
place but I want to go back to our home
and I want to go to our cool repo so I'm
going to drop down our whoops our option
here and I'm not sure why they don't
never show those on the right hand side
they really should we'll go here and I'm
going to now um open po request and a
new tab here and I'm going to go ahead
and hit period and the reason why
actually you know what we can't use uh
GitHub Dev sorry we're going to have to
open up code spaces because what I need
is that visualization tool so we can see
what we're doing so I'm going to go
ahead and open up GitHub Cod spaces and
we're going to have to wait a little
while for this to start up unless it's
already running that'd be really
nice and I'll be back here in just a
second when it loads okay all right so
now that is ready um we want to make
this a little bit easier to look at so
I'm going to switch my theme as per
usual we'll go to a darker theme there
we go and um the other thing that I want
to do here is I want to switch out to
the dev Branch so say get check out Dev
okay and another thing we're going to
need is a tree so I'm going to go ahead
and go to extensions here we'll say get
graph because we need to make this
really clear what's going on uh so I'm
going to go here and install
this
okay and hopefully that installs nice
and quick is it here not
yet come on get graph
install you can do get
graph we want you there we go we want
you here get graph so the idea is that I
want to put a bunch of commits here and
then we're going to merge them and see
what it looks like when we do that and
then we'll try a different merge option
and we'll see how much cleaner it is uh
doing that another way so what I want to
do is I want to go ahead and modify this
file save it and go get commit hyphen M
change one and we're going to do ma to
grab all of them in one go and then I
want to get push okay and then we're
going to do this again
save and I'm going to just do a
semicolon so I can just get through this
a lot quicker so we'll do that
again we'll do that
again okay you're getting kind of the
idea what's going on here we're kind of
crazy
people are not going to be happy with
all of our
commits okay great so now if we go back
to our G
graph here we got a bunch of changes I
guess we should have incremented them it
just says 1111 uh we can demend those
like there's a way to rename them I
don't really want to deal with that but
let's just assume we didn't name it all
dumb like that we made 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 or
for the next one we'll we'll just name
it two so the idea is that what will
happen the question is what Willen
happen when we merge this in will we end
up with one over here or all of these
over here and that's what we're going to
find out so we'll create a pull request
we'll make a new pull request we will
merge Dev to main we'll create that pull
request I'm going to switch it back to
normal we'll create that pull request
we're going to ignore our reviewers
we're going to just review it
ourself and notice we're on Create and
merge commit so we do this and what do
we get we go back over to get graph and
I'm going to go get fetch because
that'll update the graph without pulling
anything and now notice that all of
these
commits um is up here
now okay so that is there it didn't
squash them all into one we still have
all of the history of them
okay so just to make this clear I'm
going to just go get checkout main get
poll
get check out Dev get pull because I
want to show you that they're all still
there okay oh sorry get merge
main get
poll and
refresh okay and I'll just do a get push
for our Dev sorry but what I want to
show you is that all of this history is
still here it's not gone right it's all
still here so hopefully that is clear I
know it's not the best visual but I'm
hoping that makes sense what I want to
do now is I want to do a
um I want to do a squash okay for the
branch so I'm going to just
make a new
Branch get checkout Dev
2 and actually I'm going to do get
checkout hyphen B Dev 2 and then we'll
do get uh because we want to push this
Branch get push you origin de Dev two
and so now it's being remotely check uh
tracked and I want to do something
really similar to what we were doing
before so I'm going to go here and for
each one I'm going to remove a line okay
we'll save
it I'm looking for that one
liner there we go and this will just be
two this time two and we'll go here save
that this will be two and we'll go ahead
and save this and this will be two and
we'll go ahead and save this and this
will be two and we'll go ahead and save
this and this will be
two all right let's go back to our G
graph we have a bunch of this stuff here
let's go over here and make a new pull
request this
time we're going to Dev
2 and we're going to create that pull
request and we're going to say create
pull request and this time we're going
to say merge pull request squash and
merge squash and merge it's bringing all
those commits in and now if we go back
here and we
refresh
okay um we're going to refresh here
again oh I got to go fetch get fetch
that's why we don't see anything here
get fetch or
refresh and so notice now it doesn't
show like a merge line coming into here
what it's done it's taken all of this
stuff and it's squashed it into a new
commit and has it over here okay so it
really depends on what you want do you
want to keep all this history or do you
want to kind of have this like over here
and this has a completely separated
commit here um it's really up to you how
you want to do it I think this looks a
lot cleaner um but this is totally an
option as well it's really what you want
to do and I will see you uh in the next
one so before I do that I'm just going
to stop my
workspace all right and see you later
ciao
poll request templates are similar to
issue templates they will populate the
poll request text area with the
specified markdown template so there it
is um I need to point out that uh it's
in
GitHub requestor template. MD that's
what you want to use technically there
is a folder called pull request template
that you can use but I found that you
really couldn't leverage it because
there was no UI to select from it and
the only way that you could do that was
via this URL you gener with a query
string so um I would suggest that you
use pull request template MD and not use
the folder uh and that's where it kind
of feels like it's it's like uh where
you have issue templates where they have
that older version of it P requests
still feel like that old kind of version
if that makes sense so there you
[Music]
go GitHub discussions is a community
communication tool for your public or
private GitHub repos and there's a lot
lot of features it has it has threaded
conversations categorization Community
interaction markdown support pin
discussions conversation polls
discussion voting convers uh conversion
to issues
notifications searchable uh searchable
linkable GitHub integration and I'm
certainly sure there is more um you have
to turn this on as a feature in your
repo a discussion tab will appear in
your GitHub repo and you'll have some
default categories to begin with so
there you go
[Music]
so when someone creates a discussion in
GitHub discussions they need to choose a
category and there's a bunch that
already exists for you by default um but
you can create your own and it's a
powerful feature to have so the idea is
that you have these discussion formats
and we have these four so we have open
discussion this is just free form
conversation you have Q&A where you're
basically up voting the best answer
think of stack Overflow you have
announcements only admins can make these
posts anyone can reply you have polls so
you can uh pull people to see you know
things uh categories can be grouped into
sections and it's pretty straightforward
from there
[Music]
okay specifically for the Q&A discussion
format you can mark an answer that is
the recommended answer regardless of the
up boots to help direct which question
you think is the most credible this is
very similar to stack Overflow so the
idea is that as a men or maybe a
maintainer
I can mark it as the answer and then it
will show up as the answer the reason
I'm calling this out because it could be
an exam question so there you
[Music]
go we can pin discussions this is
similar to issues um and the idea is uh
you can just pin a discussion it shows
up at the top of the page and it'll be
nice and colorful you can pin for
particular categories or for the whole
discussions page but it's very
straightforward okay
for a discussion you can actually
convert it into an issue I say convert
with quotations because really what
you're doing is creating a new issue
it's weird they use the language convert
in the documentation but clearly when
you're adding it right there it's
telling you it's just creating an issue
it's just going to pre-populate it with
the same content and then it's going to
have a soft link it's not like Po
request to issues or there's any
relationship there it's just a simple
link um and a convenient way to help you
make uh an issue from a discussion
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and in
this follow along I want to take a look
at discussions so we have our fund repo
in our uh organization account I'm going
to go to settings and let's go ahead and
enable discussions so we'll go and do
that I'm going to go ahead and set it up
based on the default and it has a bunch
of cool stuff I'm going to go ahead and
hit start discussion and so now if we go
over to our discussions we have our
first discussion that we've ever posted
we have some default categories you can
see I can upvote or you know not upvote
and then if I want to provide a marked
answer I can just hit comment
here um oh this one is just uploading it
not necessarily has Q&A so let's go
ahead and try some of the different
discussion formats so I'll say new
discussion and we'll say Q&A I'll say uh
what
is the best movie
ever we'll start a discussion
what is
it and from there I'll just say
Roadhouse okay and so people can uh mark
it up or I can mark it as the a correct
answer and that shows up like that we
could turn this into an issue if we
wanted to so I could well first I could
pin this discussion and put it at the
top so that's another thing so now it'll
be at the top of our page here okay but
the other thing that we can do is create
this into an
issue and now it's an issue there you go
we can go back to our
discussions um a few other things that
we could do we could make a poll so that
might be
interesting choose the best
movie what is the best
movie what is the best movie we'll say
Roadhouse or Roadhouse
2 Roadhouse 2 is not a good
movie we'll go ahead and start that
discussion and now we can vote there we
go yeah um if you want to see a little
bit more with uh like a full discussion
uh GitHub as their own it's
called discussion community and so you
can see it's a lot more active a lot
more fun stuff you can see that I made a
post the other day here
um about certifications that I was
trying to provide provide them feedback
they didn't hear me they ignored me but
this is all about the certification that
you are taking right now as I was trying
to describe what I thought was lacking
and what could be better um and if
you're watching this video and you want
to practice using GitHub discussions can
you do me a favor and can you upvote
this um because I feel like GitHub
should really listen and it's a great
opportunity for you to test the feature
and then we can see how many people have
been using this here so you can come
over here and leave a comment and give
it an up vote um but yeah that's about
it for discussions and I'll see you in
the next one okay
[Music]
ciao so I just want to quickly point out
that you can find your notification
options in your profile under
notifications and you have some options
there about what you are looking at for
subscriptions what you're automatically
watching or not watching go take a look
there again I didn't see the examp am
asking any of the stuff but you should
really take a look here and see all the
options here and we'll probably do that
in one of the U uh the follow alongs
here
[Music]
okay for notifications we have some
filter options and uh we actually have a
filter syntax it looks the same as every
other filter syntax we've been looking
at in GitHub so far there are some
predefined save filters where you can
see that they already have filter
syntaxes underneath and if you want you
can I think you can create your own yeah
you can create your own new filters uh
there is the option to group by
repository or date again I don't
remember the exam ever asking uh this
but it's in the exam guide outline so I
just wanted to quickly point this out
[Music]
okay so something you can do is you can
mention people in um in comments and so
what that will do is that will get their
attention um and by that I mean it'll
show up in your inbox uh for the f
filters you can go to the mention and
quickly find where you have been
mentioned and yeah that's pretty much it
it's just you mention people and it gets
their attention and it'll show up in
your notifications in box
[Music]
okay so the notifications inbox provides
a chronological list of notification
threads this allows you to keep on top
of all subscribe activities with an
Associated GitHub repo and that's
located at/ notifications um and I want
to point out that there is some other
notification views I don't know if these
are Legacy views or alternate views but
I figured I should cover our bases and
look at all of them most of the stuff
that I think the exam is going to focus
on is probably the inbox but I never got
any questions about notifications
whatsoever in my exam attempt but if you
do um you know let's just make sure we
cover our bases here
[Music]
okay hey this is angrew brown and in
this video I want to want to take a look
at the notifications inbox which is in
the top right corner it looks like a
little inbox you can also get there by
probably going to Notifications
somewhere I thought it would be here on
the leand side or right hand side It
Isn't So I guess you really do have to
click that inbox to get there that's
going to be up here at
notifications um this is showing stuff
that we're participating in so you'll
notice that uh we have um what looks to
be poll requests and I guess we can
click into there and get to them right
away so you can see that um you know
somebody's talking to me here and so I'm
getting those uh alerts there and this
has to do with all participating stuff
so there's not a lot to show here um but
we can show mentioning because that's
something that I think would be
interesting to show so what I'm going to
do is go over to my other account and
I'm going to go into a repo that we're
both in so I'm going to go to Andrew WC
Brown um
um and there should be a repo
here no that's that's not it I'm part of
some organization called Cloud
journeyers already forgot what it's
called so I have to get the URL
from this one here and we'll switch over
to cloud
journe and I want the fun repo and I'm
just going to grab that link go back to
the other
account and then from here I'll just go
into an issue and I'm just going to
say um I think so I'll say andrewc brown
I think that would be
Roadhouse okay maybe we can go get an
image roadh house for fun movie
Roadhouse
movie there we go oh yeah that's a good
that's a good one so I'm just going to
drag that off screen here and bring that
in here so we got another reason to use
uploads for file images and I'll comment
that and there we go so now what I'm
going to do is go back to that other
account and I'm going to go into my
inbox and see if I was
mentioned what the heck oh there it is
okay we just had to be a little bit
patient so there it is um we know we
have some other options over here we
have what's this I guess
approve uh don't get any more alerts for
it or save it for later or bookmark it
um
I guess you should know those options
again I didn't see them in the exam in
terms of other stuff I'm going to go to
my other account to kind of show you a
little bit more because it has more
information in it but uh of course we
can filter stuff so I can say is
unread and then we can even click
through and do more stuff like repo
is exam Pro you know and then I can
click there and it should filter for
that we could Group by repository
instead right so that makes a a little
bit more clear pretty straightforward
pretty straightforward um and that's
about it okay
[Music]
C so you can watch a repo in order to
get notified of activities uh your own
repos are you're going to be set as
watching and so you can change the level
of participation that you want if it
feels like we're repeating this we did
because we covered watching prior we
were talking about repos but what we
didn't cover was the fact that there's
this additional watching page where you
can find where everything that you're
watching this does not show up on the
the notifications inbox so this is a
page you're going to want to know in
order to keep track of stuff that you're
watching so there you
[Music]
go let's take a look at notification
subscriptions and this allows you to
follow activities for a specific PLL
request or issue so if you go into an
issue or you go into a PLL request they
have that notifications area where you
can say I'm subscribing and you can see
all your subscriptions on your
notifications page but more or less the
notification inbox is going to take care
of that um but what I want you to
remember is that watching is for repos
it's for people it's for organizations
notification subscriptions are for very
specific poll requests or issues okay so
there you
go
hey this is angre brown and this fall
along I want to take a look at those
other screens the watches and the
subscription so we can uh see that
alternate View and the easiest way to
get there is to go to the Inbox and I
can scroll all the way down to the
ground and we have the options down
below and so if I click into watch
repositories I can see all the repos I'm
watching and I can see all the
subscriptions I belong to and there's
not a whole lot to say here this is kind
of like an alternate view of um
notifications inbox so it's not that
super exciting but it is another
simplified view we can go take a look at
our notification settings and we didn't
really look at this in the lecture slide
so I should cover it a bit more here and
carefully read it so we have the default
notification email so if I want to send
that to another email I can do that
there's custom routing which allows you
to send certain things uh to certain
emails I've never played around with it
before but it sounds cool we can a
automatically watch
repositories uh or teams so I imagine if
we join a team we're match we're
watching it if if we uh create a repo or
own it we're watching it we can choose
between email and GitHub okay um
notification for conversations you're
participating uh in so whether we get a
mention if if we should get alerted uh
apparently we can customize our email
updates so basically what we're going to
get in those
emails then we can get a weekly digest
or not get any emails whatsoever you can
get notified about dependabot alerts um
notified about GitHub actions and then a
deploy key alert so when you're giving
admin permissions and org when a new
deploy key is add it so there is your
settings and that wraps up
[Music]
notifications so gists provide a simple
way to share code Snippets with others
and every gist is a get repo which means
that it can be forked and cloned you can
get this at just. github.com this is a
super useful service I use it all the
time time and uh here's an example of a
public gist gist can be public or secret
public gists are searchable public gists
show up in uh in Discovery or discover I
should say secret gist are not
searchable and do not show up in
Discovery secret gists are not private
they are secret but they're not private
you can share yours with friends and
because that URL could be given to
somebody else they could get access to
it secret gist can be changed to uh be
Public public gist can not be changed to
be private you can pin just to your
profile for other others to easily find
just allow other users to comment just
allow you to navigate revisions with
ease you need to remember these factoids
because the exams will test you on it I
got just questions and one was about
like um about knowing how to fork or
clone uh and also for the uh the private
thing that just secrets are not actually
private to create a gist very
straightforward uh oh sorry I just want
to point out that gists can be also
marked down as well they don't
necessarily have to be code and that's
really nice but to create a gist is very
straightforward you name it you provide
the file name so knows how to do the
syntax highlighting you provide your
code you can attach a few files to it
and create a gist I'm going to remind
you that and maybe I didn't write it in
there but gists are full repos okay so
even though they're like single files
they're full git repost uh and you can
clone them and do a lot of fun stuff
with them
[Music]
okay I was saying that you can fork and
clone gists uh and the way you would do
that is if you drop down the embed
you'll see clone options I don't know
why they kind of hide it on you but
basically you just clone it like a
regular repo um and for uh just repos
other than yours you can just Fork them
so those are two things you need to know
because they'll probably show up in the
exam and I just want to make sure I
really call those out to you here
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and in
this follow along I want to take a look
at gists so gists allow you to create
simp it's a code that you can share with
other folks so I'm going to go ahead and
do just. github.com and I'm just going
to zoom on out here and before we create
anything I just want to show you that
there isn't all gist page so we can see
a bunch of stuff that's already here and
maybe we can go take a test and just
clone something at random so or not
clone but Fork so if we go uh here we
can just Fork this and now we can make
changes uh to this here and so I'm going
to go hit hit edit and I'm going just
make some changes and hit update to this
and what's cool is that you have this
revisions Tab and it actually shows you
what's been changed over time so that's
something that I really like is that if
you're trying to uh teach somebody
something and you need to show that
history over time just make for great
examples um so I really like that again
embed here you can go ahead and clone
htps or SSH let's go over here and make
a new gist I want to make a private one
so I'm going to keep it or sorry not
private but secret so I'm going to go
ahead and say secret
gist okay and we'll try to make this
markdown so just say readme.md
I'll say secret
gist this is
Secret okay and maybe what we'll do is
we'll attach our file here I wonder if
we can just drag it in yes we
can
and me I think it
added
okay oh maybe it's it's in there I'm not
I'm not 100% sure but I dragged it in
and we'll go ahead and create this
secret
gist contents can't be empty that's
totally fine um I'm not exactly
sure okay so you do that
[Music]
um I thought like you
would drag it in maybe it's very
particular in terms of what you can
bring in again the exam's not going to
test you on that but I'm a bit confused
why I can't bring that image in but I'm
going to go ahead and create this gist
and it is secret if I want to share this
with
somebody um I would give them the
sharable link so there it is new tab
there we go right pretty straightforward
uh you can pin these to your profiles I
think we did that already
um so if I go over to our and you can
star just as well right so if you go
here you can star just you go your star
gists right but um if we go back to
github.com I think we already have one
pinned from before so if we go to our
repositories or sorry not repositories
our profile we can see we pinned one
earlier so yeah there you go that's
just
[Music]
a Wiki is a collaborative way to quickly
create documentation and multiple nested
pages and a Wiki would serve as a
knowledge base for your repler or your
organization wikis are not unique to
GitHub but it's just a functionality
that they have uh and so the idea is
that you'd have this uh thing that looks
like markdown could actually be
something else in markdown and you can
search it and navigate through pages um
to turn on Wiki for a repo you have to
check box on Wiki you go to the wiki tab
you create your pages GitHub wikis can
be used for free on public repos which
is how we're going to be able to use
them I said that uh it can be other
types of markdown or sorry markup and
markdown is the default but there's a
bunch here because wikis have existed
for a long time and so they've uh really
had a lot of different kinds of uh
templating languages to link other Pages
you provide the GitHub Wiki Pages the
title as the link um so that's a little
bit different for link
and that's one thing you need to know
for visibility if you create a Wiki in a
public repo the wiki is available to the
public if you create a Wiki in a private
repo only people with access to the repo
can access the wiki so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Angie Brown and this
follow along we're going to take a look
at wikis and so I figured what we can do
is go to our um organization and we'll
go over into our fun repo and we'll turn
that feature on by going to settings and
Wiki apparently is already turned on I
don't remember turning it on but hey
it's on maybe it's on by default and
we'll go ahead and create our first new
page and this is our homepage so it's as
simple as creating it and we want to
create another page this one is going to
be called about and I want to link this
one to our homepage and so it'll be as
simple as putting Square braces
parentheses and we'll say homepage and I
think the other one is called home page
so as long as that is
correct that should work um it doesn't
look like it linked so maybe it's just
called homes I'll try that again and
we'll edit this
page and we'll save it there we go and
that links back there and so we can see
they're both there there's some way to
provide structure underneath I'm not
sure if that just uses headings so I'm
going to go ahead and try this and just
say heading one heading
two
and you know wikis here are not that
great um like I remember wikis all the
way back in 2005 and yeah they it's
providing that structure and you know
they would allow you to basically just
start writing links and when you click
through they create them so definitely
not a New Concept um this one's not that
great but it is here and it is free so
you can decide whether you want to use
it most providers will have some kind of
knowledge based thing and that is
github's kind of offer
but again I don't think a lot of
companies like to use this and I've seen
a lot of organizations start on here and
then abandon it and just take it off of
GitHub but uh it is a thing and they
want us to cover it so there you
[Music]
go GitHub Pages allows you to directly
host a static website via a GitHub repo
you need to create your public repo with
the repo name so uh this would be Omen
king. github.io it has to github.io for
this to work you simply add your HTML
files however you could use jaal which
is a static site generator that allows
you to build more complex static sites
and it it uses yaml files with front
matter and markdown files and it
directly integrates with GitHub Pages
because it is a GitHub project um and
your website will be available at the
domain name with your username at GitHub
do I wrote com it's supposed to
beio so cross that out IO there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown and this
follow along I want to go ahead and
create ourselves a static website so
apparently what we can do is use our
username and do
github.io and that should allow us to
turn this into a static website so what
I'm going to do is go ahead initialize a
read me and we'll make this a repo
public and we'll see if it's as simple
as they say it is I'm going to go ahead
and add a new file here this one is
going to be an index HTML file so we'll
just go ahead and say index
HTML and I need a little bit of code
here so I'm just going to get a template
for an in index HTML
page maybe we get one from free Camp I'm
going to go ahead and grab this one here
I don't need any JavaScript so I'm just
going to take that out there we'll give
that a preview looks fine to me we'll go
ahead and commit those changes commit
those changes and so the question is is
this a static website um I don't know
let's go ahead and copy this maybe we
have to turn it
on nope but we can go try to figure it
out by going over to here and so I'm
carefully looking for that static
website hosting I've done it before it's
just been a
while
and yeah uh it's pages over here Pages
ah here we go so build and deployment so
deploy from a
branch that's the classic experience I'm
totally fine with
that
and I'll choose
main
okay what happened it used to just let
you do static Pages let's go take a look
here uhuh create the do that's what I
did I followed the instructions on this
page and if the repository doesn't match
the name exactly it won't it won't work
okay
Okay
uhhuh add an index page okay sure push
and you're done well I did all
that so I'm going to try this
again oh okay it just needed some time
to propagate but here looks like we can
do a little bit more so if we were to
integrate um jaal and deploy it and like
integrate it we could deploy that Jackal
is pretty cool um it's a little bit out
of scope for this sort of
the other thing that's interesting is
you could add a custom
domain GitHub doesn't seem to really
care about GitHub Pages for the exam so
um you know it's on here but I I didn't
see any questions so this is why it's so
so light that we're covering here but uh
that's it
[Music]
okay let's take a look at GitHub actions
which is a cicd pipeline directly
integrated with GitHub repos and GitHub
actions allows you to automate running
test Suites building uh IM
specifically Docker images compiling
static sites deploying code to servers
and more and we can access this all
through the actions tab in your GitHub
repo uh when you first use GitHub
actions there are some templates that
you can utilize and all these files are
stored in your workflow directory in
your GitHub folder as you can see
there's this kind of yaml file that
we're going to utilize it's going to be
important that we remember some of the
structure so I remember on the exam they
wanted you to know that there was jobs
on and steps uh you can have multiple
workflows in a repo triggered by
different events so when you run GitHub
actions you'll get a history of workflow
runs where it will indicate if it was
successful or a failure how long it took
to run so this is um for something
probably for um some for one of the boot
camps that we ran as we used GitHub
actions to build the site if you want to
find the example repos because there are
those little getting started but it's
the same repo here at the starter
workflows and you can get the yaml files
and get started really quickly there are
different types of triggers uh that you
can use with GitHub actions that's going
to go on that on area and GitHub there's
about 35 GitHub actions I say plus
because in case there are more that I'm
not aware of I'm covering my bases there
examples of common GitHub actions could
be pushes pull requests issues releases
schedule events and manual triggers the
exam wants you to know that you can
trigger based on these things so make
sure you remember this short little list
here
[Music]
okay hey this is angrew brown and this
follow let's take a look at GitHub
actions so what I want to do is go over
to our organization I'm going to go to
our fund repo and here we have a tab
called actions where we can set up some
GitHub actions now I don't use GitHub
actions a whole lot maybe I will if I go
ahead and do that GitHub action cert uh
certification course but uh we'll just
have to kind of work our way through it
it shouldn't be too hard so there's a
lot of different things that we can
utilize here I can set up terraform
which is kind of cool uh we have
deployment to AWS to Azure to Alibaba
Cloud we have some security things that
we can do here we have continuous
integration automation a whole host of
stuff and um you can even do static
compilation which is pretty cool as well
so we're going to have to make make a
decision in terms of something that we
want to use um um I don't think it's
going to be deployment because that
seems like a lot of work um so I'm
trying to make a decision
here what we could
utilize build lint and test a rails
application that seems pretty small or
easy for me to do but maybe we should
try to use one of these things down
below um labels pull requests based on
files change let's go ahead and see if
we can utilize that so I hit the
configure button and it's going to bring
us into this action and I guess there's
the marketplace where we can get uh more
stuff I didn't even realize there was a
Marketplace for this looks like we got
some documentation here so customizing
when workflow is run based on trigger so
here it says on push Branch so when we
push to specific ones we can trigger
different
stuff okay so that's kind of cool let's
take a look here and see if we can
expand this and see what we're looking
at so we have name labeler on pull
request Target jobs and then we have
labels so run as Ubuntu so probably
start a container as an Ubuntu with
permissions of contents to read and it
can write pull requests and the step
that we're going to have here it's going
to use the actions labeler version 4 and
with the repo token it's going to bring
in that token so it has authorization to
do so and we know about GitHub tokens um
and I think I think we showed this uh
for GitHub actions but not 100% sure so
care reading here the whole point of
this is to apply labelers and the
basically the way it's going to do that
is through these steps and so I'm
assuming that this is kind of like a
built-in step and if we go here and just
type it in maybe we'll go find
it yeah and so they're talking about
actions
here hold on
here I guess it's just a repo so I'm get
documentation
and oh okay it's called actions all
right and so this whole repo
contains
actions all right and so it's coming
from this one and so I'm just going to
go into here and take a look at what
this looks like so just zoom out for a
second and it kind of explains maybe how
it
works um automatically labels new pull
requests based on the paths of the files
being changed on the branch the ability
to apply labels based on names of
branches and things like that the bug
related to the issue so create a GitHub
la. yaml file this will list a uh a list
of labels and config options to match
and apply the label all right the match
object allows control over the matching
options you can specify the label to be
applied based on the files that have
been changed and Etc like
that and sounds a little bit
complicated but at least down here it's
like showing us uh the flow it's
interesting that this one is showing
version four when clearly there is a
version five um there might have been
warning up here saying that we should
use it doesn't say that we have to use
version five or
four or we're first to use
five um but let's see if we can figure
this out so I'm going to go ahead and go
down below and just look at the workflow
a little bit more here and it looks
pretty much the same the only difference
is that this one's using version five
it's not passing the width for the repo
token so I'm not 100% sure if we
actually really need to do that but I'm
going to go ahead and go commit changes
and we'll commit that there okay so now
we have that here if we go to
actions um we can see that we have
labeler and it's only going to run
what's going to trigger it let's go take
a look
here um if we want to know how it
triggers we should just take a look at
the code and
whoops go back here and and take a quick
look so it says pull pull request
Target so we pull request Target what
does that
mean we'll go search it
here um pull request Target so activity
types assigned assigned
labeled runs your workflow when activity
on a poll request in the workflows
repository
occurs when activity on a pull request
in the workflow activity Cur so it's
going to check on based on a lot of
stuff so that's pretty broad but that
seems fine looks like we could even
narrow it down to very specific types
okay so I mean that's is how we could
play with
triggers um and so basically when that
triggers it's going to go ahead and then
start up Ubuntu for some reason maybe
that's what it has to use to run this
code that we saw from over
here okay and this looks like it's
JavaScript or something
and then we need that labelers
file so we need to make sense of what
this is so the base match object is
defined as this any glob to any
file okay the key okay so what does this
thing do automatically label new pull
request based
on the path of the files being changed
on uh changed or the branch
name okay well I'd rather just
do that on the branch name so let's see
if we can find that so it
says change
files give me a moment just to try to
make sense of this and then I'll just
save you the trouble of me struggling
through it okay okay scrolling on down
we're getting better examples this is
starting to make more sense it says add
an any change label to any changes
within the entire
repository Okay add documentation label
to any changes within the docs folder so
maybe what we can do is give this one a
go and uh we need to create a file
what's this file need to be called.
GitHub labeler yaml so we'll go here and
I'm going to add a new
file
okay um add a
file this will be
label l. yaml double check make sure
that is
correct I've been known to make mistakes
often and I'm going to paste that on in
here and we're going to commit that
change so now we have our labeler yaml
I'm going to go take a look here and see
if the action got triggered it did um it
failed I mean there's nothing for it to
check right now so no event triggers
defined is
on so not exactly sure what it's saying
there but that's totally fine for now
and what I need to do is I need to
create a poll request I mean it
shouldn't trigger unless we have a poll
request right
um but it did just happen now so I'm
curious what would happen if I went
ahead and just uh made any kind of
change because it shouldn't really
trigger unless it's a pull request we'll
go here and go back to actions and it
ran again so I'm really confused why is
this running what it should only happen
on a pull request
Target um we'll open it up again here
so no event trigger defined is
on okay maybe there's something wrong
with our our workflow
file let's see what they say you can
trigger all branches just by
using remove the hyphen your workflow
file seems fine have you checked all
indentation so I mean we didn't make
that file right it was generated for us
let's go take a look and see what we can
do about
that we have label and labeler
okay so this was the one that we
wrote I mean everything looks fine here
I'm G to open this up in codes spaces or
not codes spaces we'll open this up in
bring this down on this line like this
and do
that
um I don't know if we need this so I'm
just going to take that out because the
other one didn't have
it okay can expand this yeah it still
has this
here
and I'm not sure why this little red
line is here maybe it's just superficial
it's confused but this seems fine I'm
going to go ahead and update this and
say update action
the other question is do I have this in
the right
folder
because yeah it's an actions but labeler
yaml labeler yaml isn't supposed to be
in the actions folder so I think what's
happening here is that it thinks I think
I know what happened here um if we go
back to our
repo I think it thinks labeler is a an
action yeah so I think it's just we put
that in the wrong folder so I'm going to
go back and open up
github.com it and we will let that
push and I'm going to go back over to
here all right and if we go back over to
actions
oh uh this is not the repo we'll go back
over to our organization into Fun repo
it might have triggered one more time I
don't
know it has not so we are in good shape
can we delete this run yep we can let's
just delete this up to clean up so we
can see what we're
doing and uh what I want to
do is I want to trigger that uh pull
request to get automatically labeled so
we're going to need a label called
documentation for this to work so we're
going to go here to labels and we'll
make a new label there actually already
is one called documentation I don't know
this is case sensitive so I'm just going
to change it to Capital D so it just
works for us and we're going to go over
here to code and I need a new Branch so
I'm going to go to
Dev and in here I'm going to create
myself
a um a docs directory so I'm going to
make a new folder
here
and what I'll do is I'll make
a new
folder we'll call this
docs and I'll say readme.md
read me okay we'll save that we'll go
ahead and Commit
This and we're in a branch right yeah
we're in a branch
so commit we're like new docs Direct
and I know I spelled that wrong it's
okay nobody's watching here today
there's no grading going on if I ever
grade you I'll poke you for that but
right now it doesn't matter and I think
that we made that in the dev Branch so
we'll go over here and I want to go
ahead and create a new poll request so
want to make sure that folder is there
PLL requests new pull request we'll drop
down Dev we'll compare that over we'll
say create pull
request and the idea is that when we
create this it should label it if this
worked as
expected um and so what I want to do is
go over to actions and see if it
triggered and it's running so it's
queued it's going to think what to do it
has to spin up compute so this is an
instantaneous in progress good we're
watching
it label complete success we'll go to
our pull request there we go look at
that um and now we have a p a check that
passed and we overgo to our checks and
it shows that it passes so you know
before we talked about like Branch rules
we could maybe just tell it that it has
to pass that before it could proceed not
a really good example for this but we
could try it and it's just an
opportunity to show off this Branch
protection rule stuff so I'm just
looking here carefully for where that
was uh it was like checks
okay and I'm going to drop that
down
and still doesn't show up here so maybe
that doesn't work as expected but I was
hoping that maybe I could just choose
that from
there um because it's not like an
upfront check it's like something that
happens after you do that but anyway
that's get up actions in a nutshell um
it is very important that we understand
how those files work so before I go I
just want to uh pull up a link because
there was something that really explain
explained the structure of these files
really well it was understanding GitHub
actions okay so it's this here learn
GitHub actions understanding GitHub
actions I think it was this one yeah and
so this one really helps explain this
workflow file so let's go through it
really quickly and make sure we
understand it
so um first thing is the name so we're
going to name it that's optional we have
run name so the workflow uh runs the
generated from the workflow I guess it's
going to be like the Run name we have on
so specify the trigger of this workflow
so on triggers events jobs groups
together all the jobs that
run then we have steps groups together
all the steps that run uh in the check
bats version notice we didn't have these
before runs on configures the run on the
latest version of Ubuntu Linux Runner I
imagine you could change this to other
things uses uses keyword specifies the
step that will run uh
here and of course we found out those
are remote repos so that makes sense um
and that's pretty much it so so steps
jobs on remember those three on jobs and
steps
okay and that's pretty much it so I'll
see you in the next one okay
[Music]
ciao GitHub co-pilot is an AI developer
tool that can be used with multiple
idees via an extension so here is an
example of it autocom completing code
for a terminal base uh blackjack game
which I asked it to do it can do code
completion you can have uh chat
conversations in your ID or mobile while
you're working on code it is a CLI
assistance it does code referencing
public code filter and IP Indemnity I
don't know what the last one is but it
does it and you can get a free trial
with um uh for a one day 30-day trial do
you need a credit card I'm not 100% sure
but we're going to find out here shortly
as we will go and to set it up it is
free to use for verified students
teachers and maintainers of popular open
source
[Music]
projects all right so let's compare the
two versions of uh GitHub co-pilot we
have the individuals and the business
version of co-pilot and the reason I'm
doing this is because I'm pretty sure I
got an exam question about a specific
comparison so pay close attention so for
pricing co-pilot for individuals is $10
a month or1 for the year for co-pilot
business it's 19 uh USD dollars per user
per month the types of GitHub accounts
would be personal accounts for
individuals and then or and Enterprise
accounts for co-pilot business for
Telemetry you get it for um individuals
which I believe that was the exam
question that I got asked for business
you do not get it um for Block
suggestions matching public code they
both get it uh they get both plug uh
plug rights into your editor so
extensions for both Ides or for both of
them for multi-line function suggestions
they both get them for organization wide
policy management co-pilot business gets
that uh excluding specific files
co-pilot business gets that for audit
logs co-pilot business gets that and
then for HTTP proxy support via custom
certificates co-pilot business gets that
so make sure you know which you can get
and which one cannot get those feature
sets
okay
[Music]
let's take a quick look on how we would
set up co-pilot and some of its
functionality so the first thing we will
need to do is install the GitHub copile
extension in vs code there are
extensions for other different browsers
but this is the one that we're going to
focus on once you install it you want to
trust the workspace and install um sign
into GitHub for GitHub co-pilot you're
going to authorize GitHub in order to
allow access and then you'll have this
little co-pilot icon in the bottom right
corner when you want to start using it
the first thing I would do is go look at
the keyboard shortcuts they do list
keyboard shortcuts on their website but
I found that um uh the ones that were
set for me were completely different I
have no idea why so whether you're on
Mac or Windows make sure that you know
what your settings are at the time I was
doing this I was doing this on my Mac
and so it's showing Mac like key
bindings here uh it's and again it's
just a reminder best to check the hot
keys because it can be changed to
anything and they didn't seem to match
for me um once you have copilot
installed you can also enable co-pilot
chat feature and this allows you to chat
in the le- hand side I found this to be
extremely useful and I would recommend
turning it on if you can but uh yeah
there you
go so in this fall along we're going to
take a look at installing or setting up
and using um GitHub copilot um I have a
business version in my uh primary
account and this one I'm going to try to
set up IND ual um so hopefully that will
go smoothly here um so the first thing
we want to do is start using co-pilot
and maybe a good idea would be to try to
use it in um code spaces because I feel
like that's going to be a lot easier and
there' be direct integration before we
do that I just want to show you
something kind of funny about uh GitHub
and their branding so they have really
decided to call themselves an AI powered
developer platform which to me is a
little bit silly because they're only AI
solution is co-pilot is there any other
ey stuff not that I'm aware of um but
it's a really weird rebranding because
they are still a g hosting repository
but hey they can do what they want to do
but I'm just not going to buy it but
anyway let's go ahead and open up code
spaces and we do have some other ones
down here below just going to delete
them and we'll just start from scratch
here um just delete and
delete so we don't have to worry about
these other ones here and what I'm going
to do is go over to uh that repo one
more time uh over here and we'll go
ahead and create ourselves a new code
space so we'll just give it a moment to
spin up and we'll configure it as per
usual all right so our environment or
our code space is now running what I'm
going to do is go ahead and change the
color theme to dark or something that is
easier on my eyes and what I'm looking
for here is copilot now is it already
pre-installed I have no idea we'll go
ahead and take a look so we'll type in
GitHub co-pilot and see if we can find
it here and there it is so there's a
couple things I'm going to want I'm
going to want GitHub co-pilot and then
we have GitHub co-pilot chat it looks
like it grabbed both of them when I did
that so I didn't have to do anything
extra um so that is going to go ahead
and install there and then down below it
says extension failed no access to
GitHub co-pilot you're currently logged
in as Andrew Brown that's true and it
says no access sign up so let's go sign
up for GitHub co-pilot and here we have
a few options we have the monthly $10
plan or the $100 plan where's my trial
so it says pay frequency after trial so
you have to pay for it
um confirm your payment details and it
looks like we'd actually have to fill in
payment information so I'm going to save
you money here today so that you don't
have to spend anything and I'm just
going to show you in my other account
what it looks like to use uh GitHub cop
pilot so you can pass the exam whether
you want to fill the stuff in is up to
you um I'm not going to do that I'm
already paying for it so I'm not going
to pay for it twice and uh you know
again my expectation is you don't
shouldn't have to pay pay for that
either so what I'm going to do is go up
to my C command pallet and just go into
stop and I want to stop the current code
space and I mean we figured that out
that that's where we're going to hit
that boundary I'm going to switch over
to Omen
King and I'm in the same repo and I
think I'm part of this so I can open
this up in code spaces and we'll go
ahead and do the same process and I'll
be back here in just a moment when this
environment is ready to go all right so
our environment is up and as per usual
let's change our theme to something that
is a little bit easier on the eyes so
there we go and we'll proceed and do the
same thing as we were doing before so
I'm going to type in
co-pilot and that's going to give us
co-pilot right here I want the chat to
be installed as well but it seems like
it knows to pick that up there's also uh
copilot co-pilot voice I've never used
it it looks like it's in preview so
that's kind of interesting but uh not
something here for today that we'll be
playing around with um and I'm waiting
for this to finish its install and it
should you know come up and pop up here
if it doesn't I can click down here
below and it looks like it's ready to go
so I'm not having to do any additional
configurations again this other account
already has co-pilot activated but while
I'm here what I want to do is show you
in my settings
the co-pilot options so if I go down
here below you'll notice here that we
have um this feature enabled so because
it is a business organization I had to
go into that one and turn it on but if
it's enabled and I did enable it then I
I think that's the reason why I picked
it up because the first time I did this
it didn't install that chat and then I
had to go into the settings and say turn
and enable chat and then now it seems to
automatically install so um I think the
chat's right over here so that's really
good
and then down below is we can click this
to bring it open let's go take a look at
what our keyboard shortcuts are because
that's going to really tell us how to
use this and so we have control forward
slash so accept panel
suggestion alt uh Square brace next or
previous open completion panels contrl X
suggest terminal
commands uh inline trigger so we'll try
our best to try to figure this stuff out
there's clearly a lot more stuff going
on here like explain this
and other things like that so I mean
explain this might be a really useful
one to have or generate docs that seems
pretty cool but what we'll do is go
ahead and make ourselves a new file and
pretend that we are programmers I a
programmer but you know we're all
pretending we're
uh that's fine anyway I don't know where
I'm going with that let's go ahead and
make a game so I'm going to go ahead and
type in game RB and here it says press
to ask GitHub co-pilot to do something
so let's go ahead and click that and ask
it to generate some code I'll say um
create a game Loop
for a
terminal uh tick tac toe game okay so
I'll hit
enter and there's a lot of different
ways you can interact with it this is
like one way you can do it in the chat
copy and paste and do other things but
it's starting to get this stuff set up
uh and the thing is that this is
actually pulling from real repos so it's
not like magic it's actually going out
and leveraging a lot of public repos
which I'm not really happy about but um
it does get the job done and so we
already have a game generated out here
does it start the game for us it looks
like it does and so let's go ahead and
see if we can play it so I'm going to go
ahead and type in Ruby and type in game.
RB and hit enter and boom we got a game
so enter your move row and column so I'm
going to say it doesn't tell me like
whatever I'm going to say one and one so
I guess that's
Center and is this the second player now
so zero and
zero
and then we have one and uh so one and
one what happens there invalid move okay
so zero and
one and then I'm just trying to
purposely lose here so two and
two and then zero and three zero and two
so there's a few things about this game
that's not really good it doesn't tell
us the grid numbers it doesn't have an
AI to play against a simple AI um it
doesn't tell us um few things there so
maybe we can make some improvements uh
we can go to the chat and and I think
the chat is like aware of our code so it
should be able to make some
modifications but I really like the fact
that we had that little box in
place um
so looking through
this I want to look where the board is
being rendered I know Ruby really well
so this is really easy for me to read
and I'm looking for
puts where does it render the board
where are you rendering up here display
the board and so method to display the
board
[Music]
game the
board should
show the
coordinates on the uh
uh of each cell sure why
not and I'm not sure how we would tell
it to do that if I select
that say
modify this code to code to
show the
coordinates for each
cell all right and see what we can
do all right and so we'll copy this
function we'll paste it on back in
here say allow and we'll try this again
we'll see what we
get and it's not exactly what I want uh
no so say no I want the
coordinates on the outside of the
board that's board border I me say
board there we go that looks like a
little bit more of what I want so we'll
go ahead and try
that okay we'll stop this and so now
that makes a lot more sense okay so now
I can go 0 0 and I'm I'm less uh
confused about which one it is um so
that's really good the next thing is I
don't want to be playing against myself
I want to have some
AI um you know how can
I uh can you write a simple Tick Tac to
AI for my game
code and it's going to do that so it's
making a separate function which
actually is a good
idea and so that's actually what I
wanted I wanted an inputed an output
this code assumes that you have a game
over
function um do we have that yeah we do
let's go ahead and see if that
works but where do we use this
function this this code assumes that you
have a game over method that checks if a
player has won the game the AI move
method first checks if the AI can win
the next move if it can it makes the
move if it can't it checks the player if
there's no winning um so the question is
where you know where do I call this
function in my code I'm checking to see
if it understands the context of it it's
loading in game. RB so clearly he's
using that file to figure it
out so it's saying here you should call
the AI move function in your game
Loop um so here it's updated our game
Loop
um the loop starts up there's a loop
here and then this here is all I move so
this is our main game Loop I'm just
going to bring this on down here so it's
less
confusing okay
and it looks like it's Rewritten it so
we have update
board I don't have display board in
here
this code will make the AI play its turn
whenever the AI is turned the AI move
function will decide the best move and
update the board where is the display
board in this
Loop is this Loop
incomplete could we also put the loop I
was complete incomplete because it
doesn't look complete to
me
all right so now it's actually completed
it kind of lied but that's fine and so
we'll go ahead and just copy this I mean
I knew what to do there but that's fine
and look it took out the uh while loop
so it clearly changed its
code let's go ahead and see if that
works now um so I'm going to go ahead
and do
that and another thing that I would like
to know is could it indicate
can you indicate who's turn well we'll
just play the game and see what happens
first so I'm going to say 0
0 it says wrong number of arguments for
game over let's go take a look at that I
think it was suggesting that game over
might be a little bit different so this
says board and player and so I'm going
to put player in here for a
second and I don't see player getting
called here um what
about the new game over
function yeah so it's going to try to
update
that you passed
player and there's ways of doing uh like
co- completion in line I just kind of
forget but this is the way I kind of use
it so every tools a little bit different
I'm sure if I did a uh course on how to
use these tools i' would be a lot more
thorough about it but I think this is
sufficient enough let's see if it takes
that okay and we'll say Z 0 wrong number
of arguments so you can see like how
this can be a little bit finicky to get
something working um you really do need
to know what you're looking at it is
definitely a very powerful
tool um but as you can see you got to
keep working through it uh here maybe
we'll just do current player I think
it's because we still still have one
more check
here okay 0 0 there we go now it's
moving um we'll say one
one okay blocked me
02 there we go we'll say one Zer and
then one two or 21 sorry
21 and it messes up here at the end I'm
not sure why but for the most part it
almost worked this is line 121 so I can
go to line
121 and it has an issue updating the
board for some
[Music]
reason so and it's on 114 so I could
jump to line 114
here and yeah so maybe it just doesn't
really have a way of ending the game
gracefully but hey it did code it so
that's pretty
impressive we didn't really use those
hotkeys but again it depends if you're
going to be chat driven or if you're
going to use the console here we could
take a look at some of those hot keys
and just quickly try to use
them okay so we'll go back into
whoops into
our edit
settings
and
whoops hot Keys here there we go control
for slash accept a panel suggestion
suggest terminal
command trigger inline suggestion alt
back
slash so we'll do alt backlash and see
what it
does
nope it clearly is trying to do
something down below I think it did
something yeah so I think maybe it's
like
um code and see it is also trying to
autocomplete things but
function for
scoreboard go here and it's thinking
down below so if it didn't do that we
could have probably hit the hot key but
it's apparently doing it I'm going to
hit tab to grab that so you can see it
kind of helps as you're coding but you
learn how to use it as you use it we're
not building something big here and I
think this is sufficient so we'll call
this one done I'm going to go ahead and
stop this workspace so open up the
command pallet
stop and I will see you in the next one
okay
ciao
hey this is Angie Brown and we are
taking a look at GitHub codespaces this
is a cloud developer environment or also
known as a CDE Integrated with your
GitHub repo and the idea is that you
have this thing called a codespace
that's what they call their developer
environment and a codespace runs Ubuntu
Linux socer container on a virtual
machine hosted and managed by GitHub so
this is kind of a representation of how
it works um I don't write it here but
the idea is that when you launch up
GitHub codes spaces it's actually
cloning your GitHub um repository so you
can start working with it right away uh
and most Cloud developer environments do
that so that's a pretty common pattern
and it's going to clone that repo into a
workspaces folder so you can interact
with codespaces via multiple ways we
have the SSH via SSH via the GitHub CLI
you have code editors such as vs code
browser the desk to Jet brains IDE um
for the desktop you can just open that
up in the browser mode by going to open
and vs code desktop and it does give you
a bit more flexibility than the browser
because there could be extensions that
only work uh locally and you know it's
just you get a better experience there
but I usually use everything in the
browser because I don't like to do local
development anymore I'm totally moved
over to the cloud but uh for the get
upsi commands we do have a lot there so
that's a great way to programmatically
work with your GitHub codes spaces uh
when you create a new codes space you'll
have to choose the repo the branch the
region the machine type and that shows
that all there that gives you a good
idea of how you can configure uh your
code space uh the regions you can choose
from Is Us East US West Europe West uh
southeast Asia and the australas and you
know what I think when I first launched
I don't know if it always shows me this
options but if you need to choose these
options you can make sure you get that
stuff uh there is a capacity of your
environment based on the virtual machine
type so the more uh the larger it is the
more expensive it is and they they go
based on cores so you can see the larger
the cores the more RAM and the more
storage you're going to get that second
value being the storage you can see all
your code spaces across all your repos
at github.com codespaces and the way
you're going to start a codespace is if
you drop down that code under the codes
spaces tab you can go ahead and create
it on a particular Branch that's usually
what you want to do is say I want to
launch this on Main Branch or Dev Branch
you can obviously use the GitHub CLI to
open up code spaces there is a limit of
concurrent code spaces allowed to run if
you hit that limit you may need to stop
other code spaces first I don't know if
this is the case but there might also be
a hotkey within GitHub repo but we if
I'll have to go double check that uh
before we talk about it
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and this
fall along I want to take a look at some
of the configuration options when we
launch up our code spaces so I'm going
to switch back to my um other account
here and we'll go into the fun repo and
what I want to do is open up this code
Tab and normally what we would do is
we'd launch a code space here but I
really want to choose the options that I
use to configure it with and so you can
see we have some other things here we'll
go config with options and this is where
we're going to get the choice of
choosing our Branch choosing our region
choosing our machine type and so that is
the way that we can do it notice that
we're limited to two and four cores this
is probably because we don't have a
credit card attached and so it is very
limited I'm curious to see what it is in
my other account which could have some
paid capabilities so I'm just going to
quickly switch over to that and take a
look there so let's say we went into the
exam Pro repo because definitely we're
paying on exam Pro for sure and let's
just say I'm doing terraform beginner
I'm going to go here and go to Cod
spaces and say with options and see if
we get more options and yeah look we do
get more options so that definitely is a
factor for the things that you're going
to be able to see so that is pretty
clear let's go back over uh to here and
I want to again go back to this
repo and and I mean we definitely do
want to open one for code spaces but
we're going to go ahead and delete this
one I really just want to get to the
repo itself and let's go take a look uh
yeah here again and I mean I never
looked at this before so I'm really
curious uh what's under here for
configure Dev container oh it just opens
it up in Json so nothing super
interesting but it's nice to see they
have some documentation here as you're
working on that file to help you
configure it I could have probably used
that later on so um I guess we'll take a
look at that but really it's simple
we'll just go ahead and say with options
and we'll be very explicit about how we
launch it main now pretty
straightforward we'll go ahead and
launch a code space and so all I really
want to do is just show you the command
pallet in here for code spaces as we've
already used codes spaces a lot in this
course but um you know just go here and
show you some of the command poet
options so if we go to the command
pallet which was down below here we type
in code spaces this is where we're going
to get a lot of the actions actually I'm
surprised I didn't make a slide on this
but um you can see that we have a few
different things so uh we can change our
Mach machine type here we can manage our
secrets from here we can rebuild our
container if we change our Dev container
file um you know we can stop our
workspace so a lot of stuff here but I'm
going to go ahead and stop our current
workspace okay CU that's good enough for
me for now and we'll go back over to
GitHub let's take a look at what we have
in our
settings so we go here we go down to
code spaces and so we can have our
secrets here we can have settings sys
which just turned on and it doesn't seem
to ever work and we have some additional
options so we have access and security
this might be oh I guess it's no longer
here we can choose the default Editor to
launch in uh the idle time the host
image whether we want to use beta or
stable or manually set our region but it
seems like it autod detects but yeah
it's pretty straightforward but we'll
look at these features as we uh go
through this codes spaces section so
there you
[Music]
go let's take a look at the GitHub
codespaces life cycle there was no
diagram so I'm the first one to make one
uh if that's even that exciting but
usually the first thing that's going to
happen is you want to create your Cod
space and technically reopening is kind
of similar so we could say create or
reopen and from there we want to get our
codes space running once our codes space
is running uh we can stop it and of
course stopping it freezes the state of
your workpace so you can use it again
later and the idea is that if we wanted
to reuse it we just reopen it and it'll
run again if let's say our um code our
environment timed out for any reason
maybe we walked away from our computer
computer maybe we just forgot that we
forgot to turn it off maybe we had some
kind of interruption uh code spaces is
going to turn off by default after 30
minutes of activity um it's basically
the same thing as doing a a stop and
it's the equivalent um yeah it's the
equivalent of doing a stop there so this
is just to keep cost low for you um you
know if you want to make changes to your
Dev container file which is going to say
what your base images and stuff that's
installed you have to do a rebuild in
the current environment that's the only
way it's going to do do that if you're
launching up a codes space for the first
time it's going to build it from that
Dev container but sometimes you have to
do rebuilds uh the environment gets
saved periodically so generally you not
losing data so when you abruptly close
and then it stops it's persisting data
to the virtual machine as long as it's
not deleted but still assume that that
environment is uh possible to be lost I
think after a certain amount of time it
will actually delete um a repo after a
certain amount of days so just
understand that you know if it's
something really important make sure to
commit it and put it in a temporary
Branch or working Branch um it does
Autos saving so with the VSS code
browser it will autosave on by default
for vsod desktop Autos saave needs to be
turned on apparently but when I was
using it I never ran into any issues it
just seem to work uh when you're
deleting when you're done with your uh
your environment you can delete it uh
you don't have to delete it if you think
you're going to start it up again
because you're not uh having any spend
while it's deleted but there could be
some limit in terms of how many
workspaces you have or code spaces so
you might need to delete some but there
you
[Music]
go so when you create a code space it's
going to be assigned an autogenerated
display name and so in this case it made
shiny space chainsaw and sometimes when
you have a lot of um code spaces it gets
confusing what is the contents of those
codes spaces so it's totally possible
for you to rename uh your codes space
and that's just going to make things a
lot easier you can see all of those
codes spaces at/ codespaces and it'll
just make it a lot clearer
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and this
fall along we're going to take a look at
how to rename a GitHub codespace so
let's hope that we already have one here
so that we can rename it if you don't
you'll have to make a new one this one's
called shiny Cod not a great name not a
great a great name whatsoever but let's
go ahead and rename it and I'm going to
call this one uh just Dev okay and we'll
keep it right nice and simple here and
so now it's been renamed Dev and so
let's go take a look at our code spaces
so we can see the renaming of that so
it's not here I got to go back a little
bit and so now we can see all of our
code spaces and there it is so we have
our um our repo here and it's called Dev
and that is a lot better than before so
that's all I wanted to show
you
let's take a look at some vs code um
configurations in the context of GitHub
codes spaces so the idea is that GitHub
codes spaces should persist your vs code
settings so you get a similar
environment across code spaces so far I
haven't had that experience I have no
way of figuring out how to configure
that but it seems like it's supposed to
to work so if you figure it out please
tell me but I'll just pretend that it
does work somehow um if you've never
used vs code before there's this thing
called settings and it's a little bit
more complicated than that because all
this stuff that you're editing in the UI
is actually updating a settings. Json
file um it gets synced and backed up I'm
assuming on uh GitHub maybe it goes
somewhere else you can see there's a
backup and sync settings you can
override settings Json options in your
Dev container json. file let's take a
look at vs code extensions so GitHub
codes spaces should persist I use the
word should because again I'm not
getting it to work for me the idea is
that you can install your extensions um
most vs code Marketplace extensions are
available to install in the vs code
browser for GitHub code spaces you can
ensure your extensions reliable load
every time by setting them in the dev
container. Json we have vs code theme
this allows you to change the look of
your vs code um and you know this is a
personal choice of what you want to
choose but those kind of choices you're
not supposed to put in your Dev
container. Json fall for some reason um
but yeah there you
go
[Music]
there are two options or configuration
options you should know for GitHub code
spaces and that's timeout and retention
period um so timeout is how long code
spaces should wait to stop a code space
when there has been no activity you can
set this to be as low as 5 minutes up to
a maximum of 4 hours and the default is
30 minutes for default retention this is
saying when should we start deleting
your codes space if they are inactive
you could set it to a minimum of zero
days uh to a maximum of 30 days and the
default is 30 so play around these
values and figure out what works best
for
[Music]
you so there is an option called sync
settings for code spaces which will pull
your sync settings and the idea is it's
supposed to uh continually reset it so
vs code sync settings lets you share
your Visual Studio code configuration so
such as settings key uh key bindings and
assult extensions across your machines
so you are always working with your
favorite setup this has not worked so
far for me I don't know what I'm doing
wrong but um you know it is an option I
have it turned on in my account but uh
supposedly this is an offering uh that
is available for code
[Music]
spaces you can configure GitHub code
spaces to use dot files from a specific
repo that will be used for all feature
code spaces that you start so the idea
is you checkbox this on you specify the
repo it's going to pull the dot files
from this repo into all future code
spaces that you start up um GitHub
clones your selected do file repos to
the code space environment looks for one
of the following files to set up your
environment so we have install sh
bootstrap setup sh and a bunch of others
um so you can see that you could
probably offset some of the
configuration that would be in Dev
container into this as post boot scripts
um but yeah there you
[Music]
go codespace is deep link is just a way
for you to generate out a URL that will
launch a codespace for a specific repo
so here is a look at the actual URL it
says codesp spaces. new SL and then the
repo name but you can get this deep link
through dropping down the code Tab and
then you can get either the URL or HTML
or Mark up to make it really easy to
launch it and when you do launch it it's
going to bring you to the create a new
codespace uh workspace you can checkbox
the quick start if you want to skip that
but that's all it really is it's just a
sharable
[Music]
link so when you're using codes spaces
you might have uh environment variables
or uh passwords or Secrets or access
tokens that you don't want to hardcode
into your code because that's just a bad
habit uh it's just going to lead into uh
serious issues so you need to inject
them some way in environment when they
launch up from a secure location that is
what Cod spaces Secrets does so you can
see in this example we have eight of
those credentials and the idea it will
get get is that we'll get loaded in the
environment so we'll go take a look at
that
[Music]
okay hey this is angrew brown in this
video I want to take a look at how to
set secrets for code spaces so we'll go
to the repo there might be a few
different ways that we can set it what I
want to do is go first check if we can
do it this this way no but uh we can go
over to our settings and we'll check out
code spaces here on the left hand side
and from here if we scroll well it's
actually right up here we can create a
new secret and so let's just pretend
that we have a super secret we'll just
make up something here and we'll just
say
Roadhouse uh a bunch of numbers and then
a dollar sign and a net sign okay and we
can even say what repo it's for so it's
for the fun repo we're going to go ahead
and add that secret now let's go launch
up uh a code spaces and see if it's
available so I'm going to go back to
that
repo
and yeah we'll go back over
here we might already have one from
before I'm going to go ahead and delete
that and I'm just going to launch a new
one so that we are squeaky
clean and I'm not sure why it's giving
me all these options I just want to
launch one we'll go back over here we'll
try this again we'll say create one on
Main and we'll hope that that gets
loaded in so I'll be back here when this
is fully loaded okay all right so now
that our environment's up I'm going to
assume that those secets were loaded via
the environment variables so I'm just
going to bump up the font here for a
moment we're not going to spend too much
time in here and I'm going to type in
andv and actually we'll just hit enter
and see what we get so we have a bunch
environment variables that doesn't help
so much so I'm going to go back and type
in GP and we'll type in super and there
it is so we can now access that as an
environment variable I could code out if
I want super secret and there we go so
that's all I really wanted to show you
uh and I'll see you in the next one okay
so before I do that I'll just stop this
environment and yeah we'll see you now
[Music]
ciao so visual studio code Dev
containers allows you to configure your
Docker containers via Json file so you
can use this in code spaces you can use
this with vs code in general so the dev
container Json file is expected in the
root of your project and there's an
example of a very simple one let's go
look at some common configuration so you
can quickly understand how this file
Works um usually you want to provide a
remote image so this is the one um that
is I think being used for a base image
for Microsoft and a lot of the um
features that you can add to it uh you
can build your own images by supplying
the docker file in your project and
Supply it some arguments
uh there are features that allow you to
quickly install certain programs we did
this earlier um I think in our uh quick
and dirty um git crash course but the
idea is that we can install these
features so we can get quickly moving uh
and this is specifically for the common
base image if you want to create your
own features you totally could but it
has to be for your uh image you can also
uh configure custom programs you usually
put that in your Docker file um you
could also use the post crate command to
run a um shell script so there's a lot
of ways to um do Post configuration or
try to do something very similar and as
I said you can create your own features
to quickly install on top of your own
base images it is a lot of work to make
features though um setting settings
allow you to configure the settings of
vs code so that is a block that you can
put in there and you can see we also
have one for extension so it knows what
to install next time we can tell what
ports to always forward which is really
useful if you're running web servers we
have command Flags uh uh at or we can
pass command Flags to R uh Docker run
with the run args so that's something
that might be useful for you if you need
to pass environment variables you set
that in the container
EnV uh you can mount uh a bunch of
locations and then map the the files and
folders so we'll take a quick look here
at some of the options so we bind mount
a local directory Mount a Docker volume
for persistent storage Mount the docker
socket mount a specific file mount a
host directory as a read only okay um
the command that runs after creation is
the post create command you can set the
default username that a vs code should
use when connecting to the container you
can uh you could use the post create
command to install a bunch of programs
on top of your base uh container and
that's pretty much it so there is
obviously a lot that goes in with these
Dev containers I find them really hard
to configure I don't want to spend too
much time doing them uh and the exam's
not going to ask you about um uh this
stuff but for practic practicality we
should know it because if we're working
with code spaces or vs code it's
definitely something you're going to
come across but there you
[Music]
go let's take a look at how you would
change the shell for um GitHub codes
spaces so the idea is that uh vs the vs
code browser comes with bash fish zsh so
you do have a few options in order to
change your shells I usually just use
bash but um you know maybe you like
something else is there some way to get
power shell on there probably but I
didn't look into it and the way you
configure that is in your Dev container
so the idea is that uh let's say you
wanted to bring in one called uh cssh
and so you would specify the path of
where it is so this is CS CSH but you
know you might have to be very specific
where it is and then that way you can uh
uh have it in your profile profiles as a
drop down um notice that if you are
using um vs code for very specific OS
distributions then you can set the
default uh there um but yeah that's
about
[Music]
it the
github.com in
github.io page the other way is by
assembling the URL so you have
github.io followed by it
github.com so it's very limited in what
it can
[Music]
do so there's two things that look like
editors in GitHub and it's important
important that we distinguish between
the two because on the exam they'll
definitely ask you the differences
between them so for GitHub it is totally
free for code spaces you have a free
monthly quota but uh it can charge based
on storage or core hours per month and
this is usually based on that machine
type it'll increase the cost for
availability they're available to both
on github.com uh for startup it
instantly launches there's no Dev
container Json configuration for code
spaces it takes a few minutes and it
does load a Dev container Json on for
compute there is no attached compute you
can't run code or apps for code spaces
you have a dedicated attach VM you run
and debug your code and your apps uh
there's no terminal access for G
[Music]
github.com source is source code made
freely available for possible
modification and redistribution and you
might have heard of some of these open
source projects like Linux or git or
Docker or spark um a lot of times these
companies are really well utilized by a
very specific company that will have a
paid solution and it really does help
keep um the project going or help with
its mass adoption in the case of git uh
git is actually um managed by the Linux
foundation so it's not necessarily a
project that GitHub manages but GitHub
clearly makes a large um makes good use
of git so open source uh benefits
include things as encouraging Global
collaboration speeds up Innovation
offers adaptability and customization
reduces software costs enhances learning
for developers typically high quality
and uh things that are typically high
quality and reliable provides
transparency for trust and security and
open source software has often have free
community versions which make make it
easy for personal developers or small
organizations to quickly adopt
technology uh if you're looking at that
logo that's from The OSI or the open
source initiative which is a nonprofit
organization they are the steward of the
open source definition this is a set of
rules that help Define open source
software and uh one cool project that
they have is they maintain a list of
Open Source licensing documents and that
way you're able to take these documents
and quickly apply them to your projects
the top five most popular open source
licenses are MIT uh the new Public
public or the the new general public
license so GPL Apache
2.0 uh lesser general public license so
lgpl and the BSD license depending on
the license it determines whether
someone can re redistribute your code uh
as a commercial product or do they have
to alert you of how they're utilizing
the product or reference you there's all
different kinds of licenses and you can
pick one which works for your codebase
if you choose to make it open
[Music]
source GitHub sponsors allows GitHub
users to collect donations from their
GitHub hosted open source projects so
here you can see someone can sponsor the
octocat so I say projects but of course
you can directly do user accounts if
it's through patreon um sponsorship
payments um are facilitated two way
payments through GitHub on github.com
payments through patreon on github.com
and so you can set it up for a specific
repo to get your sponsor button um you
can connect your patreon via your
account settings I think to get that
Global one there uh to receive
sponsorship through GitHub on github.com
you need to be accepted into the GitHub
sponsors program I think this is
specifically for if you want GitHub to
collect the money on your behalf um you
have to apply for it and go onto a
waiting list you can do it for personal
accounts and organization
and you might have to provide uh well
you will have to provide banking
information in order to get paid GitHub
makes it easy to locate people who
maintain your dependency so you can
support open source contributions you
can go to fors sponsors exlore and it'll
tell you about uh the like the repos
that or sorry the dependencies that
you're using your project to suggest um
who you could sponsor uh that are
helping you out uh in that sense but
there you go
let's talk about GitHub and open source
projects um there is some kind of
statement that GitHub makes about open
source but I really couldn't figure out
what it is that they wanted me to put in
this course uh when I took the exam they
definitely had some kind of um uh PR
kind of language and saying what do you
think that uh is github's relationship
with open source so just do your best to
Guess that I really couldn't assemble it
here here so it's hidden in some kind of
PR content but let's talk about the
practicalities of how GI GitHub works
with open source uh one thing is that
when you create a repo you can choose a
license very easily I imagine that it's
from that OSI approved list and then
when you go to repo you can see the
license clearly displayed um and that
will be stored in that license.md that
could be license.md license or
license.md with all caps they'll all
work if you're looking to find open
source projects you can use the search
to search based on license
um there are many open source GitHub
repos that are hosted on GitHub um
because GitHub offers a lot of stuff for
free to uh good open source projects
some people will mirror their project so
maybe they don't host it primarily on
GitHub it they'll make a copy and
they'll sync it so that it has
redundancy of where it could be you can
use um uh you can explore under GitHub
topics and GitHub trending in the
community Pages uh to try to find open
source uh projects based on whether
they're popular or for specific
categories you can follow
organizations and um you can sponsor
organizations and so that might be one
way of doing that if you're utilizing
the GitHub Marketplace they have a bunch
of apps in here and a lot of these are
open source projects and you'll have uh
you'll be able to install them for free
so that is uh something else that is
really interesting um but yeah there you
go
hey this is Andrew Brown let's go take a
look and figure out what kind of Open
Source stuff we can find out on
github.com and one thing I think that
would be really important to check out
is the Community page um so I think it's
just here on the Explorer so on the left
hand side we'll go to explore we might
as well open up the marketplace as well
I mean the marketplace is good also for
apps um not just for open source but
there definitely is open store uh stuff
here so like if I go into here I'm not
sure if they have an open source license
but sometimes you go to plans and they
might tell you this one says free not
necessarily open source but there are
ones that are open source that we can uh
find but you do have to do a bit of
digging to find them I suppose anyway um
if we go to explore this is where we get
a kind of a community of information uh
you can see what's trending in terms of
repos and developers uh we have topics
over here where you can drill down into
specific things so if you like AWS you
can see all of uh these
here okay so that makes it pretty clear
in terms of
discoverability for trending we could
look for trending stuff as well over
here all right but you know primarily if
you're going to find open source stuff I
guess you'd have to search for it and
look based on the license so we can go
here and trying to expand our search but
maybe we say
license license I have a hard time
spelling that and so we can just choose
one here say MIT and just hit enter ENT
and it'll show us everything that is uh
under MIT license so that could be one
way that you could explore and try to
find things um but yeah hopefully that
gives you kind of an idea uh of you know
open source maybe we should take a look
and see what GitHub thinks they they
they want to say about open source
GitHub open source they probably have
some kind of statement where open source
Community lives a PR person definitely
wrote this um open source software is
free for you to use an explore all right
read our open source
guides
and yeah maybe there's something in here
that they would want us to know in the
course but it's just a lot of stuff you
know what I mean it's nobody wants to
read through all this but um yeah I mean
there's stuff in here so that's cool I
guess but yeah that's open source and
GitHub
okay
[Music]
inner source is organization and
development best practices for non-open
Source or proprietary software the term
was coined by Tim orali back in 2000 an
inner source is not a strict guideline
but a loose strategy to establish an
open source like culture within
organizations it was really really hard
really hard to figure out what this was
because they they when they say loose
they mean it's really loose um but uh
what I found to help make more sense was
to look at the free resources provided
by the inner Source commons. org where
they have a bunch of patterns that you
can use um to apply to your organization
to start to apply inner Source um and
yeah it's just to make sure you adopt
open source in a way that is great for
the community and your
[Music]
company all right let's make sure we
understand the difference between inner
Source versus open source so the scope
is a bit different inner sources is
within an organ organization remember
that word inner so if it's pointing
inwards we're talking about the org if
it's open source this is public and a
global Community um in terms of
accessibility in source is limited to
company employees where open source is
open to everybody for um purpose
intersource improves collaboration
efficiency internally whereas open
source shares and collaborates on
projects globally for contributions
employees of the organization is for
inner source and for open source it's
about anybody such as developers or
users for visibility in sources code
discussions often private to the
organization and open source publicly
available and visible for governance in
sources is based on the internal
policies and culture of the organization
and for open source it's usly governed
by open source licenses and Community
rules so there you
[Music]
go so forking a repo allows you to
create a copy of a repo and uh for
working allows you to take an open
source or Source available repo and Go
Your Own Way quickly apply bugs and
patch fixes a separate repo to work on
for Community contributions you can also
uh create cross repo repo poll requests
to get accepted into the original repo
when you Fork a repo you'll be able to
tell because it will say forked from the
location underneath if you need to
explore other Fork repos you can use the
network graph to find uh specific
commits to see the difference between
your repo and another one is at a glance
you may prefer using a forked repo over
the original you may find uh the
original project abandoned and a fork
becoming the go-to repo for a project
Forks help keep public projects alive uh
on the edge and collaborative so there
you
[Music]
go geta repos can be set as public
making repos easily searchable on GitHub
via search engines public repos serve a
community purpose for knowledge sharing
educational resources and open source
projects besides just search GitHub
curates content via community Pages such
as the explore page and the trending
page um GitHub provides a robust search
not uh that lets us not only search the
repo's name but the contents of the repo
as you can see in the advanced search we
have a lot of options for search uh
there is a search syntax where we can
utilize a lot of different um of these
little filters to find things very
quickly the search syntax also supports
regular Expressions wild cards not or
and multiple terms and more so there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown and this
follow along I want to take a look at
repository search as it probably will
appear on your exam to know how to
utilize this so what we'll do is just
type in rails and um I'm looking for all
results I'm going to click the one up
here because I want to get to this more
advanced search where we have a bunch of
options and where the exam might ask is
understanding how to compose a query so
you can see we have a lot of options uh
here and notice as soon as I click it
starts filling them in so um if we just
go here for a moment we can just take
out rails completely and we could try to
do something so we have public oh sorry
we'll go down here and try it down here
so we say public so is public is
something that we could do um we could
also specify based on topic
I'm not sure what we would put in for
topic let's go take a look and and see
what is
there so I'm not really seeing anything
for topic but what we could do we're not
exactly sure on all these parameters if
we go to advance search down below this
kind of basically gives us the same
stuff so if I was to search topic here
I'm really surprised I can't find what
topic is but let's go take a look and
see if that actually is something
because I'm really curious GitHub repo
topic um
with topics you can explore
repos okay so it looks like we can
actually categorize them in certain
ways I don't even know that let's go
over here ah yes topics here okay so I
guess the idea is that we can
classify our project based on a topic
and so maybe one could be Azure so we
could go back over to our search I was
kind of curious about that and we say
something like topic colon and then
Azure and then hit enter and so this
could narrow it down to Azure projects
maybe we can take out the rails term in
the front so we can kind of narrow down
exactly what it is we're looking for so
now we're getting kind of azure projects
we can put like loose search on the end
here so let's say we wanted to use bicep
which is something that Azure has we
could search it that way I'm kind of
curious about this topic option because
I didn't realize we could set topics so
let's go over to our repo and see if we
can set that so I'm going to go into our
fund repo we'll go into settings and I'm
looking for topics
so let's find that and the reason I'm
interested is because on my exam
actually topics came up and I wasn't
really aware of being able to set them
so yeah let's go see if there's some way
we can do
that um searching topics on the about
page it seems like we can set that so
I'm going to go back to my repo here and
we'll go here oh we have topics so I
could say fun which is not a real topic
but we could do that we could say uh
beginner and so that's going to provide
U topics that are uh really well known
and allow people to search for that so I
think that's pretty useful so you know
get some experience with the
discoverable uh or the the search
functionality and add some topics and I
think that'll be good enough
[Music]
okay GitHub labels are used to
categorize issues pull requests and
discussions and the way it works is you
can just apply multiple labels to your
targeted item and then it should show up
beside the item somewhere uh you can
manage your labels or create new labels
on the labels page for your repo and
creating a label is pretty simple it
just needs a name a description and a
color the GitHub CI provides commands
for labels so it is very easy to create
[Music]
labels Milestones allow you to group
multiple issues into an end goal which
shows completion towards that goal for
each closed issue so the idea is you can
make a new milestone you can assign
Milestones to it I'm just going to my
pen tool out here so you can see but the
idea is that as we uh close we get to a
completion so if we have one open one
Clos we're at 50% and when we're done
it's at 100% you can set a date um and
there you
[Music]
go hey it's Andrew Brown and this fall
along we want to create some custom
labels it's pretty straightforward but
uh I figured we should take a look at a
more popular repo and see what kind of
labels they're using if they've even
modified them at all so we're over here
on the rbon
rails um uh site and you can see we have
lots of labels and they're breaking it
Down based on uh sub packages and things
like that and I'm not sure what this is
it looks like maybe open issues you can
go here and filter out to that um
there's a lot of automation that you can
apply with labels um so when you create
issues you can have labels being
pre-assigned you could have uh pull
requests act a certain way based on the
labels it has so there's a lot you can
do with labels we're not going to show
you all those automation features but we
will show you how to create your own
labels which is pretty straightforward
so we'll go into our fund repo and we'll
go over to issues and we will create
some labels we'll make a new one here
called um
secret if we haven't already made one
before and I'll go ahead and just choose
a random color and boom we have our
secret label if we go over to our issues
we can then go ahead and ass
sign all sorts of labels super
easy so y there you go that's all you
need to know
[Music]
ciao hey everyone it's angrew brown and
this fall along we're going to take a
look at Milestones so what we'll do is
go to our fun repo and we'll have to
create a couple of issues I have one
here called what is the best movie ever
but then we can say what is the best
food
ever as our other ticket and then we can
figure out what that is later on but the
idea is that we want to put this into a
new Milestone so what we'll do is go
back to issues and we'll create
ourselves a new Milestone and we'll call
this um liveing life I don't I don't
know what to call this but we're going
to go ahead and call that um oh that was
another issue that wasn't a
milestone but that's fine we could
always use more Milestones here and
we'll create a new Milestone we'll say
true living okay and we could set a date
in the
future and date that we want to complete
this and I'm going to go back over to my
issues and I'm going to checkbox well
first all go into one and we can assign
the Milestone this way we can also Mass
assign probably this way as well if we
go
here by the way there's Mass assignment
for all these things for issues probably
good to know that and now if we go over
to our Milestone we have a percentage of
how complete it is so if we go back over
here
we can close a couple of these
okay
and if we go back over to our Milestone
we can see that we've made some progress
It's 66% complete I want to show you
maybe rails because I have a feeling
that they probably have Milestones a lot
of Open Source projects will have
Milestones to help you know when the
next version's coming out so if we go
over to issues here and go to Milestones
you can get an idea like when the next
version is and that's a really great use
case for Milestone so we can go in here
and see that they only have one more
ticket to get version 7.13 out um then
we have 8.00 and they have a bunch of
other stuff so it is quite interesting
how Milestones can be organized but
usually this is the use case uh that I
see but anyway we'll see you in the next
one okay
[Music]
ciao G up projects is a planning and
tracking tool when working on G UB repos
and a project has an adaptable view that
can be changed at any time between a
spreadsheet a taskboard and a road map
um so that's kind of the screen where
you choose what kind of view you want
projects directly integrate with issues
and poll requests projects have built in
workflows to automate common actions so
uh the idea is that a GitHub project is
composed of multiple views and you can
add more views to your project each
views layout can be changed at any time
to accommodate the project use case so
if you set set up a view you can change
it whenever you want uh so let's take a
look at what the table looks like so
this is a great uh layout if you want a
traditional uh ticket tracking system or
you have a large amount of tasks then we
have the board this is a great layout
for agile task and if you need to
understand clue the state of your issues
it's your basically can band board and
then we have road map this is great if
you're trying to plan for uh uh tasks
based on a timeline we call these
normally um
Gant charts so that's kind of what that
is there for your layout you can
configure your data based on multiple
options so we got Fields columns Group
by sort by field sum slice by zoom level
and dates I'm not reading through all
this because I didn't see it on the exam
so uh you know these are pretty
straightforward and you can read these
if you want but um yeah so your GitHub
project items have custom Fields you can
create new fields and add uh and provide
options to easily fill in those those
fields and I mean that's pretty much the
start of it but there we
[Music]
go let's talk about GitHub projects
versus GitHub project classic as this
might end up as an exam question and to
avoid any confusion if you somehow end
up creating a classic project so GitHub
projects are new more Dynamic interfaces
with tables board and Views uh classic
just has a can band board style thing
like Trello um GitHub projects are
highly customizable different views and
Fields the classic is limited
customization options uh there is
apparently more automation support in
the new projects whereas the old one was
simpler the new projects has enhanced
reporting features and insights whereas
classic has basic reporting and tracking
uh GitHub projects has deeper
integration with GitHub issues and poll
requests whereas Classics has basic
integration with GitHub repos GitHub
projects offers more advanced and
flexible project management tools
compared to GitHub classic projects
which is simpler and more
straightforward there's no reason to
ever use class unless it's for legacy
reason but yeah there you
[Music]
go GitHub has built-in project workflows
that allows you to automate what happens
based on specific events in your
projects so you have this
workflows um area like I think you do
the ellipses and you get to workflows
and from there you can uh basically
change some Behavior so when here it
says when a pull request is merg you
could say set the value or the status as
being being done for this particular
field there are the following built-in
workflows item added to project item
reopened item closed code changes
requested code review approved pull
request merged Auto archived items Auto
add to project and for the exam they
will definitely definitely ask you which
are some built-in workflows I do not
like that question but it's in the exam
so make sure you remember the so that
you can get an extra point on your exam
uh for more advanced automation of
GitHub projects you can use GitHub
actions and there you
[Music]
go project insights lets you create
charts about your GitHub projects and
there are two charts that they want you
to know the first is current charts and
the second one is historical charts so
current charts is basically you take a
value and you can plot it as a chart the
historical charts is you take values and
you plot them over time the exam will
definitely ask you about what are the
two types of um charts so make sure
remember that it's current charts and
historical charts there you
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown and in this
follow I want to take a look at uh
GitHub projects and by the way I'm not
sure if it's picking up but I'm in my
snowsuit because it's so darn cold in my
office because it's winter and my
furnace isn't working so if you hear
like scratchy sounds it's because I'm
wearing a fullblown uh heavyduty
snowsuit okay and you might hear them in
other videos but I just wanted to point
that out if that you know if you're
wondering what that sound is but anyway
let's go take a look at our fun repo and
from here I want to make our way over to
projects and we'll create ourselves a
new project I would like this to get out
of the way and um I'm going to go ahead
and create a new project I should note
that um a project can um
contain uh tasks and issues from other
projects but for the most part I I'd
rather make a new one here and so it's
just keeps giving me this darn pop get
out of the way and so we can choose from
a bunch of different templates um I'm
going to choose Team Planning because
that sounds really good and right away
we're going to get a bunch of views
across the top so we got our backlog we
can go ahead and add an item I'll just
say uh watch
Roadhouse and write a a
review okay and so we'll go ahead and do
that and this is a draft so it's not
really an issue yet it's kind of like in
limbo but you can convert this to an
issue and put it in the repo and now I
can drag it around and move into other
states which is really nice we can go up
here to backlog if we don't like the
board we can change it to a table this
allows us to drop things down in a very
nice and easy way it gives us some uh
default parameters that came with this
project we can go to road map if we want
to and we could say need to do it
between this time and that time for the
scope of our project not super
complicated I don't know how this stuff
works I fiddled with it it wasn't doing
what I thought it was going to do but
I'll change this back to a board um we
could go and generate at a chart which
is going to be in Project insights
understand there's two types of charts
current charts and historical charts and
this one looks like it's a current one
so it's not over time and how you would
have it in time I have no idea um oh up
here so I guess these are the types of
layouts we can have so that's pretty
cool um so we change that to line or bar
or sacked bar uh we can go ahead and hit
new chart and I'm trying to figure out
how do we get historical
charts because I thought it'd be like
you choose one or the other
but doesn't seem like it's that way it
seems like you probably have to group it
by something or you'd have to have it
based on the
timeline like iter or something so yeah
I'm not exactly sure how you create the
historical chart I don't think it really
matters um again this is GitHub
foundations we just need to get some
familiarity with projects if we go up
here in the top right corner um we can
get this drop down to get over to our
workflows and again I'm going to go
through these with you so we have item
added to project item reopened item
closed you can see there's a couple
already sets so when we have an item
closed it's going to set the value as
done okay so if I go back over to this
issue okay and we close
it it should get moved to done there we
go so see how that automatically moved
to done and that's because of that
workflow here and so we have some other
ones that we could set up if we want we
could edit them but these are very very
simple as you can see they're very
straightforward uh we can go to settings
and in settings you can see we have our
custom Fields you can add them change
the field type to a very specific comp
so if you want to say I want to collect
the date you could have that there and
we call this Roadhouse date which makes
no sense but we can do that we go back
to our settings we can go to our
ticket okay and click it and we can now
set our Roadhouse date so yeah hopefully
that makes sense but it's pretty darn
straightforward and that is GitHub
projects
[Music]
when commenting on issues or pull
requests you can add a save reply that
you already have set up previously and
so if you go to the save replies icon uh
you can then go choose run and this is a
great way to have like canned responses
um I'm sure there are benefits for this
it's pretty obvious it saves your time
but uh yeah that is a functionality that
you can do uh there for uh replying to
comments
okay
[Music]
I just want to explicitly point out that
you can assign issues and poll requests
to specific users right uh you can
filter issues and PRS based on assignes
and I just wanted to make that call out
because in the exam guide they wanted to
call it out and I figured I should make
a simple slide there so there you
[Music]
go so securing your account using 2fa uh
normally it's called MFA but for
whatever reason they're just calling it
2fa cuz it is really only two- Factor
authentication this is where you use a
secondary device such as a phone to
enter a code in as a extra security
precaution when sign in or performing
sensitive actions and so you can choose
your preferred UFA method on GitHub
which could be between GitHub Mobile SMS
text message or the authenticator app um
we have all these options for two-factor
authentication so you can use
authenticator app like aie which we did
use in uh when setting up our account a
lot earlier you have Google
Authenticator Microsoft authenticator
I'm sure there's other ones we could use
text messaging we could use a security
key like a UB key which is a physical
piece of Hardware we can use GitHub
mobile which we absolutely do we can
have recovery codes which is something
that is just a backup in case you get
totally locked out of your account and
you need to enter those codes in but
there you
[Music]
go personal accounts has two permission
levels the first is the reposit to owner
owner repository owner I can say it the
person who owns the account that would
be you and the repositories owned by
personal accounts have one owner the
ownership can uh permissions cannot be
shared with another personal account for
collaborators these are people you add
as collaborators I cannot tell you how
many times I did this slide that's the
best I can do it so we'll just live with
the way I said that um so let's go
through the type of permission that
repository actions have they can invite
collaborators they can change the
visibility of repos limit interactions
with repos rename the branch including
the default Branch they can merge a pull
request on a protected Branch even if
there are no approving reviews they can
delete the repo they can manage the repo
topics they can manage security and
Analysis settings for the repo they uh
they can enable the dependency graph for
a private repo delete and restore
packages customize the repo social media
preview create a template from the repo
control access to dependabot alerts
dismiss dependent bot alerts in the repo
manage data use for a private repo
Define code owners for the repo archive
the repo create security advisories
display a sponsor button allow or
disallow Auto merge for poll requests
yes there's a lot of things here I
realize this is tiring manage deploy
Keys manage web hooks let's take a look
at what collaborators can do Fork the
repo rename a branch other than the
default Branch create and edit delete on
commits pull request issues in the repo
create assign close and reopen issues in
the repo manage labels for issues and
pull requests in the repo manage
milestones for issues and pull requests
in the repo mark an issue or pull
request in the repo as a duplicate
create and merge close pull requests in
the repo enable disable auto merge for a
pull request apply suggested changes to
pull requests in the repo create a poll
request from a fork of the repo submit a
review of a poll request that affects
the merab ility of the poll request
create an edit a Wiki for the repo
create an edit releases for the
repo ask as a code owner for the repo
publish view or installs packages
removes themselves as collaborators on
the
repo okay so that's a lot to remember so
just remember this
repo owners have full control of the
repo collaborators can pull such as read
the contents of the repo and push right
changes of the repo there you go
[Music]
ciao Enterprise managed users also known
as emus allow you to manage the life
cycle and authentication of users on
github.com from an external identity
management system or IDP GitHub partners
with some Developers of identity
management systems to provide a pay path
integration with emus U the
idps yeah idps mostly provide
authentication using saml they can use
Microsoft entra ID previously known as
azuread and also offers oidc for
authentication the IDP applications
Provisions users with systems for cross
doain identity management s
cim and I'm going to just tell you on my
exam I got so many darn questions about
this and I have no idea why but anyway
for partner idps you can use Microsoft
entra ID formally known as azuread okta
and pig Federate they all support samle
uh only oid is supported by Microsoft
entra ID and then you have
SIM now when I say I got questions of
the exam it wasn't specifically which
partner provided what IDP but it was
more just understanding that enterprises
have this functionality of of having SCM
and O oidc and was it between Enterprise
uh server and Enterprise Cloud okay um
there we
[Music]
go hey this is Andrew Brown and this
fall along I want to focus a little bit
on security as I feel that uh the
security section here is a little bit
light and maybe by looking at some of
the security stuff it might help us on
the exam because they do asking about
like these scanning things and so I'm
hoping that if we look at them you'll
remember them so we have dependabot code
scanning and secret scanning this is a
public repo so we have these options
here and uh we have private
vulnerability reporting let's see if we
can turn that on what happens it's a
beta feature let's turn it on can we
turn it on it's on there we go can we
turn on dependabot alerts let's do it it
is
on and then we have code scanning so
code scanning is a little bit more work
it has code ql anal analysis is it easy
to set up let's do the default and it
says we're using Ruby and we'll enable
code ql so all those scans are now set
up it was as simple as that I don't
think it's going to cost me anything
additional because it's a public
repo okay and so now those are
enabled I thought this one was enabled
because we turned it on but maybe not
secret scanning would be something that
would be really good so let's go ahead
and try that out secret scanning let's
enable that as well and boom there you
go you got all that stuff in place it's
no more complicated than that we do also
see secrets and uh variables here so it
looks like it kind of uh bring brings
them all into one place so we sought for
code spaces but I guess GitHub actions
can have secrets as well dependabot can
have secrets as well looks like the same
kind of functionality across the board
for all of these we were basically just
looking at code security analysis so you
know that's that we can go over to our
settings over here maybe they have a
security tab over here uh um yeah they
got this it looks like the same thing
more or less maybe from a Global
Perspective it says push protection for
yourself block commits that contains uh
supported Secrets across all repos that
sounds really good I'm going to turn
that on but uh yeah just remember those
three things the secret scanning uh did
I say three things let's go back and
make sure it's just those three whatever
they were we'll go back here dependabot
code scanning and secret scanning
remember those three scanners
[Music]
okay hey this is Andrew Brown and this
follow I want to take a look at what
kind of permissions we have for
organizational accounts I was trying to
make a slide on this but I was getting
um M mix match information maybe because
there used to be an old way of doing it
now there's a new way and so it was
really confusing so this doesn't really
work but I figured what we could do is
just look at the organization and see
what we have for options it didn't mess
me up on the exam but I still think that
we should take a look and see how um
those kind of permissions work uh
for uh organizations so here I'm in an
organization we have collaborators and
teams and notice that we can set
different roles so we have admin
maintain write triage and read and if we
want to have custom roles we would have
to have GitHub Enterprise that's the
only way that we're going to get it so
hopefully that is pretty darn clear I
don't know what else to say about it
it's pretty darn
straightforward um but uh there could be
a bit more but I don't know so I just
wanted to show you that very quickly
[Music]
okay so within a GitHub repo we can
manage multiple features by enabling or
disabling them such as wikis issues
sponsorships preserve uh the repo which
goes into the GitHub Arctic code Vault
discussions projects and possibly more I
just got to point this out because it's
in uh the section for GitHub and
administrator and so uh for the GitHub
foundations course and so I had to
explicitly call out these particular
features and there we
[Music]
go let's take a look at repo permission
levels and so when you're a collaborator
and they accept an invite you can choose
from predefined roles with different
levels of access the first is read which
allows you to view and clone the repo
open and comment on issues and pull
requests and download releases we have
triage which manages issues pull
requests without WR access label and
assign issues and P requests close and
reopen issues emplo requests we have
maintain this allows you to push the
repo manage issues pull request labels
and project boards create and publish re
releases configure repo settings for
non-sensitive fields we have admins
which basically have full control and
Enterprises allow for custom rules
[Music]
okay Branch protection rules are used to
enforce certain workflows or
requirements before changes can be
merged into a branch you can find that
under the uh Branch tab in your GitHub
repo and so here we could apply a banch
uh Branch protection rules there's a lot
of stuff that we can do here we can
require a poll request before merging
require status checks to pass before
merging require conversation uh
resolution before merging require sign
commits required linear history required
deployment to succeed before merging
lock branch do not allow bypassing the
above settings and for admins we can
allow Force push allow deletions on the
exam they might ask you what kind of uh
Branch protection rule you can do I
don't think it's a very fair question
because I can never remember all of
these but
unfortunately it might show up in your
exam and if you don't want to lose a
point make sure you remember generally
what things you can do with Branch
protection rules
[Music]
okay so there is a security Tab and this
is for your repo and it basically acts
as a security check list if you are um
not the owner you're going to see
something else like the actual security
policy and some information about
vulnerabilities in the repo but security
policy is one thing that it will suggest
uh for you to create which is a markdown
fall on how security vulnerability
should be reported we have security
advisories which privately discusses fix
and publishes information I think
they're deprecating this feature um
except for open source public repo so it
might not be something that uh is used
uh much in the future uh we have private
vulnerability reporting allow your
community to privately report potential
security vulnerabilities to maintainers
and repos basically a form to tell you
about vulnerabilities I think this is in
beta right now uh we have dependabot
alerts so a bot that alerts you of
vulnerabilities due to out-of-date
dependencies dependabot can
automatically create PRS to update
dependencies for you to approve we have
code scanning alerts automatically
detect common vulnerabilities and coding
errors via code ql and third party tools
and then we have secret scanning Alerts
get notified when a a secret is pushed
to a
[Music]
repo collaborators allow uh you to let
other GitHub users have access to your
repo based on the permission levels you
provide so you can search based on
username across everybody it'll tell you
whether they I actually I don't know if
it'll tell you if they're external but
the point is you can search for them and
then you can add them the idea is that
you'll get an invitation you have to
accept the invitation um at the
invitation address I strong recommend
that you tell people um to go accept it
because it's not the best at alerting uh
other people and then sometimes it just
times out or expires so that's kind of a
pain so just make sure you keep on top
of your invitations
[Music]
okay an organization can group uh
organization members into teams and so
that's an example of having a core team
um you can set the VIS visibility
between uh secret and visible that will
definitely be an exam question that I
got so make sure you remember that teams
can be assigned to projects and issues
uh uh request reviews from teams or
request reviews from teams yep teams can
be mentioned in discussions issues and
pull requests control team access to
repos and new members can be added to
teams instantly giving them access to
all relevant repos and discussions so
the idea is that if you add people to a
team you have uh ways of delegating out
a bunch of um responsibilities and
things like that so there you
[Music]
go GitHub connect enhances GitHub
Enterprise servers by allowing your ghes
instance to access some of the
github.com cloudon offerings so the idea
is that because you are self-hosting
there's just functionality that lives in
the cloud and so this is their way of
bringing some of it to you what kind of
functionality are we talking about well
that is the automatic user license sync
dependabot github.com actions which I'm
not sure what that means but oh probably
GitHub actions it's cuz the Dooms in
there it's confusing server statistics
unified search and unified contribution
so the key thing I want to remember is
that GitHub connect is specifically for
the Enterprise server Edition and it's
to uh bring certain features uh to your
self-hosted version from the cloud
okay
[Music]
so GitHub Enterprise Cloud accounts have
a third special GitHub repo which is
called internal and so what this
internal GitHub repo does it allows all
Enterprise members to have read
permissions in the internal repo
internal repositories are not visible to
people outside of the Enterprise
including outside collaborators on
organization repos unless uh your
Enterprise uses emus members of the
Enterprise can Fork any internal repos
owned by an organization in the
Enterprise and internal repos are the
default setting for all new repositories
created in an organiz organization owned
by an Enterprise account so all I want
you to know is that there is these
things called internal repos they're
only for Enterprise Cloud are they on
the server one I don't think so but in
the docs they said it was for cloud and
then when I looked up a different
feature in Enterprise it said it was
only for cloud but was for both so um
yeah I would just say remember that
there's just third option for Enterprise
or Enterprise cloud and you'll be in
good shape and get another point on your
exam
[Music]
okay so GitHub makes extra security
features available to customers under a
GitHub Advanced security license and
these GitHub Advanced security is
available for Enterprise accounts on
GitHub Enterprise Cloud GI GitHub
Enterprise servers and some of the
features are available for public
repositories on GitHub I'm not sure I
have of four in there I guess it's just
a little muck up there so that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense I can barely
get to my pen tool um but anyway uh the
features that they're talking about is
code scanning secret scanning dependency
review and So based on uh whether you're
a public repo or you're a private repo
without advanced
security you're going to have different
access so for public repos you get full
access for private repos without the
advanced security license you get
nothing and if you have the advanced
security you get them all what's
confusing about uh this one in
particular is um it says some of the
features for public repost so it makes
me think there's more than three
features I could not find more other
than the three listed uh maybe if I made
an Enterprise account and contacted
support that I could figure that out but
um that is a lot of work especially for
a foundation's course so just know that
there is a GitHub GitHub Advance
security license and remember those
three components and those are the same
things that we basically kind of saw in
the um in the uh uh the security tab
right with all the scans and dependency
review I'm going to assume is dependabot
okay uh but there you
[Music]
go let's quickly talk about saml and Sim
these are both available for GitHub
Enterprise cloud and GitHub Enterprise
server um just remember that these are
features specifically to Enterprise and
just have a general understanding the
difference between the to so saml stands
for security assertion marketable
language it is an open standard for
exchanging authentication authorization
between an identity provider and a
service provider it's an important use
case for saml is single sign on Via the
browser if you don't know what single
sign on is it's where you use one
account to log in and then you're logged
in everywhere else and so if you want to
have single sign on the mechanism
they're using here is saml then you have
SIM so this is stands for system of
cross domain identity management it's an
open standard for automating the
exchange of user identity information
across different identity management
systems a key use for SCM is to enable
scalable and automated user provisioning
and de-provisioning often integrated
with Enterprise identity
Services I know that's a mouthful but I
got a simpler summary for you here samle
is about securely transmitting user
authentication and authorization data
for single signon purposes and Sim is
about managing user identities across
different systems to simplify account
maintenance provisioning so if you
remember those two at the bottom you'll
know what they are um they didn't really
ask at least I didn't get any questions
that had to distinguish between the two
it was more so you know where are these
features available and it was for both
the Enterprise cloud and Enterprise
server um and one other thing I want to
just note is that these two uh these two
things can complement each other in the
same ecosystem because they're doing two
different things um serving two
different purposes so just understand
that they Co co-mingle um and this is
for Enterprises
[Music]
okay hey this is Angie Brown and this
follow along I want to show you how to
register um or book your uh GitHub
certification exam so what you're going
to want to do is go to the GitHub
certifications page and you can do that
by typing in
G.I certifications and it should bring
you uh generally here I've never done
this booking before so we're going to
learn together but it should wouldn't be
too hard and the first thing we'll want
to do is register I want to point out
that if we go down below we can see our
certifications and get additional
information but I'm going to go ahead
and register here and I actually already
have registered and the process is
connecting your GitHub account um to
here so my steps might be slightly
different but more or less it's the same
so you might have a page where it's
going to pop up it's going to show you
that you have to confirm um a connection
and go ahead and do that and you should
end up in here and so so here is where
we're going to see um uh our exams and
so we have GitHub actions GitHub
administrator advaned security and
Foundations I'm interested in the
foundations one so I'm going to go ahead
and click into that and just understand
that this price may change based on um
you know based on uh if they change the
price down the road but right now it's
price is 99 USD because there this exam
is so new at the time I'm shooting this
video it actually has a discount of $49
so you might not get that um it might
just be $999 USD which is still very
affordable but just understand that uh
you know different times means different
results let's go ahead and schedule this
exam it's through PSI so if you've ever
done the PSI exam that'll be pretty
straightforward so we'll go ahead and
schedule and take our exam and we have
information to fill out so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go through
all of this and fill up my information
and click this button and then I'll show
you the next steps I just don't want to
expose of the information so I'll see
you back here in just a moment
okay all right so I click through there
and and now it's going to want me to um
accept the uh PSI test taker site to my
GitHub account I'm going to go ahead and
authorize this I'm just going to stop
and start again just because I'm not
sure if it's going to show personal
information I don't really feel like uh
um admitting it so I'm just trying to do
that so I'll be back here in just a
moment I'm going to head go ahead and
click that green button there we go and
it's brought us over to the PSI online
store so this is a familiar experience
at least for me let's go take a look at
and see the uh available tests um you
know sometimes there are tests that are
online or are on site these days
everything is both uh right right now I
cannot take these ones I'm not exactly
sure as to why as I'm pretty sure the
other ones did not have prerequisites
but maybe GitHub changed it and you need
to have the foundations before you take
these ones that's totally fine I'm just
click into this and see why that is the
test requires author from the test
sponsor so maybe since it's so new at
this time it's not going to allow me to
do this or it could be that it is a
prerequisite there but what we'll do is
go back here and click on the
foundations and notice that we have 99
USD I'm going to go ahead and continue
booking actually going to click back
there because I think there was a deal
you're pre-approved uh you're eligible
for this exam until
31224 not exactly sure why I chose that
message that's totally fine so we have
online proctored and on site I'm going
to go ahead and go to continue booking
um we have some information here uh
please don't call me it doesn't go to me
uh just annoying okay so do not call my
phone number we'll go ahead and hit
continue I might even go WR that out so
it's less of an issue for me I'm going
to go ahead
and type in Canada I am in Toronto time
so going go ahead and type in Toronto
that's uh Us East uh standard um and
we'll go ahead and hit find and so now
I'm looking for an available time that I
wish to book um so I mean I could book
it today that seems a bit
crazy um do I want to do that am I crazy
enough to do that today um
maybe yeah you know what I think I'm
going to do it I'm going to book my um
uh mine tonight for 900 p.m. I know that
sounds really crazy but I'm going to do
it we'll go ahead and choose 9:00 p.m.
make sure your time is correct you're
going to have an issue there I'm going
to book this time slot and now I need to
fill in my additional information I just
happen to have a velure code here I'm
just understand that you know you may or
may not have it but I just happen to
have it because I'm lucky we're going to
go ahead and fill in the arrest of
information continue on if the review
information has personal information I
might not show it um but uh we're almost
there so I'll be back in just a moment I
just want to quickly show that you have
two options credit card and PayPal so
I'm going to go ahead and enter my
credit card in I'm just going to go
ahead and do that I'll see you back in a
moment all right so yeah here is my
confirmation I'm going to go ahead and
purchase this so it looks to be good
make sure you confirm the time and make
note of the time that you have to
complete it as that is very important um
again to today is February 1st where I
am so that is the correct date I'm going
to go ahead and click
purchase and now my uh booking is
confirmed it's probably a great idea to
print your confirmation a lot of times
you have to prep your environment so
make sure you uh set up your remote
online Proctor uh system and do your
checks prior to this so if you click
that it should install an app on your
computer um really make sure you do that
ahead of time with these exams you
should always have two pieces of
government IDs so think passport and
driver's license the reason I just tell
you to have both of them is in case one
is giving you a problem um so just make
sure you have both on hand you really
only need one but if you go to an
inperson uh place they might want to
have two pieces of government ID maybe
one that's uh you know sometimes it can
be health card but mostly it's driver's
license passport um it's going to vary
per country but uh yeah uh give me good
luck on my exam and I'll talk to you
soon out